THIS MEETING THIS
HEARING AS A NOW IN SESSION
WITH THE MEMBERS OF BUDGETS OF
FOUR PLEASE COME TO ROOM FOUR
THREE SEVEN GOOD AFTERNOON
WELCOME TO SUBCOMMITTEE FOUR ON
STATE ADMINISTRATION I HAVE
BEEN ASKED TO READ SOME
DIRECTIONS REGARDING PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION IN TODAY'S
HEARING TO HELP ENSURE THE
SAFETY OF EVERYONE HERE TODAY
WHILE ALLOWING FULL PUBLIC
ACCESS TO THE DISCUSSION. AT
TODAY WE ARE IN ROOM FOUR
THIRTY SEVEN WE ARE HAVING A
PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN PERSON
HEARING WE ARE IN ROOM FOUR
THIRTY SEVEN AGAIN AND CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE A FEW MEMBERS A
MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF STAFF.
AND A LIMITED NUMBER OF THE
PUBLIC AND MEDIA SO WE CAN KEEP
SIX FEET OF SPACING. THERE ARE
ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCE
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL AND
FOR THOSE HERE TODAY TO MAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT. AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I WILL
RESTATE THIS ONE PUBLIC COMMENT
BEGINS BUT IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WISH TO
SPEAK THEY WILL RAISE THEIR
HANDS AND I WILL ASK THEM TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. I
WOULD ASK THAT THE PUBLIC
RESPECT THIS AGO DISTANCING AND
DO NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE
YOU'LL HAVE ONE MINUTE FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. YOU CAN EXIT
THE HEARING ROOM ONCE YOUR
PUBLIC COMMENT IS DONE OR
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT. BUT PLEASE
OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISTANCE UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL INCLUDING.
LIMITING ELEVATOR USED TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. THE PALACE ON
THE AGENDA AN ALLEY- ARE
APPEARING REMOTELY USING ONLINE
TECHNOLOGY THERE WILL BE NO
VOTE IN TODAY'S COMMITTEE. WE
ARE ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENT AT
THE END OF THIS HARING BOTH IN
THE HEARING ROOM AND ON THE
PHONE THE PHONE NUMBER TO
CONNECT IS ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND SHOULD BEALSO ON
THE SCREEN IF YOU ARE WATCHING
OVER THE INTERNET. THE NUMBER
IS TOLL FREE. 877-692-8957 THE
PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS FOUR
THREE SEVEN ONE THREE. ONE
FIVE. IF YOU ENCOUNTER ANY
PROBLEMS PLEASE CONTACT THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE AT.
916-319-2099 AND A STAFF MEMBER
WILL ASSIST YOU. WE ENCOURAGE
THE PUBLIC TO PROVIDE WRITTEN
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE HEARING
PLEASE SEND OVER YOUR WRITTEN
TESTIMONY TO BUDGET SUB FOR.
THAT THE BUDGET SUB IN THE
NUMBER FOR BUDGETS UP FOR AT
ASM DOT C. A. DOT G. OVIH. WE
HAVE NINE DEPARTMENTS WITH
SEVENTEEN ISSUES TO BE
DISCUSSED TODAY WE WILL TAKE
MEMBER QUESTIONS AFTER EACH
ISSUE WITH PUBLIC COMMENT AT
THE END OF THE HEARING. AND SO
LET'S BEGIN THE FIRST ISSUE
BEING- WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
CANNABIS CONTROL. FOR OUR FIRST
PANEL WE WILL HEAR A PROPOSAL
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION TO
CONSOLIDATE THE THREE AGENCIES
THAT LICENSE CANNABIS
ACTIVITIES. OUR PANELISTS TODAY
INCLUDE KIMBERLY HARBISON WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THROUGH SADDAM BURKE WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
AND THE FOLLOWING INDIVIDUALS
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION WILL BE
AVAILABLE FOR Q. NA TOMORROW
COLSON. TAYLOR SHIP MELISSA I'D
SENT AND RUSSIA SOME SELAMA.
LET'S BEGIN ARE THE PANELISTS
WERE TO GO. LET'S CHECK IN WITH
THE ROOM. WE CAN BEGIN SO LET'S
A WE HAVE A MS HARBISON AND
MISTER SADDAM BURKE. WE CAN
HEAR YOU YOU MAY BE ON ME. WHAT
ARE. OKAY WE'RE HAVING A- MS
HARBISON WE'RE HAVING A LITTLE
BIT OF TECH ISSUE SO CAN I JUST
HAVE YOU COUNT FROM ONE TO TEN
AS WE TRY TO FIGURE OUT THE
AUDIO. WE STILL CAN'T HEAR YOU.
IS THAT IN HERE IS THAT HER.
SHE'S NOT. MAYBE FIVE POINT
WHERE I THINK I NEED TO PRESS
THE BUTTON LET'S START AGAIN. I
WANT TO OKAY GREAT THEY MIGHT
MY YEARS IN RADIO HAVE PREPPED
ME FOR THIS MOMENT RIGHT HERE.
OKAY SORRY ABOUT THAT GO AHEAD.
NO PROBLEM GET AFTERNOON HERE
FOR YOU AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND KIMBERLY HARBISON
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
AND I'M JOINED BY MEMBERS OF
THE FINANCE TEAM AS WELL AS
COLLEAGUES FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS PUBLIC
HEALTH AND FOOD AND AGRICULTURE.
THANK YOU FOR INVITING US HERE
TODAY TO TALK WITH YOU ABOUT
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
TO CONSOLIDATE THE LICENSING
AND REGULATORY OVERSIGHT
FUNCTIONS. OF COMMERCIAL A
COMMERCIAL CANNABIS ACTIVITY IN
CALIFORNIA INTO A SINGLE
DEPARTMENT. THE PROPOSAL
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET WILL CREATE THE
DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS CONTROL
WITHIN THE BUSINESS CONSUMER
SERVICES AND HOUSING AGENCY.
EFFECTIVE JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. CREATING ONE POINT
OF CONTACT WILL BETTER SERVE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS LICENSES AND
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS BY MAKING
SURE THEY RECEIVE CONCISE AND
CONSISTENT GUIDANCE FROM THE
STATE. THE PROPOSAL AIMS TO
SIMPLIFY PARTICIPATION IN THE
LEGAL MARKET AND SUPPORT THE
SUCCESSFUL AND SAFE OPERATION
OF CANNABIS BUSINESSES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE LAW.
ESTABLISHMENT OF A SINGLE
DEPARTMENT WILL REMOVE
REDUNDANCIES PARTICULARLY
AROUND LICENSING AND COMPLIANCE
PROCESSES. AND THIS IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE LICENSING IS
PROVING TO BE A CHALLENGING
BARRIER TO ENTRY. FOR SMALL
BUSINESS OPERATORS AS WELL AS
VERTICALLY INTEGRATED COMPANIES.
FIXING ENFORCEMENT UNDER ONE
DEPARTMENT WILL NEED TO APPROVE
YOU FOR SOME COORDINATION AND
CREATE OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE
STATE'S MORE EFFECTIVELY APPLY
ITS RESOURCES. BUT TO BETTER
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH SAFETY
AND LANDS SIMPLIFY PARTNERSHIPS
WITH LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES AND ULTIMATELY MAKE IT
MORE COSTLY AND INEFFICIENT TO
PARTICIPATE IN IT ILLICIT
CANNABIS INDUSTRY. WE KNOW THAT
A STRONG LOCAL MARKET AND LOCAL
PARTICIPATION REDUCES THE
ILLEGAL MARKET HAVING ONE
DEPARTMENT WILL SIMPLIFY THE
STATE'S ADMINISTRATION
REGULATING CANNABIS AND THIS
WILL A LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. IN
UNDERSTANDING THE STATE
FRAMEWORK AND BEING MORE
WILLING TO ADOPT THAT FRAMEWORK
IN THE RESPECTIVE LOCALITIES.
ONE OF THE FIRST TASK OF THE
NEW DEPARTMENT WILL BE TO
HARMONIZE. WITH THREE SETS OF
EXISTING REGULATIONS INTO ONE.
OPERATING OFF OF ONCE THAT WILL
MAKE IT EASIER FOR INDUSTRY. TO
NAVIGATE AND THE STATE WILL
HAVE A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF
THE IMPACTS OUTCOMES OF THE
STATE REGULATORY EFFORTS REMOTE
MORE UNIFORM DATA COLLECTION
AND ANALYSIS. THIS WILL INVOLVE
CONSOLIDATION RECONCILIATION
AND STREAMLINING WHERE
APPROPRIATE. WHAT CREATES THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THE NEW
DEPARTMENT LARGELY BY MOVING
POSITIONS IN FUNDING THAT ARE
CURRENTLY SUPPORTING THE THREE
EXISTENCE EXISTING STATE
CANNABIS LICENSING ENTITIES TO
THE NEW DEPARTMENT ON JULY
FIRST. WE HAVE IDENTIFIED THE
ACTIVITIES OF THE THREE CURRENT
LICENSING AUTHORITIES CAN. IN
THEM UNDER NINE DIVISIONS AS
DESCRIBED IN THE BUDGET CHANCE
PROPOSAL IS THE RESIDENTS ARE
IT CASTRATION COMPLIANCE
ENFORCEMENT. EXTERNAL PARTNERS
I THINK LABORATORY. LEGAL
AFFAIRS DESPITE AFFAIRS AND
LICENSING. THE BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL REQUESTS SIX HUNDRED
TWENTY ONE POSITIONS AND ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY THREE POINT EIGHT
MILLION IN CANNABIS CONTROL
FUND IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO.
AND THAT AMOUNT WILL DECREASE%
TO ONE HUNDRED THIRTY SIX POINT
SIX MILLION IN TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE AND I'M GOING.
OF THE HUNDRED FIFTY THREE
POINT EIGHT NINE REQUESTED ONLY
THREE POINT TWO MILLION IS NEW
FUNDING TO ESTABLISH THE NEW
DEPARTMENT. THE OTHER ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY POINT SEVEN
MILLION. IT'S FROM THE EXISTING
DEPARTMENTS. WE'LL FOCUS ON
CONTINUITY AND STABILITY FOR
STAKEHOLDERS DURING THE
TRANSITION THROUGH THE
CONTINUED USE OF THE CURRENT
LICENSING SYSTEMS AND THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS TRACK AND
TRACE SYSTEM. AS WELL AS TO
INTERAGENCY AGREEMENTS. WHAT
THE EXISTING DEPARTMENTS FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES WHILE
WE WORK TO STAND UP THE NEW
DEPARTMENT OVER THE NEXT FEW
YEARS. THE FUNDING DECREASE THE
AMOUNT THAT I MENTIONED ABOUT
FOR TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE REFLECTS THE PHASE OUT. OF
THOSE INTERAGENCY AGREEMENTS.
THANK LIKE ONE OF THE SIX
HUNDRED TWENTY ONE REQUESTED
POSITIONS ONLY TWENTY THREE ARE
NEW AND THE REST ARE CURRENTLY
AUTHORIZED WITHIN THE THREE
LICENSING ENTITIES. CHANCE FOR
A FIVE HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT
EXISTING POSITIONS WILL ALLOW
THE NEW DEPARTMENT TO RETAIN
THE KNOWLEDGE AND EXPERTISE.
THAT RESIDE WITHIN THESE
PROGRAMS TODAY. THE TWENTY
THREE NEW POSITIONS ARE NEEDED
TO FORM THE EXECUTIVE
MANAGEMENT STRUCTURE OF THE NEW
DEPARTMENT AND IT'S CONSISTENT
WITH OTHER STATE DEPARTMENTS OF
SIMILAR SIZE. THESE POSITIONS
WILL PROVIDE SOME
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNCTIONS
CURRENTLY PERFORMED WITHIN THE
THREE EXISTING DEPARTMENTS THAT
ARE NOT SPECIFIC TO CANNABIS.
AND WILL REMAIN AT THE LEGACY
DEPARTMENTS SUCH AS AN EEO
OFFICER. AND A CHIEF
INFORMATION OFFICER. ON THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES IT
INCLUDES COMPANION PROPOSALS
FROM CONSUMER AFFAIRS PUBLIC
HEALTH AND FOOD AND AGRICULTURE
TO TRANSFER THE RESPECTIVE
CANADA'S RESOURCES TO THE NEW
DEPARTMENT- WE HAVE ALSO
PROPOSED STATUTORY CHANGES TO
EFFECTUATE THE CONSOLIDATION
AND MAKE RELATED IMPROVEMENTS
WHERE POSSIBLE. ONE ITEM OF
NOTE FOR THE COMMITTEE IS THE-
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND ACT WILL
RETAIN THAT CAN APPELLATIONS.
THE- CAL BROKE WHICH WILL
ESTABLISH FOR CANNABIS.
COMPARABLE TO THE NEXT ORGANIC
PROGRAM WILL ALSO BE WRITTEN
WITHIN AND AFTER AND THE
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH. AND
WILL CONTINUE BENEFIT EXPERT
MOST. THANKS WE WOULD LIKE TO
THE THIS PROPOSED IS THE FIRST
STEP IN MOVING TOWARD UNIFIED
APPROACH TO CANNABIS WITH IN
CALIFORNIA. I RECOGNIZE THIS
EFFORT WILL REQUIRE ADJUSTMENTS
AFTER THE INITIAL ESTABLISHMENT
OF THE DEPARTMENT AND IT IS OUR
INTENT TO PROVIDE CONTINUITY OF
OPERATIONS AND SERVICES DURING
THE CONSOLIDATION PERIOD.
RETENTION OF EXPERTISE TO THE
TRANSFER OF EXISTING POSITIONS.
FROM THE THREE STATE CANNABIS
ENTITIES THE NEW DEPARTMENTAL
EIGHT IN THIS BILL. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND WE'RE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU FOR. MISTER
SEIDENBERG. THREE SO TO WORK
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
AT THIS POINT OUR OFFICE IS
STILL EXAMINING THE PROPOSAL
AND TO THE EXTENT WE IDENTIFY
ANY CONCERNS OR HAVE OTHER
RECOMMENDATIONS REGARDING TO IT
WILL MAKE SURE TO PROVIDE THOSE
TO THE COMMITTEE AS SOON AS
THEY BECOME AVAILABLE. THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS. WHAT QUESTIONS
GO AHEAD MR LIFE. CERTAINLY THE
SUB CONSOLIDATION WILL SERVE AS
A- I THINK A BENEFIT TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BUT- I
HEARD YOU SAY THAT THERE. THIS
MERGES ACTUALLY REDUCED IN-
WILL RESULT IN REDUCED
REDUNDANCY I DON'T. DON'T KNOW
WHERE THAT'S ACTUALLY HAPPENING
WHEN. USUALLY WHEN THERE'S A
CONSOLIDATION THERE'S A
REDUCTION IN EMPLOYEES BUT
THAT'S NOT THE CASE HERE AS A
MATTER OF FACT WE HAVE. SO MORE
EMPLOYEES SO IF YOU JUST GOT TO
HELP ME UNDERSTAND WHAT
REDUNDANCY HAS BEEN. REDUCED BY
THIS CONSOLIDATION I WOULD LOVE
THAT. I'M SURE THIS IS YEAH I
CAN REALLY HAVE RISEN AGAIN
FROM FINANCE- WE DEALT. THE
WORK WILL STILL SAY THE SAME SO
THERE IS NO REDUCTION OF
EMPLOYEES BUT THE WHAT WE HOPE
TO GAIN AND PLAN TO GAIN FROM
THIS CONSOLIDATION. IS
STREAMLINING CELL INSTEAD OF
THREE SETS OF REGULATIONS
THERE'S ONE THERE'S ONE POINT
OF CONTACT FOR CONSUMERS. AND
BUSINESSES LICENSEES SISTER
STATE DEPARTMENT TO CONTACT FOR
INFORMATION SO IT'S A-
STREAMLINING AND REFINEMENT OF
THE WORK THAT WE'RE DOING SO
INSTEAD OF DOING SOMETHING.
THREE TIMES- WE WILL DO UNDER
ONE ROOF BUT THERE IS STILL YOU
KNOW DIFFERENT ASPECTS TO
LICENSING SO WE NEED. ALL THAT
KNOWLEDGE AND EXPERTISE IN THE
NEW DEPARTMENT. OKAY OKAY THANK
YOU I JUST KNOW THAT ADDITIONAL
PLACE SOMETIMES HAVE A TENDENCY
TO DO JUST THE OPPOSITE OF
STREAMLINING SO I'M HOPING THAT
YOU CAN FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
ACCOMPLISH THAT AND- I HAVE
GREAT HOPES. MISTER COOPER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF. THIS
IS A QUESTION FOR FINANCE GOING
pBACK TO THOSE. TWENTY THREE NEW
POSITIONS YOU ANOTHER MINUTE
FOR YOU TALKED ABOUT. BUT
THEY'RE SEPARATE FROM THE
LEGACY POSITIONS A LEGACY
AGENCIES. I MEAN HOW MANY HOW
MANY ARE MEANT TO SAYS IN IN
THE REPORTER SAYS. MANAGEMENT
I. T. I BELIEVE. YEAH
MANAGEMENT I. T. SO HOW MANY
HOW MANY GOING FOR EXECUTIVE
POSITIONS ARE MANAGEMENT AND
HOW MANY FOR I. T. I'M I'M- OFF
TO OUR- BASICALLY EXPERT FROM
FOOD AGRICULTURE MELISSA. HI
MELISSA IT'S AN WOULD CDFA CAL
CANNABIS WE HAVE. IT EXECUTIVE
DIVISION WE HAVE FIVE POSITIONS
AND THEN IN THE I. T. THERE IS
TEN SO THERE'S THOSE ARE
FIFTEEN OUT OF THE TWENTY THREE.
FIFTEEN NINETY. OH SORRY THERE
IS TEN NINETY AND FIVE
EXECUTIVE. OKAY LET'S FIFTEEN
WHAT WHAT ABOUT THE OTHER TO UP
TO TWENTY THREE THURSDAY MORE.
SO THAT WE HAVE- WE'RE GOING TO
NEED EIGHT INTERNAL- INTERNAL
AUDITS OFFICE SO THAT IS
ANOTHER ISSUE FOR THEIR AND
THEN IN ADDITION WE HAVE AT
THREE NEW STAFF IN LICENSING-
IN SOME OF THESE ARE FOR
SUPPORT POSITIONS OR WHEN WE
WERE LOOKING AT THE STRUCTURES.
WE THERE WAS SOME LLOCATION
ISSUES LIKE WE NEEDED TO HAVE
AN ADDITIONAL MANAGER OR- JUST
TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE WAS THE
RIGHT RATIO BETWEEN EMPLOYEES
AND- EMPLOYEES AND MANAGEMENT
BUT- LET'S SEE AND THEN IN LABS
WE HAVE ONE SUPERVISOR- AND
THEN AND- OUR EXTERNAL AFFAIRS
WE HAVE ONE OFFICE TECHNICIANS
THAT THAT WOULD BE ONE MORE
POSITION. TO THAT IT'S THE
TWENTY THREE. SO ARE KNOWN FOR
BECAUSE CORRECT. CORRECT OKAY
LAST TIME WE HAD A FULL HEARING
ON CANNABIS CULTIVATION
ADMINISTRATION DID ENGAGE WITH
THE LEGISLATURE- THE NUTRITION
SAID THEY WANTED TO BUT THEY
NEVER GOT FEEDBACK FROM US AND
WE WANT TO WORK WITH YOU GUYS
IN A PARTNERSHIP SO OF THE FIVE
HUNDRED AND NINETY EXISTING
POSITIONS HOW MANY ARE
DEDICATED SOLELY TO ENFORCEMENT.
I MEAN IT DEFERRED TO THAT BUT
THE- OF CAMPUS CONTROL FOR THAT
CAMERA. TALK ABOUT IMPORTANT.
CERTAINLY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOPER TENURE TRYING TO OUR
FIRST ONE PIECE OFFICERS ABOUT
WHAT YOU'RE INTERESTED IN IT'S
HARD TO HEAR ABOUT HEARING IT'S-
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW. YEAH
OKAY LET ME. I'M ARE YOU AND
ARE YOU SPECIFICALLY ASKING
ABOUT OUR SWORN PEACE OFFICER
POSITIONS CORRECT AMONG THE
MOST ALL THE AGENTS ARE ACTS.
CORRECT SO CURRENTLY THE BUREAU
HIS AS YOU KNOW JULY FIRST THE
KIND OF THE FIRST MAKING IT
CAME OVER FROM DC INTO THE
EURO. SO THAT IS GOING TO CARRY
OVER INTO THE NEW DEPARTMENT
AND CURRENTLY WE HAVE. SEVENTY
SIX ONE PHYSICIANS AUTHORIZED.
AND THAT WILL BE ON THE NEW NEW
AGENCY. THAT IS CORRECT THAT
WILL CARRY OVER INTO THE NEW
AGENCY. OKAY- SO WHAT CAN YOU
TELL ME AS FAR AS THE CURRENT
BEEN FORTUNATE POSITIONS WHERE
THEY WHERE THEY CURRENTLY DO.
SO IF YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT ARE
SWORN ENFORCEMENT THEY
PRIMARILY FOCUSED ON UNLICENSED
ACTIVITY. AND SO THEY YOU KNOW
DO ALL THE ACTIVITIES RELATED
TO THAT KIND OF AN
INVESTIGATION FROM THE ACTIVITY
DAYS ARE SEARCH WARRANTS TO
CONDUCT SURVEILLANCE THEY WORK
VERY CLOSELY WITH OTHER STATE
AGENCIES. AND OTHER AND THE
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT- AND
DEPARTMENTS. SO WITH A NEW
AGENCY THEIR POSITIONS WILL
REMAIN THE SAME THAT THEIR
DUTIES AND. THAT IS CORRECT
SIR. DO YOU SEE A NEED FOR
INCREASING LAW ENFORCEMENT
STAFFING. I THINK WHAT WE HAVE
RIGHT NOW IT'S APPROPRIATE WE
ARE MAKING GOOD PROGRESS ON
FILLING THOSE POSITIONS AND SO
I THINK OUR PLAN WOULD BE TO.
THOSE POSITIONS SEE HOW IT
WORKS AND THE CONSOLIDATION AND
IF WE DETERMINE THAT WE NEED
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES WE WILL
CERTAINLY ASK FOR THOSE. I
GUESS MY CONCERN IS- THERE'S A
LOT OF INVESTIGATION TO DO AN
AWFULLY SEVENTY SIX SWORN
OFFICERS. OF THE BLACK MARKET
IS STILL ALIVE AND WELL LAST
YEAR THE SAME COMMITTEE WE
TALKED ABOUT THE VAPING DEATHS
FROM BLACK MARKET CANNABIS IS
STILL OUT THERE- PEOPLE ARE
STILL DYING IS KIND OF TAKEN A
BACKSEAT BECAUSE OF CODE.
BECAUSE COVETOUS SUCKED ALL THE
AIR OUT AND RIGHTLY SO WE STILL
HAVE AN ISSUE WITH IT. YOU GUYS
HAD ONE BIG ARRESTS LAST YEAR
DOWN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA A BIG
BUST. AND USE LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT SO THERE'S NO WAY
THAT- DCC. CAN INVESTIGATE
THESE CASES WITHOUT LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT SO. I HAVEN'T READ
ANYTHING ELSE WHAT YOUR AGENTS
HAVE DONE SINCE THEN. CONSERVE
NATIONAL BOSTON LA. SO I THANK
SAID IS STILL GOING ON THE
BLACK MARKET CANNABIS SO. IT
WHEN YOU SAY THAT SEVENTY SIX
OFFICERS ENOUGH I WONDER ABOUT
THAT AND ALSO MORE IMPORTANTLY-
THERE'S REALLY BEEN NO
ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE THEY WERE
SO CONCERNED ABOUT LICENSING.
AND GETTING THESE BUSINESSES UP
AND RUNNING WHAT WHICH HAPPENED
WE GOT UP AND RUNNING BUT AS
FAR AS I KNOW. HAVING BILLS
COMMITTEE FOR SEVEN YEARS NOW
THERE'S BEEN. SUBSTANTIAL LAST
THREE OR FOUR YEARS-
ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE EVERYONE
WAS SO CONCERNED ABOUT
LICENSING. SO HAVE THERE BEEN
ANY MORE LARGE SCALE BUS
DEALING WITH BLACK MARKET-
VAPING. SIR I CAN'T SAY
SPECIFICALLY DEVELOPING BUT WE
CERTAINLY ARE OUT THERE
CONDUCTING OPERATIONS- RELATED.
ILLEGAL ACTIVITY AND EXECUTING
SEARCH WARRANTS AT AND WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE LOCALS ARE
VERY IMPORTANT PIECE OF THIS
PUZZLE AND WE WORK WITH
VIRTUALLY WITH THEM. IN FACT
FIVE INVEST LAST THANKSGIVING
FACT LAST WEEK WE EXECUTED A
SEARCH WARRANT IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THE LA POLICE DEPARTMENT
WE ALSO EXECUTED ONE IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE SAN%
BERNARDINO POLICE DEPARTMENT.
AS WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION SO ALL THREE OF
THOSE AGENCIES WERE INVOLVED IN
THAT SO WE ARE CONTINUING TO DO
THAT AND OUR PLAN IS TO
CONTINUE TO DO THAT AS WE- MOVE
FORWARD- THROUGH THE
CONSOLIDATION. AND HOPEFULLY
INCREASE OUR COOPERATION IN
THOSE RELATIONSHIPS- TO ATTACK
THE ILLEGAL MARKET THROUGH AND
ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITIES SO IT
WOULD HELP ME AS FAR AS BEING
ON THIS COMMITTEE HAVE FROM A
FULL COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO KNOW.
HOW TO USE SEARCH WARRANTS HAVE
BEEN HAVE BEEN DONE. SINCE A
BIG OPERATION LAST YEAR THAT
WERE STRICKEN WE TALK ABOUT
WILL SEARCH FOR SHE SERVED.
WITH ALL STRICTLY FOR BLACK
MARKET OVER THERE FOR OTHER
CANNABIS. RELATED
INVESTIGATIONS. SO WHEN YOU
SEPARATING OTHERS. YEAH SEARCH
WARRANTS ARE YOU TEAMS FOCUS
THEIR PRIMARY FOCUS IS ON THE
UNLICENSED ACTIVITY BUT THAT'S
NOT TO BE FOR ME SAID LICENSE
THAT COULD BE FOR JUST. FOR
CANNABIS SOMEONE HEAVILY WILL
GROW- SUPPLYING WHAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT THE CIVIC
DEVELOPING BECAUSE OF THE
VAPING DOES WE HAVE LAST YEAR.
SO CAN I NEED A IT WOULD HELP
ME MAKE DECISIONS. IF YOU COULD
BREAK THAT OUT INTO LITTLE
SPECIFICALLY WORK AND AN
ADDRESS THAT WE DEAL WITH THIS.
THE FORMER HAVE. FILED HERE I
GET AND BE CERTAINLY HAPPY TO
GATHER THAT INFORMATION AND
FOLLOW UP WITH YOU ON. BUT BUT
ONE THING I NEED TO STRESS IS
IF IT'S LIKE I'LL BE HONEST
WITH YOU MINISTRATION. WHETHER
IT'S THIS OR ANYTHING ELSE- AND
I. THEY HAVE THEY HAVEN'T BEEN
VERY GOOD ABOUT WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE ON THINGS AND
WE'RE WE'RE PARTNERS IT'S A
PARTNERSHIP- LIKE I SAID WE
WANT TO PROVE THESE THINGS HELP
YOU GUYS GET TO WHERE YOU NEED
TO BE BUT WE ALSO NEED YOUR
COOPERATION FORSMAN AND LIKELY
SAID LAST YEAR WE TALKED ABOUT
THIS AND- IT LINKS. AND NOTHING
HAS COME FORWARD FROM ANY OF
THESE ORGANIZATIONS ALL THREE
ORGANIZATIONS ABOUT WHAT'S
BEING DONE SO THAT'S THE
FRUSTRATION ON OUR PART HERE.
YOU KNOW WE WANT TO PLAY NICE
BUT IT'S HARD. WHEN WE AREN'T
GETTING THAT THE RECIPROCITY
BACK. FROM THESE ORGANIZATIONS
THESE DEPARTMENT HEADS. SO THAT
TO YOU THAT THAT'S IMPORTANT
WITH US. SO HAVE A MEANINGFUL
ENOUGH MY WORRY WHEN IT COMES
UNDER ONE ORGANIZATION YOU KNOW
WHAT IS GOING TO CHANGE BECAUSE
UP TILL NOW. IT HASN'T WORKED
THAT GREAT. SO WHAT'S GONNA
CHANGE. MY IS WHAT SURE I THINK
ONE OF THE PRIMARY THAT'S GOING
TO CHANGE IS THE FACT THAT WE
WILL BE ONE COMPREHENSIVE
SYSTEM FROM ENFORCEMENT RIGHT
NOW DEPENDING ON THE ACTIVITY
OFTENTIMES INVOLVES-
MANUFACTURING AND DISTRIBUTORS
AND SO WE'LL HAVE ONE TEAM WILL
BE ABLE TO DO FROM START TO
FINISH ALL OF THE ISSUES IN IN
ONE ORGANIZATION THEY'LL BE ONE
ORGANIZATION AS A PRIMARY
CONTACT POINT THERE WON'T BE-
TALK TO PUBLIC HEALTH OR TALK
TO CDFA BECAUSE THAT INVOLVES
THEM SO I THINK THAT'S GOING.
TO BE VERY HELPFUL- AS WE WORK
WITH THE LEGISLATURE BUT ALSO
AS WE WORK WITH OUR LICENSEES
AND THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
THAT WE PARTNER WITH. I'M
READING IN THE IN THE IN THE
STAFF REPORT PROPOSAL LEDGES
AND ALSO ALLEGES. THE
DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS CONTROL
WILL HAVE A MORE STREAMLINED
COMPLIANCE ENFORCEMENT PROCESS.
AND THIS IS A STATEWIDE
OPERATION YOU HAVE A LOT OF
LICENSES IF YOU LOOK AT THAT
THE TRIAD IN THE CANNABIS. WITH
WHO THERE IS A LOT TO LOOK AT.
AND YOU HAVE SOME INVESTIGATORS
ARE BATCH CARRIERS. THAT ARE
DOING THINGS THAT THAT ARE
SWORN LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
TO TALKING SEVENTY SIX.
INVESTIGATORS. FOR A STATE WIDE
OPERATION. WHICH NUCLEAR
AFFECTED STATE OF FORTY MILLION
PEOPLE. IN THE NUMBER OF
BUSINESSES DOING CANNABIS. NO
MATTER WHAT IT IS THAT IS
WOEFULLY INADEQUATE. WHEN YOU
LOOK AT IT CAN YOU THINK ABOUT
A PRODUCTION THAT THAT THE
GROWS- THE MANUFACTURING THE
RETAIL HOW CAN SEVENTY SIX
OFFICERS. DO ANY TYPE OF
SIGNIFICANT INVESTIGATION.
PERIOD THEY ARE MEANING IF YOU
LOOK AT THE OPERATIONS TALK
ABOUT EARLIER IN THOSE
INVESTIGATIONS THAT'S JUST
BARELY SCRATCHING THE SURFACE
TO DEAL WITH IT IT'S JUST A
IT'S THAT'S THAT'S THE HELP ME
REALIZE HOW THAT IS. AND THEN
MIND YOUR TELL YOU RIGHT NOW I
SPENT TEN YEARS IN OUR CLOCKS
ARRESTEE WHY NARCOTICS TASK
FORCE. IT'S BEEN THIRTY YEARS
INSURANCE DEPARTMENTS AND ONE
TALKING ABOUT SO WHEN I SAY
IT'S WOEFULLY INADEQUATE. I'M
SPEAKING FROM A POSITION OF
EXPERTISE WITH THIS. SO THAT'S
A CONCERN OF MINE. BUT HERE YOU
ARE REPRESENTING THE AGENCY
TELLING ME THAT ADEQUATE. HOW
HOW DO YOU RECONCILE THAT
PLEASE. SO I THINK THERE'S A
COUPLE OF FACETS WHEN IS THAT
THE YOU KNOW LICENSED
INVESTIGATIONS ARE COMPLIANCE
UNITS WILL CANCEL THOSE- THOSE
OF THE NON SWORN BUT THEY'RE
DOING THOSE INVESTIGATIONS OF
REALLY TO LICENSEES AT TIMES
THERE'S CROSSOVER WITH OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS SO THERE
IS A LARGE GROUP- OF
INVESTIGATORS AND INSPECTORS
THAT WILL BE FOCUSING ON ON
THOSE. THAT INVOLVE LICENSEES
FOR THE UNLICENSED WE DO HAVE
THE SEVENTY SIX ONE AT THIS
POINT IN TIME- AND WE'RE
FILLING THOSE POSITIONS WE ARE
WORKING WITH THE LOCALS AND OUR
OTHER STATE PARTNERS AND I
THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE WAYS
THAT WE MAKE GOOD PROGRESS IS
BY COMBINING THOSE RESOURCES
AND TO WORK TOGETHER. I THINK
ALSO ONE OF THE THINGS WE KEEP
IN MIND IS THAT COMBAT IN THE
LEGAL MARKET ISN'T SIMPLY JUST
TAKING ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS I
THINK THERE'S OTHER WAYS THAT
TO HELP WITH THAT AND ONE IS TO
TRY TO MAKE SURE. THAT THE
LEGAL MARKETS ACCESSIBLE TO
LICENSEES YOU KNOW A LOT OF
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS DON'T ALLOW
LEGAL CANNABIS MARKETS- AND
MAKING SURE THAT THE
PARTICIPATION IN THE LABOR
MARKET IS NOT COST PROHIBITIVE.
AND ADDITIONALLY MAKING SURE
THAT REASONABLY PRICED CANNABIS
IS AVAILABLE TO OUR CONSUMERS
SO I THINK IF WE COUPLE THOSE
ACTIVITIES AND THOSE POINTS OF
FOCUS ALONG WITH ENFORCEMENT WE
CAN MAKE MORE PROGRESS ON THE
ILLEGAL MARKET FRONTS THE BLACK
MARKET IS ALIVE AND THRIVING
AND IS ACTUALLY DOING VERY
WELL. AND EVEN ON INVESTIGATION
THOUGH SEVEN SIX INVESTIGATORS
THERE BAY STATEWIDE. THEY'RE
NOT IN ONE LOCATION CORRECT.
THAT IS THE ARE NOT ALL IN ONE.
CANNOT RETURN FLYING I MEAN
YOU'RE REST OF YOUR FLY BACK OF
IN CALIFORNIA. SO THEY'RE STILL
HEAVILY RELY UPON LOCAL
INVESTIGATORS DO THAT. EFFORT
FOR INVESTIGATION SURVEILLANCE
MANY DOZENS OF OFFICERS TO DO
THAT SO- AND I'M JUST YOU KNOW.
I KNOW YOU DON'T YOU'RE NOT. IN
UP A SWORN OFFICER SO YOU DON'T
KNOW. BUT WHAT I'M TELLING YOU
IS- THOSE NUMBERS ARE NOT
SIGNIFICANT OR NOT PUTTING A
DENT IN IT. AND WE SAY IT'S
ADEQUATE ONCE AGAIN THEY'RE
STILL VAPING GAS GOING ON SO
SILLIMANITE ASSUME THAT YOU'RE
OKAY WITH THAT THAT. THERE'S
ADEQUATE ENFORCEMENT SILLIER
THEY'VE ADDRESSED THE VAPING
ISSUE FOR. BLACK MARKET VAPING
PRODUCTS AND THEY'RE NO MORE
DESK BEHIND. THAT IS THAT WHAT
HE'S SAYING. NOW WE'RE SIR.
OKAY WITH THE UP OBVIOUS. AND
WHERE DOING YOU KNOW IT WHEN
THOSE ITEMS COME TO OUR
ATTENTION WEEK WE WORK VERY
HARD TO IT TO COME ABOUT THOSE
AND DEAL WITH THOSE H. I THINK
WE HAD- THE VERTICAL BUT LESS
SITUATION WITHOUT THE LARGE-
LICENSEE WHO. CONDUCTING
ILLEGAL IN THEM UNLICENSED
ACTIVITY BOTH AS A LICENSEE AS
WELL AS- ENGAGING WITH
UNLICENSED FOLKS SO I THINK
WHEN I SET UP BUT WE THINK THIS
IS THE APPROPRIATE STAFFING
RIGHT NOW WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO BUILD THOSE
RESOURCES- AND THEN ONCE WE DO
I THINK WE CAN BETTER ASSESS IF
WE NEED ADDITIONAL RESOURCES AS
WE'RE FILLING THESE NEW
POSITIONS THAT WE RECEIVED LAST
FISCAL YEAR. AND AS YOU KNOW IT
TAKES A WHILE TO GET GET
OFFICERS CAN BACKGROUND PROCESS
YEAH AND THEN ALSO SEEING HOW
THE CONSOLIDATION IMPACTS THOSE
ARE ABILITY IS THERE AND WE
THINK THAT WILL GIVE US- SOME
GREATER EFFICIENCIES AND THE
ABILITY TO CONTINUE TO PARTNER
WITH THE LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AS WELL AS OUR STATE LAW
ENFORCEMENT PARTNERS TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THE WORK
AGAINST THE BLACK MARKET. AND
WE TALKED ABOUT LAST. HOW RENT
THE BLACK. FOR WILL LA. YOU CAN
LOOK DOWN FOR MUCH ANY STREET
IN FOR BLACK MARKET VIEW
BROUGHT. SO DO YOU ARE YOU TELL
ME RIGHT NOW THAT THAT HAS
CHANGED DRAMATICALLY THAT IT'S
GONE DOWN- MUSCLES BUSINESSES
STILL. IN OPERATION. I DON'T
HAVE THE ANSWERS RIGHT NOW TO
ANY SPECIFIC BUSINESSES BUT I
KNOW THAT WE'RE CONTINUING TO
DO INVESTIGATIONS. AND WE ARE
CERTAINLY SENSITIVE TO THE
ISSUES WITH BABY LAST YEAR HIM
QUITE CLOSE ATTENTION TO THAT
WHEN THEY'RE BROUGHT TO OUR
ATTENTION AND WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO DO THAT UNDER THE
NEW DEPARTMENT. AND TALKING TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT GOALS GOALS-
VAPING SHOPS. THE LIST OF ONES
A BLACK MARKET ONES. ARE STILL
OPEN AND ARE STILL THRIVING.
BECAUSE THE ENFORCEMENT IS NOT
THERE WITH THEM. SO I'M I'M
GONNA START MY QUESTIONING
MADAM CHAIR AND- INTERNET BACK
OVER TO YOU BUT IT THAT THAT'S
A BIG ISSUE LIKE I SAID- IF IT
WASN'T FOR COVERT RIGHT NOW WE
WOULD HEAR A LOT ABOUT PEOPLE
DYING. IN THE BLACK MARKET.
MARKET VAPING AND IT'S
FRUSTRATING. THAT YOU KNOW WE
WE'VE BEEN OVER BACKWARDS FOR
THE INDUSTRY TO GET HIM UP WE
HELP THEM OT. AND NOW IT'S
TIME IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE
INVOLVED IN THE ILLEGAL MARKET.
MAY BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE AND FOR
NOT FOR COVERED. WE'D BE
TALKING ABOUT THESE DEATHS JUST
LIKE. THE FENTANYL OVERDOSES
ARE STILL GOING ON IN IN THE-
THE HEROIN. THE STUFF IS STILL
ALIVE. COBIZ JUST TAKEN THE
CONVERSATION OVER. SO I THINK
WE'RE DOING FULL SAID OF
DISSERVICE. INCLUDING THE LEGAL.
FOR THE FOURTH IN THE LEGAL
MARKET. BECAUSE THE BLACK
MARKET IT IS WAY CHEAP IN THE
BLACK MARKET IS ALIVE AND
THRIVING. AND IN MY OPINION.
THE STATE HASN'T DONE ENOUGH IN
NEEDS DOING US IN IN A STARTS
HERE WITH THE PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN LEGISLATORS AND
ADMINISTRATION. IT CAN'T BE ONE
SIDED UP TILL NOW. AND I'VE
TALKED TO MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES
THEY FELT THAT HAS BEEN ONE
SIDED WITH THE ADMINISTRATION.
AND WE'VE GOT TO WORK TOGETHER
TO FIX THIS. OTHERWISE IT IS
GOING TO RUN A CONTINUOUS OF
THINKING VENTURE. THANK YOU
MISTER COOPER AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR EXPERTISE AS A FORMER LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFICER TO BE ABLE
TO BRING THAT EXPERTISE TO THIS
COMMAND TO BE ABLE TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE DOING LEGISLATION.
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION THE REFLECTS
WHAT'S NEEDED ON THE GROUND.
MISTER LUCKY. YOU'RE JUST REAL
QUICK I WOULD LIKE TO JUST
FOLLOW UP ON MY COLLEAGUES
REMARKS. AS IT AS IT RELATES TO
FORTUNATE. MA'AM I WILL TELL
YOU THAT IT IS REALLY. CLEAR
THAT THE- THE BIGGEST THREAT TO
THE LEGAL MARKET RIGHT NOW IS.
IS THE THRIVING ILLICIT MARKET
AND THE ILLICIT MARKET- IS A
THREAT UNDERCOVER WAYS AND WHEN
WE HAVE. OF A LAW ENFORCEMENT
GROUP THAT IS MORE. FOCUSED ON.
GETTING LICENSING COMPLIANCE
WE'RE FOCUSING ON THOSE WHO ARE
TRYING TO BE. TEAM PLAYERS AND
FOLLOW THE RULES. AND THEY'RE
THE ONLY ONES GET THE FOCUS AND
I THINK THAT THAT'S UNFORTUNATE
BECAUSE IT. IT'S SENDING AN
UNINTENDED MESSAGE WHICH IS-
YOU KNOW WE'RE ONLY INTERESTED
IN AND- POLICING YOU FOLKS WHO
ARE TRYING TO FOLLOW IN
COMPLIANCE AND- I KNOW THAT'S
NOT THE INTENTION BUT THAT IS
THE CONSEQUENCE AND THAT IS
WHAT'S HAPPENING. AND WE NEED
TO CHANGE THAT- PARADIGM AND
I'M HOPING THAT- YOUR
MINISTRATION IN THIS NEW MERGER
WILL- RE DIRECT THE FOCUS
TOWARDS ILLICIT MARKET BECAUSE-
UNTIL WE DO SO- THE LEGAL
MARKET WE HAVE. ALL SORTS OF
GOOD PLAYERS WHO ARE FALLING
OUT EVERY DAY. AND THEY'RE
GIVING UP BECAUSE OF THE
DIFFICULTY THAT THEY'RE HAVING
AND MANAGING AND COMPLYING WITH
THESE RULES. WHEN THEIR
COMPETITORS HAVE NO RULES AND
UNLESS THE ONLY THING THEY WILL
RECOGNIZE AS BEING SHUT DOWN
WHEN YOU SAY. YOU KNOW THERE'S
ONLY ONE YOU HAVE HESITATION OF
FOCUSING ON A FORTUNATE BUT-
I'M TELLING YOU THAT THERE ARE
DIFFERENT WAYS TO CARRY OUT
ENFORCEMENT. AND IT DOESN'T
MEAN SEND PEOPLE TO PRISON IT
MEANS SHUT HIM DOWN. GO AFTER
THEIR MONEY THAT'S WHAT WILL
SHUT THEM DOWN. AND THAT TAKES
A COORDINATED EFFORT IT TAKES A
LOT OF WORK BUT IT MUST BE A
PRIORITY AT THE TOP. AND I
DON'TGET THE VIBE THAT- WE'VE
GOT IT AT THE TOP BUT WE SO WE
NEED TO WORK ON THAT WE HOPE
THAT WE CAN GET YOU TO BE A
PARTNER TO. FIGHT AGAINST
ILLICIT MARKET. THANK YOU FOR
THAT MISTER LACKING- ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS FROM THE MEMBERS. NOW
I HAVE A QUESTION R. D. C. A.
C. P. AGENCY FOR CDFA IS
BUDGETS BEING REDUCED BECAUSE
THE- THOSE STAFFING COST
OWNERSHIP TO THIS NEW
DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS CONTROL.
I CAN'T BELIEVE EVERYTHING FROM
FINANCE YES THEY WILL THEIR-
EACH OF THOSE DEPARTMENTS AS A
WHAT WE CALL NEGATIVE PCP TO
REDUCE THOSE RESOURCES. THAT WE
CAN NEVER DEBATED APARTMENT.
AND ALSO AND WHAT IS THAT
NUMBER LOOK LIKE WHAT IS THE
REDUCTION NUMBER LOOK LIKE. ONE
MOMENT. SO IT'S- THE CNSUMER
AFFAIRS IT IS SEVENTY THREE
POINT FOUR MILLION FROM THE
CANNABIS CONTROL FUND. AT THREE
TWENTY TWO POSITIONS AS WELL AS
TWENTY FIVE POINT FIVE MILLION
FROM THE TAX FUND AND SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND
REIMBURSEMENTS. FOR FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE IT SIXTY FOUR POINT
ONE MILLION FROM THE CANNABIS
CONTROL FOUND AND A HUNDRED
FIFTY FIVE POSITIONS. IN FORT
BUT HELLO IT IS A HUNDRED
NINETEEN POSITIONS AND TWENTY
NINE MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
CANNABIS CONTROL FUND SOME ALSO
OCCUR OUT OF THOSE THREE WHAT'S
THE TOTAL REDUCTION AND THE
BUDGET. BECAUSE OF THE BECAUSE
DUE TO STAFFING COST. THERE
WILL NOT BE GIFTING WHAT'S THE
TOTAL NUMBER. THAT'S ALL AND-
PAID FOR AND THE AGENDA AND IT
IS A HUNDRED FIFTY POINTS.
SEVEN MILLION. AND FIVE HUNDRED
NINETY EIGHT POSITIONS. THERE'S
A CHART WHERE IT'S LAID OUT FOR
YOU YES I'M I'M LOOKING AT IT
I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND TO THE
PREVIOUS QUESTIONS BEFORE THAT
WE'RE ADDING TWENTY THREE
ADDITIONAL NEW STAFF AND
KEEPING FIVE HUNDRED AND NINETY
EIGHT POSITIONS THAT ARE BEING
TRANSFERRED. AND SO I'M I'M
CURIOUS AS TO WHERE THE SAVINGS
TO THE CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS BY
CREATING A NEW DEPARTMENT.
WE'RE NOT LOOKING AT SAVINGS IN
TERMS OF DOLLARS WERE LOOKING
AT IT IN TERMS OF MORE
STREAMLINED WORK PRODUCT IN
MORE EFFICIENT PROCESSES HAVE
BEEN CONSERVING WATER- AND I'D
ALSO LIKE TO- JUST MENTION FROM
THE PREVIOUS COMMENTS FROM MR
COOPER AND MR LACKEY. THERE'S
ALSO FUNDING THAT GOES TO THE
BOARD OF STATE AND COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS- SO THERE IS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING AND THAT.
AMOUNT- RBC CAPITAL MARKETS. IS
SIXTY SIX POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS. OKAY THANK YOU FOR
THAT I THINK IT'S EXCITING TO
BE AT THE FOREFRONT OF A
DEVELOPMENT OF THE NEW
DEPARTMENT WHEN WE HAVESUCH AN
INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY TO
STREAMLINE BUT TO ALSO LOOK AT-
WAYS THAT SYSTEMS CAN BE
IMPROVED SPECIFICALLY WHAT
CONCERNS ME AND WE'VE SEEN THIS
IN OTHER DEPARTMENTS AS WELL AS
CREATING A DEPARTMENTS CREATING
MORE ADDITIONAL STAFF AND JUST
ADDING TO A BUREAUCRATIC
PROCESS THAT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY WORK AND ULTIMATELY
SPENDING MORE MONEY FOR
SOMETHING THAT- ISN'T
FUNCTIONING. SO I THINK- BASED
ON THE CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'RE
HEARING TODAY IT LOOKS LIKE WE
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO HAVE MORE
DISCUSSIONS IN TERMS OF HOW
THIS DEPARTMENT WILL BE RUN AND
THE RESOURCES THAT- BE NEEDED
TO INSURE THAT THERE'S PROPER
ENFORCEMENT THERE'S
COLLABORATION BETWEEN THE STATE.
TEXANS TO AND ULTIMATELY THAT
WE'RE USING- OUR STATE DOLLARS
APPROPRIATELY. IF THERE ARE NO
OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. WE
CAN MOVE ON TO THE NEXT PANEL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY WE
ARE NOW MOVING ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER TWO WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS. OUR
PANELISTS TODAY INCLUDE AGAIN
MISS KIMBERLY HARBISON WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- MISTER
DREW CHATER BURKE WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OFFICE.
THANK YOU CHAIR ON KIMBERLY
HARBISON AGAIN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THIS
ISSUE IS ONE OF THE PROPOSALS
FOR WHICH THE ADMINISTRATION.
IS REQUESTING VERY EARLY ACTION
FROM THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
TWENTY FIVE POINT IX MILLION
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND TO
PROVIDE LICENSE RENEWAL FEE
WAIVERS. TO ALL LICENSEES OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS BARBERING AND
COSMETOLOGY BOARD. THIS WILL BE
AVAILABLE FOR TWO YEARS
BEGINNING JANUARY FIRST OF THIS
YEAR TO MATCH THE BIENNIAL
RENEWAL CYCLE. FOR THESE
LICENSE. THANKS MAN OR SOMEONE
UNDER PAYS AN ANNUAL FEE OF
FORTY DOLLARS EVERY TWO YEARS.
AND THE INDIVIDUALS WHO PERFORM
SERVICES AT THESE
ESTABLISHMENTS. A LICENSE
RENEWAL FEE OF FIFTY DOLLARS
EVERY TWO YEARS. THIS INCLUDES
A POPULATION OF OVER FIVE
HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS AND MORE THAN FIFTY
THREE THOUSAND ESTABLISHMENTS.
THE FOR THE WAIVERS WILL BE
AUTOMATIC FOR ALL LICENSE
RENEWALS THERE IS NO
APPLICATION THAT THEY NEED TO
COMPLETE. AND THE BOARD WILL
ISSUE NEW LICENSES PRIOR TO THE
EXPIRATION OF. THE LICENSE
EXPIRATION DATE. FOR THOSE WHO
MAY HAVE ALREADY PAY THE
RENEWAL FEES IN JANUARY OR
FEBRUARY. THEIR RENEWAL DATES
WILL BE EXTENDED ON THE BACK
END UNTIL JANUARY OR FEBRUARY.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE SO THEY'RE
COVERED FOR THE NEXT PERIOD-
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
THIS WILL BE A CASH TRANSFER
FROM THE GENERAL FUND. AND
TRANSFERS FOR ONLY BE MADE IN
THE AMOUNT THAT IS EQUAL TO THE
COST OF THE PROGRAM. SO
REPRESENTATIVES FROM CONSUMER
AFFAIRS. MEYER AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. TURNING
COMING OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
MEMBERS. OKAY COMMITTEE. WAS
THAT YOU MISTER GOVERNORSHIPS.
IT SAYS ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
MISTER TO GO AHEAD. GREAT
HOPING YOU CAN SEE ME. OUR SO
MUCH APPRECIATE THE WAYS IN
WHICH WERE ALL LOOKING FOR
RELIEF FOR STRUGGLING BUSINESS
OWNERS AND I'M VERY OPEN TO
THIS PROPOSAL BUT I THINK IT
BEGS THE OBVIOUS QUESTION OF
WHY JUST BARBERING AND
COSMETOLOGY LICENSES AND
WONDERING IF THE ADMINISTRATION
HAD EXPLORED WAIVING FEES FOR
ANY OF THE OTHER THREE DOZEN OR
SO LICENSING BOARDS- WE'RE
HEARING FROM EVERY ONE OF OUR
SMALL THIS IS CONSTITUENTS
ABOUT THIS AND- AND AGAIN WHILE
WELL I THINK IT'S GREAT THAT
YOU WERE CONSIDER MOVING
FORWARD AND BARBERING AND
COSMETOLOGY. I WANT TO JUST
UNDERSTAND WHY THIS PARTICULAR
BOARD AND- AND NOT OTHERS.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION AND
WE REALIZE THE PANDEMIC HAS
BEEN HARD ON ALL KINDS OF FOLKS
UNLESS THEY HAVE ALL DIFFERENT
KINDS OF LICENSEES. BUT WE FELT
THE BARBERING AND COSMETOLOGY
COMMUNITY WAS PARTICULARLY HARD
HIT BECAUSE OF THEIR- CLOTHES.
FOR BUT THE CAPACITY TO
OPERATE- YOU KNOW MAYBE ONLY
OUTDOORS OR FURTHER TO GET THE
TIME THEY WERE CLOSED ENTIRELY.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER- ANY OTHER
OCCUPATIONS YOU'RE LOOKING UP
AT THIS POINT OR JUST THIS ONE.
EXISTENCE WHEN A CONSUMER
AFFAIRS THERE'S ALSO- A
COMPANION PROPOSAL FOR CERTAIN
LICENSEES OF THE ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGE CONTROL DEPARTMENT AND
THAT'S PRIMARILY BARS AND
RESTAURANTS. OKAY THANK YOU
THANK CHECK. MISTER COOPER
THANK MANAGER JUST TWO QUICK
QUESTIONS- FOR DLF HOW MANY
BUSINESSES WILL BE ELIGIBLE FOR
FEE WAIVERS. SO FOR CONSUMER
AFFAIRS AT FIVE HUNDRED SIXTY
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS AND ABOUT
FIFTY THREE THOUSAND SALONS.
OKAY NEVER BUSINESSES ALREADY
PAID THE RENEWAL FEE HOW DO YOU
PLAN ON DRESSING THAT. SO THAT-
AS I MENTIONED A LITTLE BIT
EARLIER IF THEY'VE ALREADY PAID
FOR JANUARY OR FEBRUARY WILL
GIVE THEM ASSEMBLY OFFENDED FOR
THEIR NEXT RENEWAL. TO LOOK AT
THE NEXT LEVEL. OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK AND HOW THEY MAY BE BE
RECEIVING NOTICE OF THAT CREDIT.
OF THE BOARD IS DOING OUTREACH
TO OTHER LICENSEES AND THEY'VE
ALSO POSTED A FREQUENTLY ASKED
QUESTIONS DOCUMENT ON THEIR
WEBSITE- AND IT'S BEEN WELL
PUBLICIZED IN THE MEDIA AS WELL.
BUT WILL THEY BE GETTING
ANYTHING IN WRITING LIKE FOR
THE DEPARTMENT BE ISSUING A
MAY QUALIFY FOR A WAIVER OR
CREDIT. I BELIEVE THERE IS A
NOTIFICATION BUT I'LL DEFER TO
CONSUMER AFFAIRS FOR THAT DATA.
CHRIS YOUNGER WITH THE BOARD OF
BARBERING AND COSMETOLOGY. M.
WE WILL AND INSTEAD OF NORMALLY
WE SEND A RENEWAL NOTICE TO YOU
I LICENSEES AND INSTEAD OF
GETTING THE RENEWAL NOTICE
THERE WILL ACTUALLY BE GETTING
A LIFE SENTENCE. I AM WITH THE
INFORMATION LETTING THEM KNOW
ABOUT THE M. THE WAITER. NOT
QUITE SURE THAT ANSWERS THE
QUESTION THE QUESTION FROM
MISTER COOPER WAS- IF THEY'VE
HAVE ALREADY PAID FOR THEIR
LICENSE. HOW WILL THEY KNOW NOT
TO DATE THAT THERE IT'S NOT
REQUIRED THAT THE PAY AGAIN HOW
YOU NOTIFY THAT THEY HAVE A
CREDIT. EVERAL FOR THAT FOR A
LICENSE FOR EXAMPLE IF THEY
EXPIRED IN. JANUARY AND HAVE
ALREADY PAID THEIR- RENEWAL
NOTICE. THEY HAVE THEIR LICENSE
ALREADY THAT IT'S GOOD FOR TWO
YEARS. SO WHAT WE WILL INCREASE
OUR OUTREACH TO THOSE LICENSEES
TO LET THEM KNOW THAT COME COME
TWO YEARS FROM NOW THAT'S WHEN
THEY'LL GET THE CREDIT AND WILL
BE ISSUED I AM A LICENSED WITH
A FEE WAIVER. OKAY THAT'S
THAT'S EXACTLY THE QUESTION AND
THE ANSWER THEN SO I WANT TO
MAKE SURE I THINK WE ALL WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE THAT
HAVE. ALREADY PAID.WILL WE SEE
THE SAME KIND OF TREATMENT TWO
YEARS FROM NOW AND THAT THEY
WILL RECEIVE A LETTER NOTIFYING
THAT THEY DON'T NEED TO PAY.
AND WILL HAVE A CREDIT IS THAT
ACCURATE. GREAT OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. IS THERE ARE THERE
ANY ADDITIONAL. QUESTIONS NOW I
ALSO WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
OF- ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU IN
TERMS OF. ADDITIONAL ADDITIONAL.
TYPE OF LICENSEES THAT- COULD
ALSO USE THE BENEFIT FOR
EXAMPLE- MASSAGE PARLORS
MASSEUSES HAVE ALL BEEN SHUT
DOWN- AND WOOD I'M SURE BENEFIT
FROM ALSO RECEIVING. A SOME
KIND OF A WAIVER I TO CONTINUE
DOING THE WORK IF THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS WILL MOVE
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER THREE.
BUSINESS SERVICES OUR PANELISTS
TODAY INCLUDE SEAN O'CONNOR
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS- DREW SODERBERG WITH
THE LIST LEGISLATIVE ANALYST
OFFICE AND KIA CHAU WITH THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. PLAYED OUT
ALREADY- CHECK GOOD AFTERNOON
CHECK CARILLO AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE- MY NAME IS SEAN
O'CONNOR THE CHIEF OF PROJECT
DELIVERY FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS OFFICE OF
INFORMATION SERVICES.
DESPONDENT IS ATION COHORT ONE
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL REQUEST
ONE YEAR FUNDING TO SUPPORT THE
PLANNED MAINTENANCE AND
OPERATIONS AND CREDIT CARD
SERVICES FOR THE FORTY CA
PROGRAMS INCLUDING COHORT ONE.
THIS INCLUDES THE BOARD OF
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS LAND
SURVEYORS AND GEOLOGISTS THE
BUREAU FOR PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION THE
BOARD OF CHIROPRACTIC EXAMINERS
AND THE CALIFORNIA ACUPUNCTURE
PART. THE REQUESTED FUNDING IS
IN ALIGNMENT WITH THE BASELINE
COSTS IDENTIFIED TO THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGIES PROJECT APPROVAL
LIFECYCLE AND THESE AMOUNTS ARE
IN ALIGNMENT WITH THE FIRST
YEAR OF OUR PLANNED ONGOING
MAINTENANCE AND OPERATIONS
COSTS FOR COHORT ONE. THIS
FUNDING WILL SUPPORT KNOWLEDGE
TRANSFER AND TECHNICAL TRAINING
FOR STATE IT RESOURCES BUSINESS
PROCESS ENHANCEMENTS AND
SOFTWARE SOLUTIONS.
ADDITIONALLY WE HAVE AN
ACCOUNTING AND BUSINESS
SERVICES PROPOSAL THAT REQUEST
TO EXTEND A PORTION OF THE
LIMITED TERM RESORTED GRANTED
TO THE DEPARTMENT IN A PREVIOUS
PROPOSAL ON AN ONGOING BASIS.
THE STAFF AND RESOURCES BEING
REQUESTED WILL ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT TO CONTINUE TO
ADDRESS THE ONGOING WORKLOAD
INCREASES THAT RESULTED FROM
DISCO. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THESE
REQUESTS AND MY COLLEAGUES AND
I ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. ANY COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
NOW K. SEEN NONE- MISTER-
O'CONNOR I THINK YOU'RE OFF THE
HOOK THEN. THANK YOU IN A TIME
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHAIR
CARILLO NEXT THE NEXT ISSUE
THANK YOU INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY SECURITY OUR
PANELISTS TODAY INCLUDE- JASON-
I'M GONNA TOTALLY BUT TO THAT I
AM SO SORRY P. SIONE. A
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS-
DREW SONNEBERG WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ALL ANALYST OFFICE
AND KIA CHAU THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. AND PLEASE- I'D LIKE
TO KNOW HOW TO PRONOUNCE YOUR
NAME PROPERLY. IT'S CHANGING
PETRONI OR CLOSE THANK YOU JOHN
BOB YES. GOOD AFTERNOON- CHAIR
CARILLO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JASON
BATTALION I'M THE CHIEF
INFORMATION OFFICER FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS.
AND BIT THE DEPARTMENT'S
REQUEST TODAY IS FOR TWO
POSITIONS AND TWO MILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. AND ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION ON GOING TO MEET STATE
OF CALIFORNIA MANDATED
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY SECURITY
REGULATIONS AND PROCESSES. THIS
REQUEST WILL PROVIDE THE
RESOURCES NEEDED O CONTINUE TO
EVOLVE THE DEPARTMENT
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY SECURITY
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND ALIGNED TO
THE STATE CYBER SECURITY
REQUIREMENTS AS WELL AS
IMPLEMENT THE FINDINGS FROM
MANDATED SECURITY AUDIT AND
SECURITY ASSESSMENTS. PERFORMED
BY THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY AND THE CALIFORNIA
MILITARY DEPARTMENT. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THIS
REQUEST. AND I AM HERE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE BEAR CALLIN FROM THE
DEPARTMENT TECH- DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. NO ANY I
RECOGNIZE THAT I DID NOT GO
THROUGH- THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FOR
ISSUES THREE SUGGEST THOUGH
CURIOUS IF THERE'S ANY COMMENTS
ON THIS ONE. ISSUE FOR. SORT OF
BORED LEGISLATIVE ANALYST
OFFICE MEETING AT IDENTIFYING
CONCERNS WITH THIS PROPOSAL FOR
THE- THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
APPRECIATE THAT AND MY
APOLOGIES. AT OKAY WE HAVE NO
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS ON THIS MR
PETRONI I READ YOUR I READ YOUR
NAME AND IN SPANISH VERSUS THE
TALENT BUT NOTED FOR FUTURE
THANK YOU. WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER FIVE- THE
REGULATIONS UNIT OUR PANELISTS
TODAY INCLUDE RYAN MY PROF WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS AGAIN MISTER SEIDENBERG
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE AND KIA CHAU THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU MY NAME IS
RYAN LARA CROFT I'M DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS LEGAL AFFAIRS.
BERMAN IS REQUESTING A TWO YEAR
FUNDING EXTENSION TO CONTINUE
SUPPORTING THE EXISTING
POSITIONS IN THE DEPARTMENT'S
REGULATIONS UNIT. THE
REGULATIONS UNIT WAS
ESTABLISHED APPROXIMATELY A
YEAR AND A HALF AGO WITH TWO
YEAR LIMITED TERM FUNDING AND
SINCE THEN THE UNIT HAS MADE
SOME GOOD PROGRESS IN IMPROVING
BOTH THE QUALITY AND TIMELINESS
OF PROCESSING REGULATIONS. AS
WELL AS PROVIDING TRAINING MORE
THAN TRIPLE THE NUMBER OF
REGULATIONS WERE FILED LAST
YEAR WITH THE STATE OFFICE OF
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW THAN IN THE
PRIOR YEAR. MORE REGULATIONS
WERE APPROVED AND BECAME LAW
LAST YEAR THAN IN PRIOR YEARS
AND ZERO WERE REJECTED BY THE
OFFICE STRICT LAW. SO GIVEN
THIS A POSITIVE PROGRESS THE
DEPARTMENT IS REQUESTING A TWO
YEAR FUNDING EXTENSION TO ALLOW
IT TO CONTINUE IMPLEMENTING AND
EVALUATING THE UNIT. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU CAN ASK. ANY
COMMENTS FROM THE ALLELES ARE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NO
CONCERNS FROM THE OHIO. OKAY
GREAT ARE THERE ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. MANAGER MR TO GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU I'M HAVING
TROUBLE WITH MY VIDEO AT THIS
MOMENT SO HOPEFULLY YOU CAN
HEAR ME BUT THERE IS- REALLY
WANT TO APPRECIATE THE THAT
REGULATORY UPDATE AND- IN
PARTICULAR IT'S GOOD TO SEE
THAT THE REGULATIONS AROUND AB
TWENTY ONE THIRTY EIGHT ARE
MOVING FORWARD AS WAS NOTED-
AND JUST FOR A LITTLE
BACKGROUND AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY
EIGHT WAS A BILL THAT I'D
AUTHORED IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
THAT REMOVES BARRIERS FOR
OCCUPATIONAL LICENSING FOR A
CLOSE TO SOME EIGHT MILLION
CALIFORNIANS THAT ARE LIVING
WITH CRIMINAL RECORDS WHAT I
WAS HOPING FOR WAS A LITTLE BIT
OF AN UPDATE ON WHERE THE
REGULATORY PACKAGES ARE IN THE
PROCESS HOW MANY ARE IN
DEVELOPMENT STILL WITH THE
DEPARTMENT FOR THE BOARD. HOW
MANY BEEN SUBMITTED TO- ALE AND
CARRIES WITH THE IMPACT OF THE
PANDEMIC HAS BEEN ON THE
REGULATIONS- AS YOU KNOW THIS
LAW WENT INTO EFFECT- THE
MIDDLE OF LAST YEAR GIVEN THE
VERY TIGHT THE VERY INTENSE JOB
MARKETS RIGHT NOW ONE SURE THAT
FOLKS THAT- HAVE A CRIMINAL
HISTORY THE BUT A READY TO WORK
WHO. IS A SHUTOUT ARE ABLE TO
ACCESS PROFESSIONAL LICENSES AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE SO JUST WANT
TO UNDERSTAND WHERE THINGS ARE
ON. THE REGULATORY PROCESS. YES
THEY HOW HAPPY TO ANSWER THANK
YOU FOR THAT QUESTION. I'M SO
WE- ARE WE HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY SEVEN
THIRTY EIGHT ABA MAKING
PACKAGES THAT REFLECT EACH OF
OUR DIFFERENT LICENSING BOARDS-
D. AS OF- EARLIER THIS MONTH WE
THERE WERE ABOUT. TWENTY NINE
PACKAGES THAT WERE ALREADY
SUBMITTED TO THE OFFICE STRIP
MARC. SEVEN HAVE ALREADY BEEN
APPROVED. NONE OF THEM HAVE
BEEN REJECTED AND THERE ARE NOT
MANY THAT ARE STILL PENDING
SUBMISSIONS. OFFICE WHICH- MADE
ME SOME VERY GOOD PROGRESS THE
MAJORITY OF THEM ARE ALREADY
THERE. ARE A FEW THAT ARE STILL
IN THE PROCESS ARE GETTING
PRETTY CLOSE TO. ANY ISSUE THAT
WE SHOULD BE AWARE OF OR IS IT
FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE IT SEEMS
LIKE THINGS ARE MOVING. AS IT
SHOULD. I THINK FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE THEY'RE MOVING AS
THEY SHOULD AS YOU AS YOU GO.
OUT MUCH OF THE- STATE
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES WERE.
IMPLEMENTED IN THE STATUTORY
LAW. AND SO THE BOARDS. ARMENT
BEGAN IMPLEMENTING JULY FIRST.
FACT AND THE AUTOMATICALLY.
AUTOMATICALLY RIGHT WELL LET ME
LET ME JUST SAY I WANT JUST
THANK YOUR OFFICE AS WELL AS
ALL THE VARIOUS BOARDS- AND-
THE STAKEHOLDERS AROUND THEM
FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS THIS IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT- THIS TIME
WE'RE TRYING TO GET PEOPLE.
INTO EMPLOYMENT SO I JUST
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MANAGER BACK TO YOU. THANK
YOU FOR THAT IF THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE WE CAN MOVE ON.
SEEING NONE WHERE NOW ON ISSUE
THANK YOU MR MARC GROFF- ISSUE
NUMBER SIX. THE BOARD OF YOUR
WORKLOAD OUR PANELISTS TODAY
INCLUDED PATRICK DORIA'S WITH
THE DEPARTMENT WITH THE BUREAU
OF AUTOMATIC WITH. AUTOMOTIVE
REPAIR. JUST CáC FUHRMAN WITH
THE BOARD OF VETERINARY
MEDICINE. JONATHAN BURKE THE
BOARD OF PSYCHOLOGY MICHAEL JIM
NEXT P. THE CONTRACTORS STATE
LICENSING BOARD. CHAIR MURPHY
BOARD OF OPTOMETRY INTEREST ON
A BURKE WITH ELLY ELLS OFFICE
AND KIA CHAU THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE YOU MAY BEGIN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS PATRICK PARADE CHIEF OF
THE BUREAU OF AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR.
ZERO REQUESTED. THREE MILLION
DOLLARS DOCUMENTATION OF THE
REPAIR ASSISTANCE SCHEDULE OF
THE HYPE WILL GET OVER THERE.
ACT WE ARE TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
TWO TWENTY TWO. AND ALSO FY.
TWENTY TWO TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE WHICH WOULD
INCREASE THE ANNUAL%
APPROPRIATION FOR THE REPAIRS
BUSINESS PROGRAM TO MILLION.
EIGHTY SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS.
PROCREATION WILL SUPPORT RECENT
CHANGES TO REGULATIONS THAT ARE
DESIGNED TO BENEFIT LOW INCOME
CONSUMERS. AND IMPROVE
CALIFORNIA'S AIR QUALITY ARE
SPECIFICALLY ANNUAL
EXPENDITURES FOR THE PAYROLL
SMOG CHECK REPAIR SYSTEMS
PROGRAM ARE EXPECTED TO BE ON
THE CURRENT SPENDING AUTHORITY
OF. THE MILLION. SEVEN HUNDRED
NINETY SIX THOUSAND. AND THE
COMING FISCAL YEAR THAT IS DUE
TO THE ANTICIPATED CLIMATE
ADOPTION OF EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS THAT WERE
IMPLEMENTED ON AUGUST THIRTY
FIRST LAST YEAR. THESE
REGULATIONS PROVIDE UP TO
TWELVE HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR
CONDITIONS REPAIRS. WITH MORE
THAN DOUBLE THE PREVIOUS AMOUNT.
AND CLUED OTHER CHANGES TO HELP
LOW INCOME CONSUMERS WITH SMOG
CHECK REPAIRS IN THEIR VEHICLES.
THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING WILL
ALLOW THE REPAIR OF
APPROXIMATELY SIXTY THREE
HUNDRED VEHICLES PER YEAR OVER
THREE TIMES. LAST YEAR'S
VOLATILE WHILE PROVIDING THE
CARE OF THE OPPORTUNITY TO
GATHER MORE DATA REGARDING THE
SCOPE OF CONSUMER DEMAND FOR
THE PROGRAM. UNDER THE NEW
REGULATIONS. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RESPECT RESPOND
TO THIS REQUEST. I AM AVAILABLE
ALONG WITH THE NEEDS CUNNINGHAM
WHO OVERSEES THE CONSUMER
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM AT THE PIER
ALL ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE. THANK YOU MISTER
DRAKE. WE HAVE A QUICK QUESTION
FOR YOU ACTUALLY TWO MISTER
LUCKY GO AHEAD. YEAH I SEE HERE
THAT THE- WHAT YOU'RE ASKING
FOR IS TWO POINT THREE MILLION
HELP ME UNDERSTAND WHY YOU. ARE
ONLY ASKING FOR TWO POINT THREE
WHEN YOU BELIEVE THAT THAT IT'S
LIKELY TO A DEMAND SEVEN
MILLION. BECAUSE HERE HERE'S
HERE'S MY FRUSTRATION IS I.
REPRESENT A DISTRICT THAT'S NOT
NECESSARILY. A FIELD WITH MANY
HIGH INCOME PEOPLE. AND SAW
THEIR INADVERTENTLY IMPACTED
WORSE THAN MOST PEOPLE BECAUSE-
AS INDICATED IN YOUR OWN NOTES
MANY LOW INCOME VEHICLE OWNERS
ARE UNABLE TO AFFORD REPAIRS
THE FALL IN THIS- INSPECTION
DEMAND KNOWS RESULT THEY
CONTINUE DRIVING THEIR
POLLUTING VEHICLE WITH EITHER
EXPIRED REGISTRATION TAGS. OR
FRAUDULENT CERTIFICATES THAT IS
A BAD SCENARIO THAT WE WOULD
LIKE TO- HELP BRING REMEDY
TOWARD. WHAT WE UNDERSTAND A
GOOD POINT I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT YEAH THAT THE NUMBERS
ARE TWO POINT THREE MILLION OF
THE CURRENTLY- ARE BUDGETED FOR
AND WE'RE ASKING FOR AN
INCREASE OF ABOUT TWO POINT
SEVEN MILLION. RAINING OUR
ANNUAL MOUNT FOR THE PROGRAM TO
A LITTLE OVER FIVE MILLION I
GUESS WE'LL JUST GATHER ALLOW
US MORE TIME TO GATHER
INFORMATION BUT LET RELATIVE
TO- CONSUMER PARTICIPATION AND
DEMAND FOR THE PROGRAM WE'VE
ALREADY SEEN- FIFTY ADOPTION OF
EMERGENCY REGULATIONS LAST
YEAR- OKAY. I'M REALLY HEALTHY
RESPONSE. THE NEW ARE MOUNTED
AND FAT IN REGULATE ASIAN UP TO
TWELVE HUNDRED DOLLARS A TIME
AS I POINTED OUT SO I THINK IT
GIVES US A CHANCE THAT IT. AND
FIND OUT WHAT OUR PARTICIPATION
RATE ALL RIGHT IT'S GOING TO BE
UNDER THE NEW REGULATIONS OKAY
DOPP STUDY ON BEFORE. THE END
OF THE YEAR. I WILL CONCERNS
OVER THIS DEFICIT BECAUSE IT
DOES. AS OUR PATROL MEMBER I
CAN TELL YOU IN A PORSCHE
CAPACITY THIS IS A BIG PROBLEM.
AND IT'S VERY VERY REAL IN MY
DISTRICT I DON'T KNOW ABOUT-
MANY OTHER DISTRICTS BUT
THERE'S A VERY REAL PROBLEM.
AND I THINK WE SHOULD BE BETTER
STEWARDS AND LISELOTTE IN THE
AT THE APPROPRIATE. FUNDING SO
THAT IT CAN BE FIXED. YES HOW
TO PART FINANCE- HE- U. S.
HEARING YES PLEASE GO AHEAD-
JUST OF THE IT'S POSSIBLE THAT
THE ACTUAL IMPLEMENTATION COST
ME BE HIGHER BUT THERE'S NO
HARD DATA TO SUPPORT THAT THIS
TIME IT'S JUST AN ESTIMATE SO
WE THINK THIS PROPOSAL- IT'S
IMPORTANT PURCHASE A LOT OF THE
BUREAU TO COLLECT DATA FROM
THIS YEAR AND NEXT YEAR TO
SUPPORT THE APPROPRIATE. LEVEL
AND- IF THE- YOU'RE A FINDS
THAT- YOU KNOW THE DEMAND IS-
VERY HIGHLY AND MORE IN
ADDITIONAL COSTS ARE NEEDED-
NOTHING FOR. OUR MAKING. OTHER
PLASTICS- MISTER COOPER. IT IS
A QUESTION SO IT'S OBVIOUSLY
GOING TO GO FROM BASICALLY
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED VEHICLES TO
OVER NINE THOUSAND I HEARD. A
BIT OF AN EXPLANATION OF LIFE
THAT'S THAT'S STILL PRETTY
DRAMATIC. MATCHES COULD BECAUSE
THE AGE OF THE VEHICLES ARE ARE
WHY. CORRECT I WOULD SAY THAT
THE NINE THOUSAND WAS AN
INITIAL ESTIMATE EARLY IN THE
EARLY DAYS OF THE PANDEMIC. I'M
LAST SPRING AND PRIOR TO
ADOPTION OF THE EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS LAST AUGUST. I DATA
GATHERED SINCE THE ADOPTION OF
THE REGULATIONS AND SUPPORT A
MORE MODEST PROJECTION OF ABOUT
SIX THOUSAND PEOPLE. THAT WAS
DRIVING UP THE DEMAND FOR
REPAIR ASSISTANCE. HELLO.
VEHICLES NEEDING FAILING THE
SMOG CHECK PROGRAM- AND WHEN
THEY'RE SMOG CHECK INSPECTION
AND NEEDING REPAIRS AND HAVING
A HIGHER DOLLAR AMOUNT THAT WE
NOW- WHAT AIMED TOWARDS- AIR.
PREVIOUSLY OF THE SENATE
CAPITAL CAPITAL FIVE DOLLARS
RIGHT THAT MEANS THAT THE
PROGRAM INCEPTION BACK IN THE
EARLY TWO THOUSANDS. HAVE BEEN
MODIFIED. I TIME. AFTER REPAIRS
THE VEHICLE THAT WE- YOUR
ATTENTION HADN'T MODIFY TWENTY
YEARS AND YET WE'RE PAYING TO
BUY ELECTRIC. IN AND GIVING
REBATES FOR THAT WHICH IS WHICH
IS TOTALLY ARE IRONIC SO I
COMMEND YOU GUYS ON UPPING THE
REPAIRS A TWELVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS BUT STILL WHAT PERCENT
OF VEHICLES DO WE SEE THAT ARE
NOT REPAIRABLE THAT HAVE TO BE
PULLED OFF THE ROAD. I DON'T
HAVE THAT INFORMATION IN FRONT
OF ME OF CERTAINLY CAN PROVIDE
THE NUMBER OF VEHICLES MAKE
YEAH- HELLO SMOG INSPECTION.
THE PUBLIC THIS. INCREASE
AMOUNT WILL ALLOW MORE
CONSUMERS TO BE ABLE TO COMPLY
WITH THE VEHICLE REGISTRATION
REQUIREMENT NOT OUT. I'M
REGISTERED A FUNDING ROUND
THANK YOU SO AS AS I READ THE
REPORT A LOT OF FOLKS JUST
CONTINUE TO DRIVE THOSE
VEHICLES AROUND. AND DON'T
REGISTER THEM CORRECT. I THAT
IS OPTION IS A POP IF NOT YEAH
YEAH. WE'RE TRYING. WHAT HOPE
THAT WITH THE DAHLE AMOUNT THAT
LIKELY TO HAPPEN OKAY. I DON'T
I'M NOT SURE. IF THERE'S A-
HEAD INFORMATION RESPECT TO
LICENSES I APPRECIATE THAT BUT
YOU CAN'T HAVE IT BOTH WAYS
BECAUSE IN THE REPORT IS THAT.
THE PEOPLE CAN STILL CONTINUE
TO DRIVE THEIR CARS AROUND. SO
THAT'S THE SUDDEN OBVIOUSLY
THEY ARE WE KNOW THEY ARE I
MEAN IT'S NOT LIKE YOU ABOUT IT
SO CONTINUE TO DRIVE THAT AND
POLLUTE I GUESS THE BIG ISSUE
HERE IS THE MEDIAN AGE OF THE
VEHICLE PER DIEM V. IN
CALIFORNIA IS FOURTEEN YEARS
OLD SO SAY SOMEONE'S CAR CAN'T
BE REPAIRED DO YOU GIVE THEM
MONEY TOWARDS A NEW CAR-
PURCHASING A NEW. A NEW CAR.
THERE ARE PROGRAMS IN TWO ALSO
RETIRED VEHICLES THAT DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE TO REPAIR THE
VEHICLE AND THAT'S AN OPTION
YEAH RIGHT BUT IN. HER AND YES
THERE ARE PROGRAMS RUN. YOU
INSTEAD OF A- ADVERTISE VEHICLE
BY PUTTING THE VEHICLE OWNER IN
A NEWER CLEANER VEHICLE BUT WAS
THERE A PROBLEM HERE. RUNNING
CONCERT WITH EACH RESOURCES BUT
THE ISSUE IS THAT WE'RE WE'RE
WE'RE THIS IS BACKWARDS THAT
IS. ADULTS FORTY DOUBLES LIKE
SAID FORTY THE AVERAGE JUST
MANAGES FOURTEEN YEARS OLDER.
MOST FOLKS DON'T HAVE A CAR
PAYMENT. THEY CAN OF A CAR. SO
IF YOU READ THERE VIA. IF THE
FUNDS ARE OUT THERE TO GIVE
THEM MONEY. THEY'RE NOT GONNA
BUY A NEW VEHICLE BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T AFFORD A CAR PAYMENT. IN
THIS YEAR CLOVIS ABOUT
SURVIVABILITY IT'S ABOUT PAYING
YOUR MORTGAGE OR RENT. PUTTING
FOOD ON YOUR TABLE IN YOUR
UTILITY BILLS IN CALIFORNIA OUR
UTILITY BILLS OR 45% HIGHER
THAN THE REST OF THE COUNTRY
AND WE'RE ABOUT TO GO ALL
ELECTRIC TO THE RICH GROWING UP
HIGHER GAS IS A DOLLAR MORE
GALLON IN CALIFORNIA ANYWHERE
ELSE IN THE COUNTRY SO WHAT
WHEN I SAY THAT IT'S- YOU KNOW
AND THEN WE HAVE THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER. WHERE THERE'S NO SALES
OF GASOLINE VEHICLES STARTING
IN TWENTY THIRTY FIVE IN
CALIFORNIA SO FOR THESE
WHATEVER THIS PERSON IS THAT
DRUG IS A VEHICLES THAT ARE
POOR ARE IMMIGRANTS ARE SINGLE
MOTHERS WITH CHILDREN. THEY
CAN'T AFFORD A NEWER VEHICLE
THEY CAN'T AFFORD A CAR PAYMENT
THEY CAN'T AFFORD THE V. FLOWS
WERE CALIFORNIA IS BASS
AFTERWARDS WHEN THEY DO THIS
AND THEY PAY YOU TO BUY ANY V.
BUT YET YOUR OLD CAR THAT'S A
CLUNKER. YOU KNOW IT'S JUST
IT'S MIND NUMBING STILL YOU
GUYS DID A GOOD JOB THANK YOU
BUT WE'VE GOT IT WE'RE GONNA
JUSTICE SOMEHOW AND GET PUT IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION HEALTH
ADMINISTRATION. WILL WILL DO
THAT. THANK MANAGER. THANK YOU
MISTER COOPER MCCARTY
TRANSACTION COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU- MYSTERY I THINK WHAT
YOU'RE HEARING IS JUST- A
LITTLE BIT OF FOR OF
FRUSTRATION IN TERMS OF. IDEALS
AND GOALS THAT THE STATE HAS
VERSUS THE REALITY OF FOLKS ON
THE GROUND AND WHAT WE WANTED
SHE VERSUS WHAT IS- AN
OPPORTUNITY AT THE MOMENT AND
SO I THINK THIS. THIS IS A AN
INTERESTING CONVERSATION I MAY
REQUIRE US TO LOOK AT IT A
LITTLE BIT A LITTLE BIT MORE IN
TERMS OF WHAT CAN WHAT CAN WE
POTENTIALLY DO TO BE ABLE TO
ACHIEVE. WHAT THE STATE CALLS
ARE SO THANK YOU FOR THAT-
LET'S HEAR FROM THE ADDITIONAL
PANEL- SMITH SACRAMENTO YOU
WANT TO GO AHEAD. I THINK YOU
KNOW GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS JUST AS THE FROM AND
THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE
VETERINARY MEDICAL BOARD. I
THINK FUNDING FOR THREE
POSITIONS THE STAFF MEMBERS
MENTOR ONE IS A STATE PROGRAM.
ADULT AND GOVERNMENT PROGRAM
ANALYST. AND AN OFFICE
TECHNICIAN. JUST OFFICIALLY
ADDRESSED OVERSIGHT
PROBATIONARY WORK WITH EIGHTY
P. N. O. T. BEING REQUESTED AS
ADDRESS THE LISTING AND ONGOING
PREPARATION REQUIRED. FUNDING
FINANCES AND ONE IS REQUESTED
ON A TWO YEAR LIMITED TERM
BASIS TO PROVIDE SUFFICIENT
OVERSIGHT. FOR THE SIX LIMITED
TERM ANALYSTS RECEIVED IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY. TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BCP FOR DRESS BACK LOCKS.
AFTER TWO YEARS THE BORDER
RECESSES WORKLOAD AND ME A
DRESS ONGOING NEEDS IN THE
FUTURE PCP. THANK YOU CHRIS SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AN
OPPORTUNITY COME BEFORE YOU.
HAVING TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. I JUST HAVE ONE FOR
YOU MISSY FOR MEN- CAN YOU
EXPLAIN- WHY THERE HAS BEEN
SUCH A HUGE INCREASE IN
CONSUMER CONF- COMPLAINTS.
ABOUT 72% INCREASE. YEAH AND SO
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE DATA IT
LOOKS LIKE IT CORRELATES
EXACTLY WHEN FOR WHEN WE WENT
LIVE AND BRINGS IN JANUARY OF
TWENTY SIXTEEN. THAT'S WHEN YOU
START SEEING THAT THAT DRAMATIC
INCREASE AND WE BELIEVE IT'S
BECAUSE IT'S MUCH MORE IT'S
MUCH EASIER FOR CONSUMERS TO
FILE COMPLAINTS ONLINE. AND
ALSO FROM LICENSEES AND IT'S
MUCH MORE STREAMLINED THEY
DON'T HAVE TO PRINT OUT A
COMPLETE FORM FILL IT OUT AND
MAIL IT IN TO US IT'S MUCH MORE
CONVENIENT. WOULD YOU BELIEVE
IT IS TIED TO THE AVAILABILITY
AND ACCESSIBILITY. OF BEING
ABLE TO FILE A COMPLAINT THAT
MY- CAN YOU SHARE JUST ME BEING
A COUPLE OF DETAILS IF YOU CAN
IN TERMS OF WHAT THE COMPLAINTS
HAVE BEEN ABOUT. SURE IT WAS SO
WHEN WE LOOK AT THEM IN THIS IS
IT IT LOOKS LIKE IT'S STILL
CONSISTENT WITH THE NUMBER OF
COMPLAINTS THAT WE'RE GETTING
IT'S AT ABOUT 75% OF THEM.
ALLEGING THINGS SUCH AS
UNPROFESSIONAL CONDUCT
INCOMPETENCE AND NEGLIGENCE AND
SO IT'S STILL. A PRETTY BIG
AMOUNT OF CASES THAT REQUIRE A
LOT MORE THE INVESTIGATION SUCH
MATTER EXPERTS REVIEWING
MEDICAL RECORDS. I'M AND THINGS
LIKE THAT SO IT IS A HUGE
INCREASE BUT THEY'RE ALSO.
ALLEGES CONCERNS THAT TKE
QUITE A BIT OF TIME TO
INVESTIGATE. THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THAT CALIFORNIA
HAPPENS TO BE ONE OF THE
STATE'S THAT SPENDS THE MOST
MONEY WHEN IT COMES TO- ISSUES
RELATING TO PETS. SO IT'S VERY
INTERESTING TO SEE THE TYPE OF
OR TO HEAR THE TYPE OF
COMPLAINTS. THAT YOU HAVE BEEN
RECEIVING AND TERM AND I AM I'M
A DOG OWNER I YOU KNOW I LUIS
IS. VERY FAMOUS AROUND HERE AND
WITH FRIENDS. BUT IT IT'S IT I
THINK ABOUT- I THINK ABOUT
FOLKS THAT TRY THEIR BEST TO
TAKE CARE OF THEIR PETS AND-
MAY NOT BE RECEIVING THE
QUALITY OF CARE WITH THEIR
VETERINARIANS AND MANY OF WHOM
ALSO DO A LOT OF PRO BONO WORK
AND A LOT OF WORK IN LOW
INCOME. COMMUNITIES TO TRY TO
STAY IN NEUTER- THEIR PETS AND
SO I APPRECIATE THE FEEDBACK
AND HOPEFULLY WERE ABLE TO
FIGURE OUT WAYS THAT. THROUGH
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS IN THE
BUDGET PROCESS WE IMPROVE THOSE
NUMBERS. THANK YOU FOR THAT TO
AND DOES ANYBODY ELSE HAVE ANY.
QUESTIONS OKAY. THANK YOU MISTY
FIRMIN WILL MOVE ON TO- MR
JOTHAM BURKE- THE BOARD OF
PSYCHOLOGY. THE NEW MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS JONATHAN BUCKNER I'M
CONSISTENT EXECUTIVE OFFICER
BOARD OF PSYCHOLOGY. POLICE
REQUESTING TOOL WILL COMMENCE
THIS EXPERT WITNESS IN COURT
REPORTER BUDGETS TO BE TACTFUL
EXPENDITURES. EXPERT WITNESSES
AND COURT REPORTERS ARE A
CRITICAL COMPONENT OF THE
VOTING FOR PROGRAM. WHEN A
COMPLAINT IS RECEIVED BY THE
BOARD EXPERT WITNESSES A
UTILIZED ONCE THE BOARD
COMPLETES ITS INVESTIGATION. TO
DETERMINE WHETHER THE LICENSEE
OR REGISTRANT MY DEPARTURE FROM
THE STANDARD OF CARE. CALL
REPORTERS I NEEDED FOR OFFICIAL
DOCUMENTATION DURING
FORBEARANCE PATIENCE. BEFORE
THE BOARD. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THE TRUCK I'M
HAPPY TO ANNOUNCE ANY- THE
COMMITTEE FIRST ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS. NO
OKAY I ACTUALLY HAVE A QUESTION
FOR YOU- MR BURKE HOW DOES THE
PORCHES TO REQUEST AN EXPERT WE
WITNESS FOR A CASE. THE BOLD
YOU CLASSES EXPERTS TO REVIEW
CASES- THAT INCLUDE AND ARE NOT
LIMITED TO PATIENTS- PRACTICING
OUTSIDE OF COMPETENCY CHILD
CUSTODY CASES- NEGLIGENCE FOR
UNLICENSED PRACTICE. DESK
ENFORCEMENT ANALYSTS CONDUCT A
THOROUGH REVIEW OF ALL CASE
MATERIALS TO DETERMINE SEEDING
WITH THE NEXT BUS IS NEEDED.
FULL SET OUT A LIST OF NOT
LICENSE LIKE COLLEGES TO MANY
OF THE CASES ARE COMPLEX AND
REQUIRE EXPERT REVIEW BY
LICENSEE WITH EXPERTISE IN THE
AREA OF THE COMPLAINT. OF THE
PROFESSIONAL STANDARDS OF
PRACTICE. GREAT THANK YOU. I'M
SORRY THAT I WERE YOU DONE.
OKAY GREAT THANK YOU FINO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE WE
CAN MOVE ON THANK YOU MISTER
BURKE LET'S GO WITH MISTER
MICHAEL JIM NEXT THINK- AND
PLEASE HELP ME PRONOUNCE YOUR
NAME CORRECTLY BUT THE
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSING
BOARD. GOOD AFTERNOON IT'S
MAKING JAM THAT SKI WITH THE
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE BOARD
LEGISLATIVE DIVISION AND WITH
ME HERE ON SCREEN IS JUST IN
THE PRODUCT THE- LICENSING
DIVISION. AND THE BCP BEFORE
YOU TODAY WOULD ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO-
CAN'T. SEE ME A CONSTRUCTION
MANAGEMENT EDUCATION ACCOUNT
APPROPRIATION IN A GIVEN YEAR
BASED ON WHAT'S ACTUALLY AND
THE ACCOUNT. CONTRACTORS STATE
LICENSE BOARD HAS AN ACCOUNT IN
THE BUDGET BILL THAT FROM
PRIORITY SEPARATE. FROM ITS
SPECIAL FINE CALL CONSTRUCTION
MANAGEMENT EDUCATION ACCOUNT.
FUNDED ENTIRELY BY DONATIONS
AND JUST AS IT SOUNDS OF THE
NATION'S GO TO CONSTRUCTION
MANAGEMENT EDUCATION
EXPERIENCE. QUALIFYING PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS WE ARE
ABSOLUTELY AVAILABLE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS. AND WE DO APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME. TO THE MEMBERS OF
COMMITTEE HAVE ANY QUESTION OR
CALL. NO OKAY SEEN NONE AT
THANK YOU FOR THAT MISTER TO
NEXT DAY WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THAT THE NEXT
PANELIST MISS CHERYL MURPHY
WITH THE BOARD OF THE PALM TREE.
SHARES OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS SERVING AND I'M
THINKING OF OFFICER FOR THE
STATE OR THE COUNTRY. POSIBLE
FOR YOU TODAY I SIXTY ON. TO
FIND. EXAM DEVELOPMENT AND
VALIDATION COSTS TO INSURE THE
POOR TASK FOR MEDICAL EXAMPLE
COMPETENCY FOR LICENSURE
ONGOING EXAM DEVELOPMENT IS
CRITICAL AS EXAM QUESTIONS
BECOME FAMILIAR AND THIS
FUNDING WILL ALLOW FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF ROBUST THANK
ATTACHED QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
THIS REQUEST TODAY AND OF.
COURSE HAPPY ANSWER ANY OF YOUR
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU FOR THAT
MISTER MURPHY TO THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. NOW
SEAMAN. YOUR OFF THE HOT SEAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY THANK YOU.
FOR BEING A PALACE I'M SORRY A
NEXT PERSON. ACTUALLY LET'S ACT
LET'S SEE IF- MISTER SADDAM
BURKE WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE OR MYSKINA
CHAU THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
OF ANY COMMENTS ON ANY OF THE
PANELISTS. FOR LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE DIDN'T
IDENTIFY ANY CONCERNS WITH THE
PROPOSALS PRESENTED. MICHELLE.
NOT A PROBLEM FINANCES NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS GREAT OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL
MOVE ON TOWARDS THE NEXT ISSUE
WHICH IS LEGISLATIVE WORKLOAD
AGAIN WE HAVE- MISTER MURPHY
WITH THE BOARD OF ATOMIC TREE
GENUS ON CZYCE WITH CEMETERY
AND FUNERAL BUREAU SUSAN SAILOR
WITH THE STRUCTURAL PEST
CONTROL BOARD AND DREW SADDAM
BURKE WITH ELLY ELLS AND CAME
CHAU THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
GO AHEAD MISS MURPHY. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
ON WEDNESDAY- BUT- IN FRONT OF
YOU IS ABOUT TO CHANGE PROPOSAL
TO IMPLEMENT VERSIONS OF
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT NINE SIX
THE STATE BOARD OF OPTOMETRY
HAS LONG SUPPORTED IMPROVE
ACCESS TO CARE. YOU SEE BEFORE
YOU TODAY AS THE MINIMUM
STAFFING NEEDED TO ENSURE
QUALITY CARE FOR UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES AND RELIABLE
OVERSIGHT OF SERVICES OR
MATERIALS ARE UNSATISFACTORY.
FOURTEEN IF REQUESTED. OKAY.
LET'S GO LET'S MOVE FORWARD
SEEN NINE LET'S MOVE FORWARD
WITH THAT MISS SANCHEZ WITH THE
CEMETERY AND FUNERAL BUREAU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
CARILLO AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS GINA
SANCHEZ AND I'M THE BUREAU
CHIEF FOR THE CEMETERY AND
FUNERAL ZERO. THE REQUESTED FOR
YOU TODAY IS PERHAPS AUDITOR
POSITION TO ADDRESS THE
WORKLOAD RELATED TO THE
REQUIREMENTS OF CHAPTER THREE
OH NINE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN.
AB SEVEN NINETY FIVE. WHICH
ALLOWS CEMETERIES THAT HOLD
FUNDS IN THE INDICTMENT CARE
TRUST FUND TO CONVERT FROM A
NET INCOME DISTRIBUTION METHOD.
TO UNIT TRUSTS DISTRIBUTION
MARKET. UNIT TRUST PROVIDES
MORE FLEXIBILITY IN ASSET
MANAGEMENT AND ENCOURAGES
TRUSTEES TO MAXIMIZE THE TOTAL
ASSETS OF THESE CHEST. THAT'S
POTENTIALLY PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL MONEY FOR THE CARE
AND MAINTENANCE OF OUR
CALIFORNIA LICENSE CEMETERY.
AUDITOR POSITION IMPLEMENT THE
PROGRAM. APPROVED CONVERSION
APPLICATIONS THAT TRACK AND
MONITOR COMPLIANCE THE
CEMETERIES ON ANNUAL BASIS. AND
PROVIDE A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON THE PROGRAM
DURING OUR NEXT TO SENSE THAT
HEARINGS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THIS REQUEST
AND I'M HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU FOR THAT
AND SENILE ADDITIONAL FROM THE
COMMITTEE LET'S MOVE FORWARD
WITH THE NEXT PANELIST SUSAN
SAILOR WITH THE STRUCTURAL PEST
CONTROL BOARD. I AM CAPTAIN
MADAM CHAIR CARRILLO AND
MEMBERS OF THE TRAINING. MANY
SEASON SAILOR AND I IN THE
TICKET THE TICKET OFFICER FOR
THE STRUCTURAL PEST CONTROL
BOARD. WITHIN THE TECH MAKERS
AMERICARES- MORTGAGEE CLAUSE
RECHARGE TO IMPLEMENT AN EIGHTY
TWO ONE THIRTY EIGHT. I THOUGHT
FOR YOU GAME. ONE STATION ON A
THREE YEAR LIMITED BASIS. THE
FACILITY AND MANY AB TWENTY ONE
THIRTY EIGHT. THE AND OBTAIN
APPLICATION APPLICANTS CRIMINAL
HISTORIES. AND MONITOR
PROBATIONERS. FORD HAS
APPLICANTS PLACE WITH A HIGH
NEAR OF CLEAN CONVICTION BACK.
AND NOT MAJORITY INCREASE IN
WORKLOAD. WITH EXISTING
RESOURCES. DEPARTURE QUESTIONS
COULD BECAUSE AND PUBLIC SAFETY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDER
EVENT ACROSS HIM HITTING ANY
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU MISS
TAYLOR ACTUALLY DO HAVE A
QUESTION FOR YOU BUT FIRST MAY
GO TO THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. NOW I CAN SHARE- YES
GO AHEAD MR TO. GREAT THANK YOU
SO MUCH- PROBABLY NOT A
SURPRISE THAT I'LL BE ASKING
THE QUESTION WE SPOKE EARLIER
ABOUT AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY
EIGHT AND- DISCUSSED THE FACT
THAT- DOZENS OF OTHER BOARDS
WERE ABLE TO DO THIS WORK-
WITHOUT HIRING AN ANALYST- AND
I HAVE TO ADMIT- YOU KNOW AS
WAS LAID OUT IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS NOT ONLY DID THE
BUDGET STAFF. NOTE THAT IT'S
INCONSISTENT WITH THE
APPROPRIATIONS ANALYSIS FROM
THIS BILL BUT- GOTTA ASK WHY
YOU'RE REQUESTING THIS POSITION
BASICALLY TO GO TO COURT HOUSES.
WHAT WAS CRIMINAL RECORDS IF
YOU CAN GET. BESTEST
FINGERPRINTING CRIMINAL HISTORY
ALREADY AND I'LL JUST NOTE YOUR
BOARD WASN'T DOING THIS BEFORE-
AND SO WITH THIS PARTICULAR
REQUEST AT THIS TIME- IS IT
SURPRISING AND FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE- I AND I DON'T SEE
THE JUSTIFICATION FOR IT- JANET
POSITION QUESTIONS AWESOME
CHIEF FOR INCREASED.
APPLICATIONS THAT WE INTERESTED
IN HAVING- DEMOCRATS
PETITIONERS THAT'S ALREADY
INCREASED FOR THE FIRST QUARTER
AND THE FISCAL YEAR. AND WE
EXPECT AND WE EXPECTED. TO
CONTINUE TRENDING- THAT MINIMUM
QUALIFICATIONS FOR OUR ENTRY
LEVEL POSITION- IS EIGHTEEN
YEARS OF AGE AND THAT'S THE
ONLY NUMBER REQUIREMENT. SILVA
JULY. APPLICANTS WITH CRIMINAL
HISTORIES. SO I APPRECIATE THAT
I THINK THAT'S ALSO TRUE FOR
OTHER BOARDS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT AND AGAIN I WOULD JUST
NOTE THAT YOUR BOARD DIDN'T
OBTAIN CRIMINAL RECORDS FROM
COURTHOUSES- NO BEFORE AB
TWENTY ONE THIRTY EIGHT AND-
AND YOU CAN GET A LOT OF THIS
INFORMATION AROUND CRIMINAL
HISTORY FROM D. O. J. C. DON'T
REALLY ACTUALLY ANSWER MY
QUESTION AROUND. EITHER OF
THOSE TWO POINTS. WELL I WERE
ON THE TRAIN BUT WE'RE ALSO
DOING WATER AND IT IS
REQUESTING. AN ACTUAL PROJECT
PRESIDENT OF THE DOCUMENT CARE
ACT EVIDENCE. Q. EVALUATE IF
THE IF. WERE ELLAGIC OUR
LICENSING. AND ARE YOU SAY THAT
SOME YOU NEED TO THAT STEP FROM
WHAT OTHER BOARDS HAVE DO. ONE
NOT SOMETHING THAT'S DIFFERENT
I'M ASSUMING THAT MOST
PREVENTIVA DCA ARGUING THAT.
OKAY WELL AGAIN I DON'T WANT TO
BELABOR THE POINT BUT I JUST
POINT OUT THAT YOU KNOW I
CERTAINLY WILL HAVE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS FOR THIS IF THIS IF
THIS AT B. C. B. CONTINUES SO
JUST WANNA FLAG INTO THE RECORD
AND WE'LL OBVIOUSLY KEEP
DISCUSSING THIS. MEASURE THANK
YOU CAN TRY TO FINANCE- MISTER
IF YOU CHAU HEADMISTRESS. I
DON'T WANT TO- THE- AB TWENTY
ONE THIRTY THIRTY EIGHT THE
BOARD- DID REQUIRE APPLICANTS
WITH CRIMINAL BACKGROUNDS TO
PROVIDE THEIR RECORDS UNDER AB
TWENTY ONE THIRTY EIGHT THE
POOR WILL NEED TO REQUEST
INFORMATION IF NOT CAN IT DOES
NOT VOLUNTEER TO PROVIDE THIS
INFORMATION OR TO CONTACT THEM
AND- REQUEST MEDICAID
INFORMATION SO THEY DON'T HAVE.
THE WORK DONE THIS BEFORE AND
THEY NEED PART OF THIS POSITION
IS- AS MENTIONED MMHM YOU KNOW.
FOR THIS WORKLOAD. THE OTHER
PART OF POSITIONS ALL. A TO
HELP WITH THEIR- WHAT. WHICH
WHICH AGAIN I APPRECIATE I'M
JUST UNDERSTAND HOW THIS BOARD
IS DIFFERENT FROM ALL THE OTHER
BOARDS THAT SEEM TO BE ABLE TO
DO THIS WORK WITHOUT THIS
WITHOUT THE ADDITIONAL-
EXPENDITURE REQUEST AND IT
SEEMS THAT THE WAY THEY'RE
GOING ABOUT IT IS- IT IS PRETTY
INEFFICIENT COMPARED TO HOW
OTHER BOARDS ARE DOING. I WOULD
NOTE LAST YEAR WE JUST HAVE TO
BE REQUEST FROM- THREE OTHER
BOARDS- TO THEM WITH A SIMILAR
REQUEST THIS ONE AS WELL. OKAY
WELL AGAIN LET'S SO LET'S KEEP
TALKING ABOUT IT- I'M
OBVIOUSLY- INTERESTED IN IN
THIS. THANK YOU MR CHIU- AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR QUESTIONS
ACTUALLY WERE VERY IN LINE WITH
WHAT I WAS GOING TO ASK AS WELL
SO I APPRECIATE YOU- ASKING
THOSE- LET'S GO TO THE BEFORE
WE MOVE ON TO THE NEXT- THE
NEXT PANEL ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS FROM- THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. SORT OF BORED
WITH THE L. A. O. NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME. GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
TO THE PANEL WE'RE GONNA MOVE
ON TO- ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT. A
RELATED TO CALIFORNIA ARTS
COUNCIL OUR PANEL OF FOR THIS
ISSUE AREA WILL BE AND BROWN
I'M SORRY AND BILL CRAWFORD
WITH CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL.
ADDRESS ON A BURKE WITH ELLY
ELLS OFFICE AND AMY JARVIS WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
HELLO THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- I'M INBOUND
CRAWFORD I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA ARTS
COUNCIL. THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY
BUDGET PROPOSES THE CREATION OF
THE CALIFORNIA CREATIVE CORE HI
THE PROGRAM. THIS PROGRAM IS TO
BE A STATEWIDE PUBLIC AWARENESS
CAMPAIGNS USING VARIOUS MESSAGE
METHODS TO FUEL POSITIVITY
REGAIN PUBLIC TRUST AND INSPIRE
SAFE AND HEALTHY BEHAVIOR IN
ORDER TO STOP THE SPREAD OF
COVERT NINETEEN. WITHIN OUR
HARDEST HIT COMMUNITIES.
MANAGED BY THE CALIFORNIA ARTS
COUNCIL THIS PILOT WILL HAVE
CALIFORNIA ARTISTS USING
DIFFERENT MEDIUMS TO PROMOTE
PUBLIC HEALTH AWARENESS. IN THE
HOPES TO PREVENT THE SPREAD OF
THE VIRUS. SURMODICS THE
PROCESS BY WHICH THE COUNCIL
WILL ALLOCATE FUNDS. THE
COUNCIL FIRST USER DECISION
SUPPORT TOOL FOR LOCAL
ASSISTANCE GRANT FUNDS TO
DETERMINE HOW THE PROGRAM WILL
BE ADMINISTERED I THERE IS A
DIRECT PROGRAM OF THE C. A. C.
RESERVE PROGRAM COORDINATED
THROUGH A RE GRANTING PROCESS.
BASED ON THAT DECISION ONE OF
THE FOLLOWING METHODOLOGIES
WILL BE HERE. IF COUNCIL
DETERMINES THE AGENCY SHOULD
ADMINISTER THE PROGRAM ITSELF
THE C. A. C. WERE USED YOUR
JUDICATA AND SCORED PROCESS
THAT WE HAVE ESTABLISHED FOR
ALL OF OUR GRANTS. SPECIFIC
REVIEW CRITERIA WILL BE
DEVELOPED FOR THE PROGRAM AND
ITS HANDLE OF ART EXPERTS WILL
BE ASSEMBLED AS FIELD
REPRESENTATIVES TO REVIEW AND
SCORE EACH APPLICATION BASED ON
THE CRITERIA. THE CDC USES A
SIX POINT RANKING SCALE AT THE
CONCLUSION OF THE PANEL PROCESS
EACH RANKED APPLICANT WILL BE
PROVIDED. TO THE COUNCIL FOR
FINAL ALLOCATION OF FUNDS FOR
INDIVIDUAL GRANT O'ROURKE. IF
THE COUNCIL DETERMINES THAT THE
PROGRAM SHOULD BE ADMINISTERED
THROUGH LOCAL REGIONAL RE
GRANTING PROCESS THE
ADMINISTRATION ORGANIZATIONAL
RECEIVED FUNDS AS AN ARGUMENT
TO FIX CURRENT C. A. C. ARMS.
THOSE ORGANIZATIONS WILL
DEVELOP. A RE GRANTING
PROCESSING. USING A TAILORED
VERSION OF THE C. A. SEIZE
DECISION SUPPORT TOOL THAT'LL
BE MONITORED BY THE CAAC TO
ENSURE EQUITABLE DISTRIBUTION
OF THE FUNDS TO THE ARTISTS.
THE COUNCIL WILL ALSO BE
LOOKING AT BEST PRACTICES SUCH
AS THOSE DEVELOPED BY THE
UNIVERSITY OF FLORIDA. AND
INCORPORATING THESE PRACTICES
INTO THE GRANT PROGRAM. ARTS
AND PUBLIC HEALTH RESEARCH AND
BEST PRACTICES WILL BE
HIGHLIGHTED IN THE PROGRAM PLAN
SPECIFIC RESEARCH WILL BE CITED
AND RELEVANT FRAMEWORK WORKS
WILL BE DEVELOPED. FOR EXAMPLE
COLLABORATIVE STRATEGIES TO
REACH TRUSTED COMMUNITY ARTISTS
WILL BE PRIORITIZED INVITE PART
COMMUNITIES. ADDRESSING
REALITIES SUCH AS MEDICAL
MISTRUST STRUCTURAL INEQUITIES
AND GENERATIONAL TRAUMA.
COLLABORATIONS WITH TRUSTED
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS AND
CLINICS WILL BE EMPLOYED TO
GUIDE THE STRATEGIES EMPLOYED
BY PARTICIPATING ARTISTS. EVEN
WITH THE DEVASTATING IMPACTS OF
KROGER NINETEEN CALIFORNIA ARTS
ECOSYSTEM IS AMONG THE MOST
POWERFUL AND MOST REALLY RICH
IN THE WORLD AND SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED INVESTED IN AND
LEVERAGE. I'M HERE TODAY WITH
MY DIRECTOR OF LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS CHRISTIAN MARGOLIS AND
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU FOR THAT- CAN
WE HEAR FROM THE ELLY ELLS
OFFICE AS WELL AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. TRUE
SAID ABOARD LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. IN LOOKING AT
THIS PROPOSAL. OUR OFFICE
BELIEVES THAT THE USE OF ART TO
PROMOTE PUBLIC HEALTH MESSAGES.
MISSING PRACTICE THAT IS WORTH
EXAMINING HOWEVER WITH RESPECT
TO SOME OF THE DETAILS OF
PROPOSAL WE FEEL THAT THERE ARE
SOME KEY UNANSWERED QUESTIONS
FOR EXAMPLE AT THIS POINT AS
YOU HEARD IT'S A BIT UNCLEAR
PRECISELY HOW THE GRANT WOULD
BE ADMINISTERED WHETHER IT
WOULD BE C. A. C. ADMINISTERING
AT A STATEWIDE LEVEL MORE IF
THEY PARTNER WITH LOCAL OR
REGIONAL PARTNERS TO DIRECT
FUNDS DIRECTLY TO ARTISTS. OR
COMBINATION OF THE TWO- THERE'S
PROS AND CONS OF EACH APPROACH
FOR EXAMPLE WHO IS ADMINISTERED
AT A STATEWIDE LEVEL- IT'S MORE
LIKELY THAT THE PROGRAM WOULD
BE- UNIFORM AND ITS-
APPLICATION ACROSS THE STATE.
WHERE IS IF IT WAS-
ADMINISTERED CLOSER TODAY
COMMUNITIES THAT'S TARGETED
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT THE LOCAL
PARTNERS WOULD HAVE MORE
INSIGHT INTO THE COMMUNITIES
THAT THE ARTIST BEING TARGETED
AT. PROBLEM THERE'S ALSO A LOT
OF QUESTIONS ABOUT PRECISELY
HOW THE FORMS WOULD BE OUT
ALLOCATED SO- CDC INDICATES
THAT WE'RE GOING TO TARGET
COMMUNITIES MOST IMPACTED BY
CODE NINETEEN INCLUDING
HISTORICALLY MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES. BUT THERE'S A FEW
THINGS WE DON'T KNOW SUCH AS
WHAT OTHER CRITERIA WILL BE
CONSIDERED OR HOW THESE
CRITERIA. WILL BE WEIGHED
AGAINST ONE ANOTHER. WELL
THERE'S ALSO ABOUT HOW MANY
WILL BE REACHED. THE OUR
UNDERSTAND THAT OUR COUNCIL
HOPING WORK WITH FIVE RD. AND
OKAY EIGHT. AT POINT IT'S WILL
UNCLEAR AS TO HOW MANY PEOPLE
WILL BE EXPOSED TO THE ARTWORK
THAT WOULD BE. SUPPORTED THIS
MAKES IT DIFFICULT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO BE ABLE TO
COMPARE THE STRATEGY TO OTHER
STRATEGIES THAT MIGHT HAVE
MIGHT CONSIDER SUCH AS
ADVERTISING. IT'S ALSO A BIT
UNCLEAR HOW THE MATCHING
REQUIREMENT WOULD WORK. BOB
IT'S UNCLEAR SO BASICALLY WHO
WOULD BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
IDENTIFYING THE MATCHING FUNDS
AND IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO GET CLARITY ON
THIS BECAUSE THE MATCHING
REQUIREMENT COULD
UNNECESSARILY. LIMIT THE TYPE
AND NUMBER OF ARTISTS WHO ARE
ABLE TO APPLY FOR THE GRANTS-
AT THIS POINT WE WOULD
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WITHHOLD ACTION ON THE PROPOSAL
UNTIL WE CAN GET. MORE
INFORMATION TO ANSWER THESE
QUESTIONS TO THE EXTENT THAT
THE LEGISLATURE IS ABLE TO GET
INFORMATION THAT SUGGESTS THAT
THE PROGRAM WOULD BE EFFECTIVE
HOWEVER. WE WOULD RECOMMEND
APPROVING IT. HOWEVER OBVIOUSLY
IF THE BUTTON FOR IS NOT. OR
THERE'S QUESTION ABOUT THE- OF
THE PROGRAM ONCE THE
INFORMATION IS PROVIDED WE
RECOMMEND ABOUT WHAT. THE
LEGISLATURE LOOK FOR OTHER
ALTERNATIVES. WE'RE HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE. THANK YOU FOR THAT I'M
SURE WE DO ACTUALLY HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS- MISTER NAZARIAN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- MY
APPRECIATE THE ANALYSIS THAT
WAS OFFERED RIGHT NOW BECAUSE I
pSUMMARY MY DISTRICT IS
EXTREMELY DEPENDENT ON THE ARTS
AND ENTERTAINMENT- I ALSO HAVE
THE BENEFIT OF REPRESENTING THE
HOLLYWOOD BOWL. AND WITH THE
SEASON SHUT DOWN AND THE
UNCERTAINTY OF WHEN THE SEASON
IS GOING TO BE COMING UP
BETWEEN THAT AND VENUE AND THE
FORD VENUE AS WELL. ALSO THE
WALT DISNEY HALL- NOT JUST THE
IMMEDIATE JOBS OF THE
PERFORMERS AND THE
ADMINISTRATION BEHIND IT BUT
THEN ALL THE OTHER SUPPORT
SYSTEMS ALL OF THE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS ALL THE VENDORS ALL
THE EVERYBODY ELSE IS LARGE
SCALE OF INDIVIDUALS HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY THIS. AND SO I'M
I'M JUST WONDERING- THE. HOW
THE COUNCIL IS MOVING FORWARD
N. OFFERING RELIEF OR EVEN IF
WE SHOULD BE ASKING FOR
SIGNIFICANT LARGER AMOUNT OF
MONEY. ONE TWO- A PROPOSAL LIKE
THIS THAT WAS GONNA BE HELPFUL
TO THE ARTS INDUSTRY AND
COMMUNITY SHOULD HAVE ALREADY
BEEN IN PLACE AND WE SHOULD
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. SO THAT WE COULD
HAVE ROLLED IT OUT ALREADY. SO
I I'M KIND OF TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT THE HOLD UP IS. AND
ALSO. WHY NOT BE ASKING FOR
MORE MONEY WHEN WE KNOW THAT
THE NEED IS DIRE RIGHT NOW.
WHAT FIRST OF ALL BEFORE I TURN
THIS OVER TO MY NOW TO KRISTIN
HOW MY DIRECTOR OF LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS. ACT I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR CREATING THE DARKNESS
OF THE SITUATION. THANK YOU-
CHRISTIAN. ALL YOU MAY STILL
WHO MAY BE ON MUTE. THANKS VERY.
OKAY I AM HELLO THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- THANK YOU SO MUCH
ASSEMBLY AND THEN UNDER THE RAN
FOR YOUR COMMENTS- AS USUAL WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT
I'M PRETTY ARTS COMMUNITY AS
WELL AS THE OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE SUPPORT- AND I
THINK OU MAKE A VERY IMPORTANT
POINTS- I DO WANT TO SHARE WITH
YOU THAT- THE CALIFORNIA- ARTS
COUNCIL HAS RECENTLY ADOPTED A
NEW STRATEGIC FRAMEWORK. AND
THAT STRATEGIC FRAMEWORK WAS
DEVELOPED TO GUIDE- THE
COUNCIL'S WORK FOR THE NEXT
SEVEN YEARS. AND THIS COMPASSES
SEVERAL ASPECTS INCLUDING AND
INPATIENT ENGINE VALUE
STATEMENTS BRISTOL EQUITY
STATEMENT A DECISION SUPPORT
TOOL WHICH AND MENTIONED THE
AND A SET OF ASPIRATIONS FOR
POTENTIAL FUTURE ACTIONS OF THE
COUNCIL. AND THIS DECISION
SUPPORT TOOL IS REALLY WHAT'S
GONNA GUIDANCE- FORWARD- WITH
THIS PROGRAM AND ALL THE ATARI
THANK. YOU FOR A MINUTE I HAVE.
THE YOU KNOW- I APPRECIATE YOU
OUTLINING SOME OF THE STEPS
YOU'VE TAKEN- BUT I GUESS WHAT
I'M TRYING TO SAY IS THIS ISN'T
THE TIME NECESSARILY FOR NEW
MISSION VISION GUIDELINES. THIS
IS THIS IS IMPLEMENTATION THIS
IS GO TIME IT'S BEEN GO TIME
FOR SOME TIME NOW- AND I GUESS
I WASN'T VERY CLEAR. EARLIER IN
MY COMMENTS BUT WHAT I'M ALSO
SAYING IS. YOU SHOULD HAVE
ALREADY BEEN AND MY OFFICE AS
WELL AS MY COLLEAGUES OFFICES
AT THIS POINT WHETHER VIRTUALLY
WELL VIRTUALLY AT THIS POINT.
AND WE SHOULD HAVE BEEN HAVING
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW WE- CAN
WORK HAND IN HAND IN SUPPORTING
THE ARTS. THIS IS THE AREA THAT
IMPACTS- ALL OF OUR DISTRICTS
SIGNIFICANTLY ESPECIALLY THOSE
OF OURS IN THE GREATER LA AREA.
AND SO I YOU KNOW I I'M I GUESS
I'M JUST SHARING MY FRUSTRATION
ALSO THAT AS THE VOICE OF THE
ARTS IN THE STATE- WHOSE
FUNDING WAS DRIED UP UP UNTIL
ABOUT EIGHT YEARS AGO AND
STARTED TRICKLING IN AND
INCREASING A LITTLE BIT OVER
TIME. I WOULD HAVE EXPECTED YOU
TO STEP UP AT THIS POINT ALSO
TO FIND. WAYS THAT YOU CAN WORK
WITH US AND FINDING- GREATER
RELIEF- FOR THIS INDUSTRY- THIS
IS WHEN THIS INDUSTRY NEEDS THE
MOST SUPPORT ESPECIALLY GIVEN
ITS INDEPENDENT- NATURE. GIVEN
THE INDEPENDENT STRUCTURE OF
THE BUSINESS AS WELL NOT
TALKING ABOUT THE STUDIOS HERE
I'M TALKING ABOUT THE ACTUAL
PERFORMERS AND ARTISTS AND THE-
FOLKS WHOSE LIVELIHOOD IS BASED
AROUND THE PERFORMERS AND THE
ARTIST ALSO DOING THEIR WORK.
SO IT'S A VERY I DON'T NEED TO
TELL YOU THIS BUT VERY
INTRICATE WEB. ARTS COUNCIL- SO
THAT'S WHAT I WANT TO HEAR AND
ALSO WOULD LIKE TO HEAR WHY
SOME OF MYSELF AND SO MY
COLLEAGUES HAVEN'T HEARD FROM
YOU OR ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL
ALREADY BECAUSE WE SHOULD HAVE
BEEN ON THE GROUND WORKING ON
THIS AND FOR IT NOT TO JUST
COME UP DURING. OUR BUDGET
MEETING. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN. AMY
JARVIS WITH THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE IF I COULD PLEASE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OUR GREAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH I HAVE A
COUPLE OF THINGS I WANTED TO
AND REMIND THE COMMITTEE THAT
THIS PROPOSAL IS ONE OF OUR
EARLY ACTION PROPOSALS IN
RECOGNITION THAT IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR US TO GET THESE FUNDS OUT
THE DOOR AS SOON AS POSSIBLE IT
IS A REQUEST FOR FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS OF WHICH FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IS REQUESTED
AND FOR HERE AND TEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET- IN
RESPONSE TO A LEO'S COMMENTS I
THINK I'M RECOGNIZE SOME OF THE
CONCERNS AND THEY HAVE BEEN
WORKING DILIGENTLY. ARTS
COUNCIL TO GET ANSWERS TO SOME
OF THE QUESTIONS ARTS COUNCIL
AS YOU ALL KNOW I THINK HAS A
STRONG HISTORY IN THE GRANT
MAKING PROCESS AND IT'S AT A
STRONG HISTORY OF INTEGRITY AND
EFFECTIVENESS AND INTEND TO
EMBODY ALL OF THOSE THINGS THE
PARK ARTS COMMUNITY AND ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT EACH COMMUNITY
IS GOING TO HAVE A DIFFERENT
TRUSTED MESSENGER IN THE ARTS
COMMUNITY- AND SO I THINK THE
ARTS COUNCIL ABSOLUTELY ONE
HUNDRED PERCENT. READY TO MAKE
THIS HAPPEN QUICKLY AND AS
EFFECTIVELY AS POSSIBLE LIKE
THEY ALWAYS HAVE AND I JUST
WANTED TO- ADD THOSE CONSCIOUS
AGAIN THE EARLY ACTION ASPECT
OF IT DOES DEMONSTRATE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S COMMITMENT TO
GETTING THESE FUNDS OUT THE
DOOR AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE TO
SUPPORT. THE ARTS COMMUNITY AS
BEST IT CAN. YOU HAVE FALLEN
SHORT SO THEN WHEN CAN WE SEE
THE- EXACT PROPOSAL. IF AT THIS
POINT IN TIME WE'RE HAVING
SINCE WE DO HAVE A COUNCIL THAT
SETS POLICY WE'RE HAVING- I
HAVE A MEETING OF OUR COUNCIL
MEMBERS AND WE'RE HAVING THAT
AND ABOUT. THREE WEEKS AND WILL
BE PUTTING. THERE WAS THE
TOGETHER AND GETTING ALL THE
DETAILS TOGETHER- I ALSO MIGHT
JUST ADD THAT- ADVANCE SAID WE
HAD THIS COUNCIL MEETING AND-
WHAT I WAS STATING BEFORE IS
REALLY KIND OF THE PROCESS THAT
THE COUNCIL WILL GO THROUGH SO
AND HAD MENTIONED HIS DECISION
SUPPORT TOOL AND THAT IS PART
OF OUR STRATEGIC FRAMEWORK- THE
WHOLE IDEA BEIND THAT
DECISION. SUPPORT TOOL IS TO
GET MONEY OUT THE DOOR TO THOSE
WHO MAY BE DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY ACTIONS AND ARE
SIGNIFICANT HAVE SOME KIND OF
STAKE IN THE RESULTS AND SO-
THIS IS HOW WE WILL BE ABLE TO
SERVE THE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
MOST IN NEED THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA JUST LIKE WE HAVE IN
THE PAST WITH ALL OF OUR OTHER
PROGRAMS- IN ALL OF YOUR
DISTRICTS. FACT AND PROGRAMS
LIKE CULTURAL PATHWAYS- AND
LOCAL IMPACT OUR PROGRAMS THAT
REALLY. ARE GREAT EXAMPLES OF
HOW WE'VE ALREADY DONE THIS
WORK AND WE'RE READY TO DO THIS
WORK- BUT THERE IS A PROCESS
AND OUR COUNCIL DOES HAVE TO BE
PART OF THAT PROCESS OKAY THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR I'LL BE LOOKING
FORWARD TO SEEING THE PROPOAL
AS I'M SURE. MOST OF MY
COLLEAGUES WILL BE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS. I THINK WHAT WHAT
YOU'RE HEARING IS ANY AND WHAT
YOU'RE CURRENTLY CAUGHT IN-
MISS ABOUT CRAWFORD IS. LACK OF
DETAILS WHILE WE ARE INCREDIBLY
SHORT ON TIME IF THIS IS GOING
TO BE MOVING FORWARD AS A-
IMMEDIATE ACTION. SO WITHOUT
THE ABILITY TO PROVIDE AID
DRAFT PLAN OR A PLAN ON HOW THE
FUNDING WILL BE DISBURSED OR
HOW GRANTEES WILL BE SELECTED.
IT IS A CHALLENGING. ISSUE IN
TERMS OF EQUITY AND MAKING SURE
THAT- FUNDING IN THE BUDGET
GOES TO- IS DEBATED IN A IN AN
EQUITABLE WAY ACROSS FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES- I BELIEVE THAT
ARTS AND I AS WELL AS MY
COLLEAGUES BELIEVE THAT ARTS
CAN PLAY AND PLAY A ROLE. IN IN
A VERY IMPORTANT ROLE
ESPECIALLY DURING AT THIS
PANDEMIC THAT WE ARE LIVING
THROUGH BUT- CAN YOU IS THERE
ANY WAY. THAT YOU MIGHT BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE A PLAN SOONER THAN
THE THREE WEEKS THAT YOU ARE
ANTICIPATING BEFORE YOU MEET
WITH YOUR COUNSEL. THREE WEEKS
UNFORTUNATELY IS TOO FAR GONE.
WHAT STATE WE CAN OF COURSE
SUGGEST A PLAN WE SUGGESTED
YOUR TOTAL MEMBERS IT IS. WE
CAN'T MOVE FORWARD WITH THE
PLAN AND HAVE IT SET IN STONE
WITHOUT COUNSEL INVOLVED. SEE
THAT'S THAT'S THE AND THAT'S
THE UNFORTUNATE PART OF WHAT
YOU HAVE IS YOU HAVE SUPPORT.
BUT IT WOULD BE IT WOULD BE IT
WOULD PUT. THE LEGISLATURE IN A
VERY STRANGE POSITION TO
APPROVE FUNDING FOR A PLAN THAT
HAS DOESN'T YET EXIST. YEAH
SEVEN AND WE- DON'T HAVE. I'M
SORRY YOU BROKE UP THERE FOR A
MINUTE CAN YOU REPEAT THAT. WE
DO HAVE CONSTRAINTS WITHIN OUR
PROCESS WE CAN PUT TOGETHER
DETAILS AS FAST AS WE CAN AND
WE ARE WE'RE DOING THE
RESEARCH. WE'RE WE'RE PUTTING
IT TOGETHER FOR ALL THE
INFORMATION TOGETHER FOR
COUNCIL RIGHT NOW. AND WE HAVE
ACTUALLY. AND IS THERE IS
APPROVAL YOUNG WOMEN ARE
COUNCIL IN REHEARSAL ENGLISH
PLAN. OKAY NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. OKAY
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE YOU
TAKING THE TIME AND AT LEAST-
AS JOINING US THROUGH YOUR YOUR
IDEAS AND- I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT TO SEE TO SEE A PLAN.
ON HOW THE FUNDS WILL BE
DISTRIBUTED THANK YOU
PRITCHETT. WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
TOWARDS OUR NEXT- PANEL AND-
ISSUE NUMBER NINE. B. CALVET TO
ELECTRONIC HEALTH RECORD
PROJECT OUR PANELISTS TODAY
INCLUDE ANTHONY WHAT IS WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF VETERAN
AFFAIRS. JACQUELYN BOTTLE SEAL
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST
OFFICE AND PHIL OSBORNE WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
MISTER WALLACE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ANTHONY WATERS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
VETERANS AFFAIRS I AM THE
PROJECT DIRECTOR FOR THE CALVET
ELECTRONIC HEALTH RECORD
PROJECT. THIS PROJECT WILL
IMPLEMENT A NEW LONG TERM CARE
ELECTRONIC HEALTH RECORD SYSTEM
AND ALL EIGHT VETERANS HOMES OF
CALIFORNIA. AND INCLUDING OUR
HEADQUARTERS OFFICE. THIS
REQUEST IS FOR ONE TIME
AUGMENTATION OF TEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND FOR THE
SECOND YEAR OF IMPLEMENTATION.
THE TEN MILLION DOLLARS
INCLUDES NINE POINT SIX MILLION
FOR OUR PRIMARY VENDOR
CONTRACT. TWO HUNDRED EIGHT
THOUSAND FOR INDEPENDENT
VERIFICATION AND VALIDATION
CONTRACT AND A HUNDRED AND
THIRTEEN THOUSAND FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY OVERSIGHT
SERVICES. IN REGARDS TO OUR
CURRENT PROJECTS STATUS DUE TO
COPE WITH IMPACTS WE HAD A
EXPERIENCE SCHEDULE DELAYS. NO
HOMES HAVE IMPLEMENTED THUS FAR.
WE ARE CURRENTLY IN THE
PLANNING PHASE. TO DATE NO
PAYMENTS AVE BEEN MADE TO THE
VENDOR BECAUSE THE INITIAL SET
OF DELIVERABLES FOR ALL ZERO
COST TO THE REBELS. WE HAVE THE
BEST NUMBER TO REACH BASS LINE
THE PROJECT SCHEDULE. WE DO
EXPECT THAT THIS EFFORT WILL
RESULT IN A SPECIAL PROJECT
REPORTS SUBMITTED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY AT
THIS TIME WE DO NOT KNOW THE
FULL IMPACT OF THIS CHANGE.
MANORCARE I'M HERE WITH OUR
AGENCY INFORMATION OFFICER IS
THEM ALL AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
FOR THAT MISSING VIRUS LET'S
HEAR FROM MISS BOTTLES BOTTLE
SEAL AND MR OSBORNE. EGGMAN
BREAKS YOU HAVE WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OFFICE. I'M
AS MENTIONED BY THE DEPARTMENT
THEY ARE CURRENTLY LOOKING AT
THE POSSIBILITY OF RE BASE
LINING THE PROJECT TIMELINE ON
WHICH WOULD REQUIRE SUBMITTING
A SPECIAL PROJECT REPORT TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY. AND
WITH THAT SAID WE WOULD
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HOLD OFF ON TAKING ANY ACTION
RELATED TO HIS PROPOSAL UNTIL-
YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REVIEW THE SPECIAL- FOR OUR
PROJECT REPORT THE REVISED
TIMELINE AND ULTIMATELY UNTIL
CDTV APPROVES THAT THAT
TIMELINE. THANK YOU FOR THAT
MISTRUST BORN. THANK YOU
MEDICARE MEMBERS THORKELSON'S
PARTLY FINANCED. FORMER
FINANCES NO CONCERNS WITH THIS
PROJECT AS PRESENTED WE DO
RECOGNIZED TIME LINE HAS
SLIPPED AND- WE'RE ALSO LOOKING
FORWARD TO- GETTING. ONE OF THE
PROJECT. NOT BEING SAID WE
THINK THAT WE CAN STILL MONEY-
OUR BEST UNDERSTANDING IS THAT-
IT HASN'T BEEN A COST ISSUE BUT
IT'S CHANGED IT'S MORE JUST A
DELIVERABLE SCHEDULE OF
DELIVERABLES. AND SO WE WERE
STILL SUGGEST FULLY FUNDING THE
PROJECT THE IDEA THAT THAT
MONEY WOULD BE ENCUMBERED IN
BUDGET HERE AND THEN WHAT
HAPPENED. DIGITAL AMOUNT OF
TIME TO EXPAND. THANK YOU FOR
THAT MISTER OSBORNE ARE THERE
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. THE YES NO.
MISTER AFARIA THANK YOU JUST
OUT OF CURIOSITY. GIVEN THE
PANDEMIC GIVEN THIS LAST YEAR
WHAT ARE- I'M NOT SEEING ANY
DATA IN THE- IN THE REPORT SO
IT AND THIS MAN NOT NO ONE
MIGHT BE PREPARED TO MENTION
TALK ABOUT THIS BUT- IS THERE
ANY. ANYTHING OF INTEREST TO
NOTE DURING THIS HEARING- ON
NUMBERS AND ACTIVITY AND- GIVEN
HOMELESSNESS THE PANDEMIC AND
ALL THE DIFFERENT ISSUES THAT
ARE HAVE COME ABOUT MENTAL
HEALTH RELATED. ARE YOU SEEING
A CHANGE IN NUMBERS THAT YOU'D
LIKE TO. OFFER OR REPORT ON
RIGHT NOW. A CHANGE IN NUMBERS
AND- IN REGARDS TO INTERACTIONS
HOMES AND THE EFFECTIVE COPING
YES YEAH. I WILL NOTE THAT
DURING THE INITIATION OF THE
PROJECT- WE HAVE- WE DIDN'T
EXPECT OUR SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERT AVAILABILITY- AND
SPECIALLY IN THE AREA OF OUR
CLINICIANS BUT TO BE MORE
AVAILABLE FOR THE PROJECT
UNFORTUNATELY WITH COLD AND THE
AND THE PRIORITY OF CARE FOR
OUR VETERANS AND RESIDENTS ARE
HOMES THAT HAS TAKEN AN IMPACT
ON OUR PROJECT AND AFFECTED.
OUR DELIVERABLE SCHEDULED OUR
OVERALL SCHEDULE I DON'T HAVE
SPECIFIC NUMBERS THAT I CAN
SHARE RIGHT NOW BUT WE CAN TAKE
THAT BACK AND PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION BECAUSE
COMMITTEE JULY. K. ANY ANY
UPDATE ON- COVERT INFECTION
RATES IN THE HOMES. THOSE WOULD
BE THE NUMBER THAT WE WOULD
HAVE TO- AND THAT IS WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING. OKAY OKAY AND
HAVE A HAS THERE BEEN
VACCINATION ADMINISTRATION
STARTED IN THE HOME'S ALREADY
THAT. YOU CAN ALSO PROVIDE SOME
NUMBERS FOR. SO I DON'T HAVE
THE NUMBERS BUT AS PART OF THIS
RE BASELINE EFFORT WE'RE
LOOKING AT IT IS THAT YES THE
VACCINATION SCHEDULE IN THE
HOMES HAS THE ROUND ONE AROUND
TO MOVE ON TO A VACCINATIONS.
OCCURRED IN THE HOMES AND WE
GET THROUGH THOSE THOSE
VACCINATIONS THAT AND NOT ONLY
JUST THE SECOND VACCINATION BUT
ALSO THE TIME TO PUT THOSE TO
BECOME A FACTOR THAT AT THAT
POINT. IN OUR PROJECT SCHEDULE
WE'D BE ABLE TO. PLAN FOR MORE
AVAILABILITY FOR THE SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTS TO PARTICIPATE
IN THIS PARTICULAR PROJECT-
THERE ARE SPECIFIC DELIVERABLES
THAT WE- THAT WE CAN INPUT FROM
pAND TRAINING- THAT WE TO WANT
TO MAKE SURE WE TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT. OUR SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS IN THE HOMES SO THAT WE
DON'T. MOVE TOO FAR DOWN ON OUR
TIMELINE. WITHOUT THEIR
PARTICIPATION. BUT AS THOSE
VACCINATIONS OCCUR WE DO EXPECT
THAT AVAILABILITY OPEN. K. IF I
CAN ASK YOU TO FOLLOW. SIR WITH
SOMEBODY ELSE GONNA MAKE
COMMENT. IN THIS IS JACKIE WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OFFICE-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IT IS THERE AND
IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE QUESTIONS
ARE JUST MORE BROADLY TRYING TO
GET OUT WHAT COUNT THAT IS-
CURRENTLY DOING TO ADDRESS
KOPET NINETY- I WILL I WILL SAY
THAT- THE DEPARTMENT DOES SEND
OUT WEEKLY UPDATES- AND I'M
JUST. READING OFF OF THE MOST
RECENT UPDATE THAT WAS PROVIDED
AND TO DATE 18% OF ALL BETTER
IN HOME RESIDENTS 56% OF STAFF
HAVE RECEIVED THEIR FIRST DOSE
OF THE VACCINE. AND 46% OF
RESIDENTS AND 49% OF STAFF.
HAVE RECEIVED BOTH DOSES.
THAT'S DESK NOW THANK YOU HI I.
WAS JUST A IF THE STAFF ON THE
BUDGET SITE TEAM HAS RECEIVED
IT AND DOESN'T SEEM LIKE EITHER
OF THEM HAD SO IT'LL BE NICE IF
WE'RE INCLUDED IN THESE-
INFORMATION SHARING I KNOW THIS
HAS BEEN A ROUGH SPOT FOR THIS
ADMINISTRATION TO BE ABLE TO
SHARE INFORMATION- BUT- MAYBE.
WE CAN DO A BETTER JOB OF
COMMUNICATING TO ONE ANOTHER SO
WE CAN. BOTH HELP SOLVE THESE
CHALLENGES TOGETHER RATHER THAN
MAKING IT INTO A GUESSING GAME.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
NAZARIAN UP MISTER WHAT IS
THANK YOU FOR THE WORK THAT
YOU'RE DOING WITH THE
DEARTMENT OF VETERAN AFFAIRS-
I KNOW THAT IT IS AN INCREDIBLY
DAUNTING TASK TO HELP THE MEN
AND WOMEN WHO HAVE SERVED SO
BRAVELY TO RECEIVE THE MEDICAL
ATTENTION AND CARE THAT THEY
THAT THEY SO RIGHTFULLY DESERVE
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN THE STATE
AUDITOR RELEASED A REPORT
CONCERNING THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF CAL THAT'S ENTERPRISE WIDE
VETERANS HOME INFORMATION
SYSTEM. THE REPORT CONCLUDED
THAT CALVET PAID NEARLY TWENTY
EIGHT MILLION FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF A SYSTEM THAT
DOES NOT ACTUALLY IMPROVE THE
VETERANS HOME PROCESS FOR
DOCUMENTING MEDICAL CARE OR
REDUCE THE HOMES RELIANCE ON
PAPER RECORD THAT FEDERAL SO MY
QUESTION TO YOU IS WHO IS
OVERSEEING THIS PROJECT TO
ENSURE THAT CAL THAT DOES NOT
HAVE THE SAME IMPLEMENTATION-
SYSTEM INSTABILITY AND
FUNCTIONALITY CONCERNS THAT
WERE RAISED IN THE TWENTY
FIFTEEN AUDIT FOR THE
INFORMATION SYSTEM PROJECT NOW.
THE QUESTION MANAGER- AS THE
CARE PROJECT DIRECTOR. THANK
YOU TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
THAT. AND THIS PROJECT HAS WENT
THROUGH THE- DEPARTED
TECHNOLOGIES PROJECT APPROVAL
LIFECYCLE WE HAVE TAKEN INTO.
ACCOUNT CONSERVE OUR LESSONS
LEARNED ARE COMING FROM THAT
PART- I CAN POINT OUT A COUPLE
OF ITEMS SPECIFICALLY WHEN WE
WENT THROUGH THE PROCUREMENT-
FOR- FOR THE CARE PROJECT WE
DIDN'T INCLUDE. SOME GERMAN
LEADS AND THOSE PROCUREMENT
LEADS TO COME FROM PARKER
CLINICAL AREA AND IN THE
COLLUDED. AB CHIEF MEDICAL
OFFICER FROM OUR ACTIONS HOMES
ALSO INCLUDED TO PREPARE
DIRECTOR OF LONG TERM CARE FOR
THE DEPARTMENT SO THEY WERE
INTIMATELY. INVOLVED WITH THE
CREATION OF THE OF OUR OF OUR-
OUR PRIMARY VENDOR CONTRACT SO
MANY OF THOSE CONSIDERATIONS
ARE PART BUILT INTO THE
CONTRACT. AND IN ADDITION WE
HAVE WE'RE ALSO AS A NON
DELEGATED PROJECT WE HAVE
OVERSIGHT FROM THE DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY WE ALSO HAVE AN
INVENTOR FINISHED INVALIDATION
CONTRACTOR THAT THAT ALSO
PROVIDES OVERSIGHT TO THE
PROJECT AND THEY PROVIDE
MONTHLY. ASSESSMENTS ON A
MONTHLY BASIS TO US SO WHAT WE
DO WE DO TAKE A WEEK WHEN YOU
CONSUME THAT INFORMATION AND
ACTUALLY MAKE ANY ADJUSTMENTS
AS NEEDED ALONG THE WAY.
CORRECT SO DO YOU DO YOU FEEL
CONFIDENT THAT THIS NEW PROJECT
WILL HAVE THE OVERSIGHT
NECESSARY. TO ENSURE THAT YOU
DON'T- SEE THE SAME TYPE OF
CONCERNS MOVING FORWARD. YES I
WOULD SAY THIS TIME WE DO FEEL
CONFIDENT THAT AND NAPS- IN
ADDITION THERE WAS- OKAY WE
ALSO HAVE A RISK MANAGEMENT
PROCESS AS- WE MEET ON A WEEKLY
BASIS TO. MITIGATE AND MANAGE
RISKS AND THAT'S AT RISK
INITIALLY COMMITTEE INCLUDES.
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS AND KEY
STAKEHOLDERS FROM ALL EIGHT OF
OUR VETERANS HOMES- IT ALSO
INCLUDES OUR OUR OUR PRODUCTS
EXECUTIVE SPONSORSHIP OF THE
WITHIN CALVET. SO IN TERMS OF
VISIBILITY THE OF THE PROJECT
AND CURRENT STATUS. WE DO HAVE
MANY. HOLDERS ENGAGED. OKAY
WELL THANK YOU FOR THAT SCENE
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE PANEL
APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE TIME
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO THE ISSUE NUMBER
TEN OTHER CALVET BUDGET- CALVET
BUDGET PROPOSALS- THIS PANEL
INCLUDES DAVID GERALD WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF VETERAN AFFAIRS
THAT JACKIE ABOUT US HERE WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE AND MISTER PHIL OSBORNE
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
MISTER GERALD PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU A GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS DAVE GERARD AND THE
CHIEF OF THE FACILITIES AND
BUSINESS SERVICES DIVISION HERE
TO- CAL THAT. YOU HAVE IN FRONT
OF YOU ARE FOR CAPITAL OUTLAY-
OR RELATED PROPOSALS- THE FIRST
ONE. OR DISCUSSION. IT IS A
REQUEST. FOR TWO HUNDRED NINETY
SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
PRELIMINARY PLANS AND WORKING
DRAWINGS- FOR THE EXPANSION OF
COLUMBARIUM NICHES AT OUR AYE
GO CEMETERY IN AND- BOB S. AT
OUR NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
VETERANS CEMETERY AND I GO
CALIFORNIA. THE DESIGN WORK
THAT'S REQUESTED ALLOWS US A
TWELVE MONTH PERIOD OF TIME TO
THEN PARTICIPATE IN THE-
SECRETARY GRANT PROGRAM AND
PURSUE A GRANT FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION PHASE EVENTUAL.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
IN RELATION TO THE PROPOSAL-
THANK YOU FOR THAT LET'S HEAR
FROM- MISS BUT I SEE ON MR
OSBORNE. JACK GRUBER IF YOU
HAVE A LEO NO CONCERNS AT THE-
K. FOR MORE WITH PARTNER
FINANCE NO CONCERNS. ARE THERE
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS. NO I
ACTUALLY DO HAVE A COMMENT FOR
YOU MISTER GERALD OF. THIS
QUESTION IS REGARDING THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA VETERANS
CEMETERY WATER SYSTEM UPGRADES
IS THIS MEMORIAL BUILDING
OPENED DURING COVERT NINETEEN
AND DOES THE BUILDING PROVIDE
ANY SERVICES TO VETERANS. SO
THE MEMORIAL BUILDING HE IS-
OPEN- WE TAKE THE NECESSARY
PRECAUTIONS- THE- MEMORIAL
BUILDING HAS BEEN THERE IT
ALLOWS FOR FAMILIES- TO HAVE A
MEMORIAL SERVICE DURING THEIR-
THE BURIAL- WE TOOK ALL THE
PRECAUTIONS THAT ARE NECESSARY
THE WATER TREATMENT UPGRADE. IS
ALLOWING FOR WATER PRESSURE-
THROUGHOUT THE THROUGHOUT THE
PROPERTY- THAT'S REQUIRED BY
THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL- IT ALSO
ALLOWS FOR SOME SPRINKLER
INSTALLATION. AS WELL WITHIN
THE MEMORIAL BUILDING AND THE
ADMINISTRATION BUILDING ON THE
PROPERTY. AND I'M I'M SORRY I
DON'T THINK I QUITE HEARD DOES
THE BUILDING PROVIDE SERVICES
TO VETERANS. YES WE DOUBLE YES
OKAY GREAT OKAY THANK YOU SEEN
NO ADDITIONAL. COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE TIME
AND THANK YOU FOR THE WORK THAT
YOU DO TO HELP OUR VETERANS
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO- ISSUE
NUMBER ELEVEN. LEGISLATIVE
WORKLOAD OUR PANELISTS TODAY
INCLUDE JULIAN A WEST WITH THE
FAIR POLITICAL PRACTICES
COMMISSION NICK SCHROEDER WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE AND AGAIN AMY JERVIS
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
GO AHEAD MISS WEST. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS GALINA WEST
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
THE FAIR POLITICAL PRACTICES
COMMISSION. WITH ME TODAY IS
THE F. B. B. C.'S CHIEF
ADMINISTRATION LARISSA HAN.
WE'RE HERE TODAY ASKING FOR
YOUR APPROVAL FOR THE FUNDING
FOR THE CONTINUING WORKLOAD
ASSOCIATED WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DISCLOSE ACT LEGISLATION. AND
THE WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT PASSAGE OF AB TWO ONE FIVE
ONE REGARDING LOCAL CAMPAIGN
FILINGS. THE CALIFORNIA
DISCLOSE ACT PROVIDED
COMPREHENSIVE PROVISIONS. FOR
CAMPAIGN ADVERTISING INCLUDING
CONTENT LOCATION AND FORMAT OF
DISCLAIMERS REQUIRED FOR
TELEVISION PRINT RADIO
TELEPHONE ELECTRONIC MEDIA
ADVERTISEMENTS. THE LITTLE
REQUIRING ON ADVERTISEMENT
DISCLOSURE OF TOP THREE
CONTRIBUTORS AMONG OTHER
PROVISIONS. THESE RULES HAVE A
CONTINUING WORKLOAD FOR THE
FCC. SO THE FTC IS REQUESTING
FOR NINE THIRTY THOUSAND
GENERAL FUNDING FOR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY TWO AN
ONGOING CONTINUE FUNDING FOR
THREE EXISTING LIMITED TERM
FUND POSITIONS. ON A PERMANENT
BASIS TO CONTINUE
INTERPRETATION OUTREACH
EDUCATION AND FORCE MET AND THE
REFINEMENT WITH THE CONTINUING
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH. AB
CHECK FOR NINE THE CALIFORNIA
DISPOSAL. THIS REQUEST CONTINUE
FOR SENIOR COMMISSION. ONE
POLITICAL REFORM COUNTY
CONSULTANT AND ONE SPECIAL
INVESTIGATOR. IN ADDITION AB
TWO ONE FIVE ONE REQUIRED LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AGENCY THAT RECEIVES
A CAMPAIGN FILING DISCLOSURE
FILINGS IN PAPER FORMAT
SUPPOSED COPIES OF THE PAPER
FILINGS ON ITS INTERNET WEBSITE
WITHIN SEVENTY TWO HOURS THE
FILING DEADLINE THAT AND THAT
TOOK EFFECT ON JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. YEP YOU SEE
REQUEST A HUNDRED TWENTY ONE
THOUSAND AND GENERAL FUNDING
FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. AND ONE HUNDRED FOURTEEN
THOUSAND ONGOING FOR ONE
PERMANENT POSITION TO IMPLEMENT
AB TWO ONE FIVE ONE REGARDING
ONLINE FALLING IN DISCLOSURE
SYSTEMS. HERE BECAUSE HE
EXPECTS AN INCREASED AMOUNT OF
ADVICE INQUIRIES FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES REGARDING
THEIR OBLIGATIONS UNDER THE NEW
STATE MANDATE. THE GENERAL
PROVISIONS OF THE ACT
CONCERNING CAMPAIGN FILING
REQUIREMENTS AND DEADLINES AND
ELECTRONIC FILING SYSTEMS. TO
HELP MEET THIS WORKLOAD THE FEC
IS REQUESTING ONE ADDITIONAL
POSITION TO GET BACK
EDUCATIONAL AND INFORMATIONAL
OUTREACH ON THE POSTING
REQUIREMENTS OF AB TWO ONE FIVE
ONE. THIS IS COMPLAINT AMONG
OTHER DID IT DUTY. SO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND WE'RE HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MIGHT HAVE. THANK YOU FOR THAT
MISS WAS LET'S HEAR FROM-
MISTER SCHROEDER AND MISTER OF
THIS. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS- MY NAME IS DICK
SCHROEDER AT THE ALEJO- WE HAVE
NO CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU MISTRUST. IN AB
JARVIS WITH THE PART OF FINANCE
I DON'T HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD AT
THIS TIME EITHER. THANK YOU ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. SEEN
NINE NINE I ACTUALLY HAVE A
QUESTION. OF MISS WEST THE
FISCAL COMMITTEE ANALYSIS FOR
THE DISCLOSE ACT FOUND IT WOULD
INCUR ABOUT THREE HUNDRED FORTY
EIGHT THOUSAND AND I'M GOING
COST. WHY HAVE THE STAFFING
COSTS INCREASED. I BELIEVE
WE'RE IN THE DISCLOSE ACT WE
HAD ANTICIPATED THREE PERMANENT
POSITIONS BUT GOT APPROVED FOR
THREE LIMITED TERM POSITIONS.
AND SO- DOES VISIT WE'RE ASKING
FOR THOSE POSITIONS BECOME
PERMANENT I LARISSA HAN FOR AN
ADMINISTRATION CAN TALK ABOUT
IT THERE'S A DIFFERENT
DISCREPANCY IN THE ACTUAL
FIGURES. HI THIS IS CLARISSA
HAN CHIEF ADMINISTRATION FROM
THE F. PPC- THE FUNDING HAS
INCREASED DUE TO THE FACT THAT
THIS- CRITICAL PCP WAS APPROVED
ON FOUR YEARS AGO AND SINCE
THEN THERE HAS BEEN- SALARY
ADJUSTMENTS AND THEN THE COSTA
ONGOING COST OF- SALARY WAGES
AND- BENEFITS. AND THEN SO
THEREFORE THE INCREASES- IT'S
MINIMAL DUE TO ALL OF THOSE
INCREASES THAT OCCUR IN THE
PAST FOUR YEARS. AND I'M SORRY
HOW MANY NEW STUFF YOU SAID
THIS THIS IS PART OF. THIS WAS
A- THREE A PERMANENT UP P.
WANTED THAT WE'RE REQUESTING TO
EXTEND- THE FROM THE ORIGINAL-
BCP IT WAS. A THREE LIMITED
TERM THREE YEARS FUNDING SO
WHICH IS ASKING FOR A PERMANENT
ONGOING OPPOSITION FUNDING. GOT
IT OKAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SEEN NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE WE
CAN MOVE ON THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THE TIME. WE ARE GOING
TO ISSUE NUMBER TWELVE STATE
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION AND
MAINTENANCE OUR PANELISTS TODAY
INCLUDE JASON KENNEY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
JAMAL A MAIN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES.
DREW SADDAM BURKE WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
OFFICE EVELYN'S SEUSS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SALLY
LOOKING BILL WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND GABBY
SANTORO ALSO WITH THE
DEPARTMENT. OF FINANCE MISTER
KENNY YOU CAN BEGIN. I COULD
HAVE SHE CARILLO AND CAMINO.
MONEY IS CHASING AND THE DIRECT
FOR MOST FOR EACH. I WITH
BUILDINGS. IN FRONT OF YOU THE
RENOVATIONS OF THE JESSE UNRUH
NATURAL RESOURCES AND GREGORY
STATUS RIGHT UPS OR EXCELLENT
SUMMARIES AND SUBS CAN ADD A
FEW SUPPLEMENTARY. REMARKS OUR
FIRST. WE BACKGROUND ALL THREE
BUILDINGS. ARE OF THE JUSTICE
TEN YEARS HE WOULD THINK WHICH
IS A PROGRAM. WE'VE BEEN
BRINGING FORWARD LEGISLATURE
SINCE. TWENTY SIXTEEN. I AM AND
WHY IT'S CALLED PLAN BECAUSE
WE'VE BEEN. NEW BUILDINGS TO
ADDRESS LONG TERM SPACE NEEDS
IN THE AREA. AND THEN THE IDEAS
PEOPLE DEPARTMENTS MY MOST
EFFICIENT SPACES MOVE INTO THE
NEW CONSTRUCTION SO WE CAN
RENOVATE THE BUILDING. CAME OUT
AND- IT'S INTO OUR NEXT. AND
WHEN YOU. ALSO ALTHOUGH AND IT
SEEMS THE WE'RE GETTING SOME
THERE'S ANOTHER MIKE THAT'S ON
OR YOU'RE HEARING TWO DIFFERENT
VOICES JUST ONE MOMENT WHILE WE
FIGURE THAT PIECE OUT WE'RE
GOOD WE'RE GOOD TO GO OKAY
MISTER CAN YOU MAY CONTINUE.
MEMBERS SO AS WE SEE A NEW
BUILDINGS ARE FINISHING THIS
SPRING AND SUMMER- WE HAVE A
ONCE IN A LIFETIME OPPORTUNITY
TO RENOVATE THE PROPOSED
BUILDINGS AT THE SO THAT'S
REALLY NEAT- AS A TESTIFIED
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE IN PRIOR
YEARS. WHAT'S PROPOSED IS A
COMPREHENSIVE RENOVATION OF
THESE THREE HISTORIC BUILDINGS
WHICH ARE IN THE TOP FIVE. MOST
EFFICIENT INFRASTRUCTURE. IN
OUR PORTFOLIO THE NECESSARY
SKILLS WORKING CLUES THE
REPLACEMENT OF EVERY MAJOR
BUILDING SYSTEMS INCLUDING
ELEVATORS PLUMBING HEATING
VENTILATION AIR CONDITIONING
ELECTRICAL TELECOMMUNICATIONS
AND SECURITY. AS WELL AS SOME
CRITICAL FIRE LIFE SAFETY
ISSUES SUCH AS FIRE SPRINKLERS
EXITING STANDARDS- ALL SYSTEMS
ARE SIGNIFICANTLY BEYOND THEIR
USEFUL LIFE IN DANGER OF
FAILING. I WITH THE BATES SEVEN
HUNDRED BUILDINGS PARTICULAR
HAVING EXTERIOR WATER ISSUES
THAT THE BUILDINGS INTO DANGER
OF FALLING INTO A STATE OF
PERMANENT THIS REPAIR. I WILL
ALSO BE ADDRESSING A SEVERE
SEISMIC DEFICIENCY IN THE
RESOURCES BUILDING. WHICH WOULD
REQUIRE REPLACING THE EXTERIOR
SKIN OF THE BUILDING. I'M AT
THE GYM TO NOTICE THESE THREE
PROJECTS HAVE THEIR INITIAL
PHASE AUTHORIZED BY THE
LEGISLATURE IN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN- WE COMPLETED THAT
PHASE BUT PLACE THE BUILDINGS
AND THE PROJECTS ON BECAUSE OF
THE LAST BUDGET CYCLE. TO
ENSURE THE TELEWORK HAD NO IN
ADVERSE IMPACT ON THE PROJECTS
WHICH WE HAVE DONE. I'M NOT
ONLY ARE ALL THREE PROJECTS
MORE THAN CAPABLE OF SUPPORTING
THE TELEWORK PLANS OF THE
FUTURE TENANTS. OF THE
RENOVATIONS ARE IN LINE WITH
INDUSTRY GUIDANCE DESIGN
GUIDANCE OUT OF SCOPE OF
BUILDINGS- THESE PROJECTS FOR
THE SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON THE
LOCAL ECONOMY AT A TIME WHEN
PEOPLE AND BUSINESSES ARE
SUFFERING. THESE PROJECTS WORK
DIRECTLY AND INDIRECTLY CREATE
THOUSANDS OF JOBS AND THE
PROJECT READY PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENTS ALL CONSTRUCTION
JOBS WILL PROVIDE A LIVING WAGE
AS WELL AS THE SKILLS AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR A LIFETIME OF
WORK. ADDITIONALLY THESE THESE
PROJECTS WILL INCLUDE A
COMMUNITY WORKFORCE AGREEMENTS.
WHICH BRINGS A FOCUS ON EQUITY
AND FUTURE EMPLOYMENT THAT IS
YOU'RE IN HER FOR STATE
PROJECTS. TO QUICK FINAL NOTES-
THE JESSIE I'M REBUILDING DOES
HAVE A HISTORIC FOUNTAIN JUST
OUTSIDE OF IT AS MENTIONED IN
YOUR GENDER. WE HAVE TAKEN A DO
NOTHING APPROACH WITH THE
FOUNTAIN YOU'RE. NOT REQUESTING
MONEY IN A PROPER FOR. OTHERS
FUNDING FOR. TO DEMOLISH IT OR
TO READ IT- IF YOU MAY. A
PUBLIC. I BELIEVE LETTERS MAY
HAVE GONE TO SOME OF YOUR- WERE.
THAT THE STOCK. AT FUNDING
RENOVATE FOUND. WELL WE NOT.
DOING WE IT THE- HAVE LOVED. WE
WERE IF WE WERE ASKED TO
RENOVATE IT- AND THEN FINALLY
THE CHEN ALSO MAY. CONCERT BY
THE TRICK IS TREASURER. WHO IS
THE- AND RUBIO- AS THE AGENDA
MENTIONED HAVE A LETTER THE
TREASURE. WE HAD A VERY.
CONVERSATION TREASURE AND HER
STAFF OR ADDRESS. THIS CONCERT
ABOUT THE PROJECT INCLUDING.
THE SEVERITY OF THE BUILDING
ISSUES AND THE FACT THAT WE ARE
ABSOLUTELY NOT DESIGNING THIS
USING. PANDEMIC STANDARDS I
WITH A COPY OF OUR RESPONSES.
WAS SENT TO YOUR OFFICE. ARMED
WITH THAT I AM HAPPY TO AN ANY.
YOU. SORRY LET'S HEAR FROM AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AS
WELL AS THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. L. DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE- GOOD AFTERNOON- I
JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT
THESE PROJECTS- DURING INCLUDED
IN THE ADMINISTRATION'S PLAN OR
CONTINUATION OF THE COMMITMENT
TO INVESTING IN STATE
INFRASTRUCTURE AS A DRIVER OF
ECONOMIC STIMULUS AND BE HAPPY
TO. ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT THINK. L. SORT OF BORED
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WE
HAVE NOT IDENTIFIED ANY
CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSAL FOR
THE THREE BUILDINGS OR THE FIRE
SAFETY MODIFICATIONS WE ARE
CONTINUING TO EXAMINE THE
PROPOSAL FOR FACILITY
MAINTENANCE STAFF HOWEVER AND
WE WILL UPDATE THE COMMITTEE IF
WE IDENTIFY ANY CONCERNS. THANK
YOU TO THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. NOW I ACTUALLY HAVE A
COUPLE PERHAPS- DO YOU EXPECT-
AND THIS IS FOR MR KENNY DO YOU
EXPECT TO ALTER THE LAYOUT OR
DESIGN ELEMENTS FOR THESE NEW
FACILITIES BASED ON THE
EXPERIENCE OF COALBED. NINETEEN
FOR EXAMPLE WILL OFFICES BE SET
UP ASSUMING THAT EMPLOYEES ARE
TELEWORKING OR PARTICIPATING IN
VIRTUAL MEETINGS. SO I GUESS
SHE POINTS IN THAT THERE'S A
BEGINNING TO BE MORE MORE
INDUSTRY DESIGN GUIDANCE ON
WHAT A POST CODE THE BUILDING
THAT LOOKS LIKE- MOSADDEK
GUIDANCE ALIGNS WITH. THE
TRADITIONAL YOU KNOW LAST FIVE
OR SIX YEARS OR SO HEALTHY
BUILDING STANDARDS- WHICH WE
ADOPTED ACTUALLY IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN- SO. KIND OF FORWARD
THINKING WE ARE OUR BUILDINGS
ALREADY ATTACHED TO MUCH OF
WHAT THE ISSUE GUIDANCE IS- BUT
MORE THAN THAT- WE ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT AS A RENOVATING
THESE BUILDINGS. AND
CONSTRUCTING NEW BUILDINGS AND
EXIT TWO YEARS TELEWORK WAS
GONNA BE MORE MORE OF A THING.
NO ONE COULD EVER IMAGINE
HAPPENING QUITE SO QUICKLY- BUT
WE KNEW IT WAS GOING TO HAPPEN
EVENTUALLY INSTALL THE
BUILDINGS THAT WE HAVE EITHER
BUILT OR ARE PLANNED FOR
INNOVATION HAVE HAD. TELL
WORKING PEOPLE FOCUS A SIMPLE
EXAMPLE IS RIGHT DOWN THE
STREET FROM THE CAPITOL THERE'S
THE NEW NATURAL RESOURCES
BUILDING. THAT BUILDING WILL BE
CONSTRUCTED IN JULY- IT WAS
ORIGINALLY DESIGNED WITH THIRTY
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY SEATS-
AND- IT WILL STILL HAVE THIRTY
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY SEATS BUT
FOUR THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED EACH
EMPLOYEES IN ITS- ALL- ADOPTED.
TELEWORK IT WE DID COST US
NOTHING TO MAKE THOSE CHANGES
THAT IT WAS JUST A MATTER OF
SORT OF REARRANGING WHO WHEN
WHERE AND WHEN PEOPLE INCOME
ALTERNATE PIECES WHICH YOU CAN
NOW CUTS. SO YES I DID ANYTHING
WITH THAT THE TIME IS WHAT I DO
TO THE TELEWORK. WILL WILL BE
ABLE TO CONTACT. THANK YOU
ACROSS ON THE FOUNTAIN CAN YOU
PER MORE AND- REGARDING THE
STATE. FOUND YES SO- ACROSS THE
STREET FROM THE CAP- BETWEEN
NINE TEN- YOU HAVE THE JESSIE
I'M REBUILDING AND YOU HAVE TO
LIVE RECORDS BUILDING IN
BETWEEN IS AROUND ABOUT- WITH A
HISTORIC WRITTEN. THAT HISTORIC
FOUNTAIN AND- IS PART OF THE
HISTORIC DISTRICT ITSELF-
ORIGINALLY WHEN WE HAD TO BE
DONE GOING THROUGH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW FOR THE
PROJECT. WE TYPICALLY TAKE A
WORST CASE SCENARIO APPROACH-
ENTITLED THE WORST POSSIBLE
THING. THAT WHAT IF SOMETHING
WERE TO HAPPEN THE PROJECT WE
OUGHT TO GO BACK OUT AND YOU
STUFF TO PROVIDE DRUG USING
BECAUSE ANYTHING- UNTIL WE HAD
ORIGINALLY PROPOSED A
DEMOLITION OPTION I GET NOT TO
SAY THAT WE WOULD ACTUALLY
DEMOLISH IT BUT- WE DID PROPOSE
THAT AND THE ENVIRONMENTAL
DOCUMENT- WE IT COSTS ABOUT A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS PLUS
OR MINUS TWO TO POLISH THE
FOUNTAIN- CONSIDERING THE
SUBSTANTIAL UNDERGROUND
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT GOES ALONG
WITH IT- AND THEN TO RESTORE.
AROUND ABOUT TO GET SOME SOME
NEW. FEATURE R. N. ROUGHLY OUR
CIVIL ABOUT TWO MILLION DOLLARS
TO RESTORE IT. ITS FULL
FUNCTIONALITY THERE IS MULTIPLE
COMPONENTS IN THE FOUNTAIN AND
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THEM
WITHOUT FAIL IS BROKEN IN SOME
WAY SHAPE OR FORM- AND SO- WE
DELIVER. TAKEN OUT I DO A WITH-
WE- DIDN'T THINK- THE ADDED
MONEY TO RESTORE THE- WAS THAT
WE WOULD. ASK FOR- NOR DO WE
RECKON DEMOLITION OF THIS. AND
THAT'S KIND OF WHERE WE SET. M.
BUT THEN THAT THE IT'S AN A-
DOES THIS REPAIR YES THANK YOU
MISTER LAAKIIN- THAT IT WAS
ALLOWED TO GET TO THE POINT OF
WHERE IT IS NOW THAT'S VERY
UNFORTUNATE. ON A SEPARATE
ISSUE- ISSUE HAVING TO DO WITH
THE TREASURER'S OFFICE HAVE YOU
MET HAS YOUR DEPARTMENT MET
WITH THE TREASURER'S OFFICE
STAFF ABOUT THE CONCERNS RAISED
IN HER LETTER. YES YES
ABSOLUTELY- WE MET WITH THE
TERMS REMARKS- AND MEMBERS OF
OUR STAFF- RECENTLY LAST WEEK
WE'VE ACTUALLY BEEN WORKING
WITH THE TREASURER'S OFFICE
SINCE- EARLY TWENTY NINETEEN ON
THE PROJECT- WE GOT HER LETTER-
WHEN YOU GUYS DID. WE SET DOWN
WITH HER KIND OF WALK THROUGH
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
MISCONCEPTIONS- AND THINGS WE
WERE HAPPY TO CLARIFY- FOR
EXAMPLE THAT WE ARE DESIGNING A
BUILDING BASED ON PRE MED AND
EXTENDERS THAT DESIGN IS NOT
DONE THAT BASED ON THE- RECENT
OBVIOUSLY WHAT THE BUILDINGS
GOING TO FUNCTION. WE LOOK LIKE
IN THE FUTURE OF THOSE SORTS OF
THINGS- THEY ALSO RAISING
CONCERNS ABOUT- THERE ARE
POTENTIAL RELOCATION PARTISAN
BUILDING BE CLARIFIED THAT THAT
BUILDING IS. NOT ENOUGH WERE
STATED THAT THE- REBUILDING
THAT'S WHY WERE YOU CAN
RENOVATE THE I'M BUILDING UP
UNDERSTAND- BUT WE ALSO
PROMISED TO WORK TOGETHER WITH.
YOU TRYING TO THE- BUT THE BEST
RELOCATION SPACE FOR THEM- WE
DID MENTION THOUGH OF COURSE
THAT WE PICKED UP UNDERSTAND
BUILDING- IN PART BECAUSE WE
ARE. SPLITTING UP A LITTLE BIT
BUTALSO TO. BE LEAST COST
IMPACTFUL MOVE FOR THEM AND
WHAT ACTUALLY STATE THAT WE
SHOULD SAVE THEM SOME MONEY ON
THERE AND WILL. ALWAYS. BUDGET
THEY WERE. THANK YOU FOR THAT
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS ARE. FROM
COME. NO LOOKING ON MEDICARE DO
YOU MIND IF I. BETTER CHESMA
ALLEGRI AHEAD. COME APPRECIATE
THE PRESENT I WANT TO GO THE
TRACK LETTER- AND IT SOUNDS
LIKE YOU'VE HAD SOME CA. WITH
THE TREE TO- THERE WAS ONE L.
OF A LETTER THAT YOU DIDN'T
TOUCH ON WHICH WERE THE BUDGET
CONSIDERATIONS AND- WHAT-
TREASURE MOD LAYS OUT UNDER
LETTER WAS SENT ORIGINALLY- THE
BUDGET FOR THIS BUILDING WAS
NINETY MILLION THAT INCREASED
43% TWO HUNDRED TWENTY NINE
MILLION. ORIGINALLY WAS SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY PER SQUARE FOOT
NOW IT'S OVER A THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER SQUARE FOOT AND
WHAT SHE HIGHLIGHTS IS DURING
THIS TIME GIVEN THE ECONOMIC
IMPACT OF THE PANDEMIC. MANY
PEOPLE ARE FACING UNPRECEDENTED
DISRUPTIONS TO THEIR LIVES
INCLUDING STATE EMPLOYEES HAVE
BEEN SUBJECT TO PAY CUTS EXCEPT
TRUCK TO PROCEED WHICH SUCH A
LARGE SCALE EXPENSIVE
RNOVATION PROJECT- MAY CAUSE
INDIVIDUALS TO QUESTION OUR
STATE'S PRIORITIES DURING THIS
UNCERTAIN FISCAL TIME COULD YOU
ADDRESS THAT- I HAVE TO ADMIT I
READ THAT IT. JUMPED OUT AT ME-
AND I'D. BE CURIOUS TO KNOW
WHAT YOUR PERSPECTIVE IS ON
THAT. YEAH ABSOLUTELY- SO COME
POINTS IN RESPONSE- AND ALL
THIS BE COMMUNICATED TO THE
TREASURES WHILE- PERSON
FOREMOST- SHE IS RIGHT ABOUT
THE PERCENTAGE CLIMBS- OF THE
PROJECT I CAN EXPLAIN THAT A
SECOND- WE DID POINT OUT. THAT
THERE'S A REASON WHY YOU DON'T
USE. THAT SQUARE FOOTAGE AS THE
COST BASIS- GENERALLY FOR
RENOVATIONS NEW CONSTRUCTION
USE GROSS- BECAUSE IT JUST
LOOKS LIKE THAT YOUR FLIGHT THE
COST OF COURSE BUT WHEN HE SAID
THAT- TO THE COSTS ARE ACTUALLY
LOWER THAN STATED. ON A SQUARE
FOOTAGE BASIS BUT THE COSTS
HAVE INCREASED AND THE
PERCENTAGES ARE ABOUT RIGHT-
THERE A COUPLE OF REASONS FOR
THAT- FIRST AND FOREMOST-
CONTEST CONDITIONS SO- THE
PROJECTS IN IN THE LATE- ONE
YEAR. HAVE GONE UP THE DIRECT
COST OF GOING UP 5% PLUS- ON
THE BASIS. INDIRECT COSTS THAT
GO ALONG WITH IT- AND SO YOU
END UP HAVING DESIGN FEES WHICH
ARE PERCENTAGE- YOUR PRODUCT.
TO CONTINUE TO SEE WHICH IS THE
PERCENTAGE. INSPECTION WHICH-
SO THE DIRECT COSTS OF GOING SO
HOW THOSE FEES. WITH OTHER-
COUPLE OF A GENERAL. IN TERMS
OF PRICE COSTS IN. EIGHT NINETY
THE PROJECT FOR WAS FIRST PUT
FORWARD- THEY WERE BASED ON OF-
INFRASTRUCTURE STUDIES WERE EXT.
THE TIME- WE ALSO USED LIBRARY
COURTS AN- PROJECT WHICH IS
ACROSS THE STREET FROM PINE
RIVER AS A COST BASIS FOR TWO
OF THEM- BACK. TO BE A MISTAKE
HE- LIBRARY COURTS ANNEX
ACTUALLY PROVED TO BE A PARTIAL
RENOVATION WHICH WE DID NOT
REALIZE- AND SO WHEN YOU ALIGN
THE SCOPE. OF THE LIBRARY
COURTS RENOVATION TO WHAT WE
HAVE TO DO THESE BUILDINGS
BECAUSE ACTUALLY MATERIAL HE-
MATCHED THE PROBLEM IS OF
COURSE IS THAT WE JUST PICK THE
COR ANALOG BEGIN WITH.
UNDERESTIMATED THE COSTS THE
SECOND PLEASE- THAT WAS AS WE
GOT THE FUNDING LEGISLATURE IN
EIGHTEEN NINETY BEGIN TO DO.
MORE UPDATED- BUILDING
INVESTIGATIONS- WHAT WE
GENERALLY FOUND WORK CONDITIONS
THAT HAD- XCELERATED LEE GOTTEN
WORSE- AND NEW BUILDING
CONDITIONS THAT EXIST FOR. A
REALLY SIMPLE EXAMPLE I THINK
IS- THE- THE RESOURCES BUILDING
SO WE KNEW THE BUILDING HAD A
SEISMIC ISSUE WE HAD IT. FOR
BUT DIGGING INTO SOME OF THE
SPECIFICS AND THE EXTENT OF IT-
WE FOUND WE HAVE TO. REMOVE THE
ENTIRE EXTERIOR CLADDING OF THE
BUILDING- AS WELL AS CHORE UP
THE ENTIRE INTERIOR STRUCTURAL
SYSTEM IS A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
SEISMIC ISSUE- SOME OF THOSE IT
WORSENING CONDITIONS. HAVE
DRIVEN UP THE COSTS OF. IF I
COULD I UNDERSTAND NOW WHY THE
IS GOING UP MY REAL QUESTION IS
NOW THE RIGHT TIME FOR US SPEND
ON TWENTY MY- DOLLARS. ON THIS
WEEK THAT'S THAT'S REALLY WHAT
THIS IS THAT'S REALLY WHAT ARE.
THAT'S WHAT CALIFORNIA'S ARE
GONNA BE ASKING US. AND I WOULD
I WOULD MAKE THE- THAT THAT YES-
THESE PROJECTS- COMBINED WILL
ADD A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT INTO
THE LOCAL ECONOMY- THE UNDER
PROJECT A LOCAL CREATE
SOMEWHERE NEIGHBORHOOD OF THREE
HUNDRED JOBS PER YEAR DIRECTLY
PLUS INDIRECT BENEFITS- IN A
GENERALLY SPEAKING IT'S EVERY
ONE DOLLAR YOU CAN
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS TO GET
THREE DOLLARS. OF ECONOMIC
BENEFIT FROM IT. THESE PROJECTS
HAVE BOTH PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENTS AND COMMUNITY
WORKFORCE AGREEMENTS. IT'S NOT
JUST YOU KNOW. BOTTOM LOW
PAYING JOBS THESE ARE JOBS THAT
HAVE FUTURES WITH THEM- AND CAN
YOU WORKFORCE AGREEMENTS HAVE A
FOCUS ON EQUITY WHICH WHICH- WE
HAVE WE'VE NEVER DONE OUTSIDE
OF THE SACRAMENTO PROJECTS- AND
SO I THINK THERE ISN'T. AN
ABSOLUTE ECONOMIC ARGUMENTS
BEING MADE HERE THESE ARE ALSO-
FINANCE PROJECT FINANCE
PROJECTS. WOULD YOU GENERAL
FUND CASH TO. PAY FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION. WE'RE JUST DOING
SOME OUTSIDE LITERALLY JUST
DIVIDED THREE HUNDRED AND TO
HUNDRED THE MILLION. IT COMES
OUT TO FOUR HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THREE. DOLLARS PR JOB I ASSUME
IS NOT WHAT YOU ARE PAYING
FOLKS SO AGAIN JUST TRYING TO
THINK OF THE ECONOMIC IMPACT OF
THIS DURING THIS ECONOMY WE
HAVE SCARCE DOLLARS. DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE FOR US TO MOVE FOR
WITH THIS PROJECT RIGHT NOW.
YEAH THAT'S THAT'S THE THAT'S
THE DIRECT- JOB. DOES NOT COUNT
THE INDIRECT JOBS OF THE SUPPLY
CHAINS THAT YOU'RE PURCHASING
AS WELL- THERE'S GENERAL
INDUSTRY STUDIES AGAIN FOR
EVERY ONE DOLLAR YOU PUT ANY
TEND TO GET THREE DOLLARS OUT
ECONOMICALLY FROM. PROJECTS
LIKE THESE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
FIGHT I CAN JUST ADD TO MISTER
KENNEY'S COMMENTS- YOU'LL
NOTICE THAT. ADMINISTRATION HAS
COME OUT PRETTY ADAMANTLY ON IN
FAVOR OF. INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS- IS STRONG DRIVERS
OF ECONOMIC ECONOMIC STIMULUS I
ALLUDED TO THAT A FEW MINUTES
AGO. AND THIS IS ONE OF MANY
PROJECTS THE ADMINISTRATION
WILL BE BRINGING FORWARD IN THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS ON THE- JOB
CREATION AND ECONOMIC STIMULUS
IN MIND IN FACT WE HAVE A FIFTY
TWO BILLION DOLLAR. FIVE YEAR
ON PRESCRIPTION PLAN. THAT THAT
THE ADMINISTRATORS VERY SUPPORT
OF THAT CAN IN THE SAME VEIN OF
JOB CREATION AND ON ECONOMIC.
STIMULUS CALIFORNIA. I PREFER
THE AYE AYE LOVE TO SEIZE OF
THAT AND- AS THE CHAIR THAT
COMMITTEE. IF I HAD A HUNDRED
THIRTY MILLION I FOR OUT
BILTMORE HOUSING TO PUT ROOFS
OVER PEOPLE'S HEADS WHILE
CREATING JOBS. I UNDERSTAND
THIS IS SOMETHING WE NEED TO DO
WE JUST AGAIN THINK ABOUT THE
TIMING SO I APPRECIATE THE
APPRECIATE THAT THE-
CONVERSATION AND- I'LL TURN IT
BACK TO THE CHAIR. THANK YOU
MANAGER. THANK YOU FOR THAT
MISTER TO ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. NO I WOULD JUST ADD
THAT THERE IS A THE LEGISLATURE
IS INVESTED IN ENSURING THAT IN
OUR CO BID. AT A CON MI
RECOVERY PLAN WE ARE CREATING
GOOD JOBS GOOD UNION JOBS
INFRASTRUCTURE IS ALWAYS A GOOD
DIRECTION AND HOW TO GET TO
THAT- THAT GOAL IN ADDITION TO
ENSURING THAT WE DON'T ALLOW
THINGS LIKE. THE FOUNTAIN TO
CONTINUE TO BE IN DISARRAY OR
ANY ADDITIONAL BUILDINGS TO
CONTINUE TO FALL APART THAT ARE
STILL QUITE NEEDED FOR US TO BE
ABLE TO DO THE BUSINESS OF THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
TO THE PANEL. IF THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS FROM THE
COMMITTEE WILL CONTINUE TO MOVE
ON OKAY THANK YOU WE ARE NOW ON
ISSUE. THIRTEEN OUT OF HOW MANY
ISSUES DO WE HAVE TODAY WE HAVE
SEVENTEEN. SEVENTEEN ISSUES
WE'RE ALMOST THERE FOR THOSE OF
YOU THAT ARE WAITING FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT WE ARE GOING TO GO ON
TO- ISSUE NUMBER THIRTEEN
OTHER- DDS PROPOSALS- AND WITH
US ON THIS PANEL IS. ANDREW
STERN FELLS WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF GENERAL SERVICES I DECLARE
NANCY ANDOR THE DEPARTMENT ALSO
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES- IT- DREW SADDAM BURKE
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. EVELYN SEUSS GABBY
SANTORO AND BARBARA TAYLOR.
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
LET'S BEGIN. GO AHEAD MR FELT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR GOOD
AFTERNOON- MANAGER MEMBERS AND
YOU START BILLS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
WE HAVE A FIVE ITEMS BEFORE YOU
TODAY- THE FIRST TWO ARE WILL-
ITEMS DIRECTLY RATING SOARED TO
BUSINESS STATE ARCHITECT MYSELF
AND I THINK THE ARCHITECT I
DECLARE WILL BE HANDLING THOSE
THE FIRST IS THAT I DON'T WANT
TO BE DETECTABLE WARNING
SURFACES THE DEPARTMENT GENERAL
SERVICES DIVISION OF STATE
ARCHITECT IS REQUESTING A ONE
TIME BUDGET AUTHORITY INCREASE
OF ONE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS. AND A DISABILITY HAVE
ACCESS ACCOUNTS FOR FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
THIS WILL ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT-
DIVISIONS TO COMPLETE A
STATUTORILY MANDATED STUDY ON
THE EFFECTIVENESS AND SOUNESS
OF DETECTABLE WARNING SURFACES
OF THE TECHNICAL ONE SERVICES
ARE REQUIRED BY THE FEDERAL
AMERICANS WITH DISABILITIES ACT
ACCESSIBILITY GUIDELINES AND
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING CODE
THE SERVICES ARE FLYING A
PEDESTRIAN PATHS FOR EXAMPLE BE
A YELLOW BOX YOU MIGHT FIND A
CROSSWALK THAT'S ONE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE VISUALLY
IMPAIRED THAT THEIR APPROACHING
OR ENTERING HAZARDOUS AREAS
LIKE ST WILL BE A TRAIN
PLATFORM. WITH ME TODAY AGAIN
EXACTLY THE ARCHITECT OF
CLAREMONT AVENUE INTO ANY
QUESTIONS MAY. HAVE ON THIS
ONE. WHEN WE CONTINUE TO. HEAR
FROM THE OF THE PER. AND THEY
WILL THE QUESTIONS IN COMMENTS
AT ACT. ABSOLUTELY THE SECOND
BEFORE YOU IS- THE BETTER IN
THE DIVISION OF ARCHITECT
STANFORD EXPAND PERMANENT
ONGOING EXPENDITURE INCREASED
ELEVEN POINT ZERO THREE BY
MILLION AND TWENTY SIX
POSITIONS IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO TO
MANAGING CREASING PUBLIC SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION WORKLOAD AND
REQUIRED OVERSIGHT- THE FOR THE-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. WHO'VE BEEN
ON CORPORATE YOU NEVER TO YOU
AGO WE ASKED FOR ABOUT NINE
POINT SIX MILLION TEMPORARY
UP PRETTY LARGE. IN SCHOOL AND
PROJECTS- AND WE REQUESTED THAT
AUTHORITIES WERE TEMPORARY
BASIS THAT WE COME BACK TO YOU.
HAVE TO GET A BETTER IDEA OF A
LONG TERM PROJECTS AS THE
SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS SO
WE'RE BACK TO YOU TODAY IS THE
FOLLOW UP- IN ASKING FOR THE
PERMANENT AUGMENTATION IN
POSITIONS ARE TO HANDLE DSA
WORKLOAD. LET ME SUMMARIZE IN
THREE. THE FIRST IS THE- AND
SUPERMAN A STRAW. FIRE LIKE
STATE. SUSTAINABILITY AND
CUSTOM. PLAY REVIEW. AND
CONSTRUCTION OVERSIGHT.
DEVELOPMENT IN THE BILL CODE
REGULATIONS ASSISTING SENIOR
POLICY INTERPRETATION TRAINING.
ADMINISTRATION OF TRAINING AND
CERTIFICATION EXAMINATIONS. THE
THIRD ITEM YOU TODAY IS A ITEM
FOR A CONTACTED FISCAL SERVICES
WORKLOAD WE REQUESTING POINT
ONE FOUR SIX MILLION ADDITIONAL
ONGOING AUTHORITY AS A SPLIT
BETWEEN GENERAL FUND AND
CENTRAL SERVICES COST RECOVERY
PLAN AND SERVICES ALL INCLUDED
YES AND SEVENTY POSITIONS TO
PROVIDE ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES
PERFORMING CLIENT AGENCIES. WAS
CLIENT AGENCIES INCLUDE THE
CALIFORNIA AFRICAN AMERICAN
MUSEUM. WILL BE PROVIDING
ACCOUNTING SERVICES FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL WITH WE
CAN START PROVIDING ACCOUNTING
AND BUDGETING SERVICES FOR AND
IN THE NATIVE AMERICAN HERITAGE
COMMISSION AN ADULT PROTECTION
COMMISSION BOTH TO CURRENTLY
RECEIVE HER MINISTRY OF
SERVICES FROM THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION AND DETAILS WILL BE
PROVIDING ACCOUNTING BUDGETING.
HR. AND PROCUREMENT SERVICES
FOR. THE FOURTH BEFORE YOU IT
IS AN ITEM FOR OFFICE OF BREAST
CANCER MANAGED. WAS REQUESTING
HUNDRED DOLLARS AND ON SERVICE
FOR BALLING X. ALREADY. AND
SUPER. STILL SUPPORT INCREASED
DEMAND FOR A PART ON STATE
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT FOR-
SPECIFIC STATE LAW RESULTS.
AMBER PLANNING. AND THEN THE
FINAL ITEM FORTY I FIVE. IS THE
LARGEST OFFICES IS REQUESTING
ONE TIME BUDGET AUGMENTATION OF
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL. AND
ONE POINT THREE MILLION IN
SERVICE REVOLVING FUND IS
ALREADY. THIS REQUEST IS THE
FIVE YEAR FIVE OR C. S. ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES BY YOUR
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT PLAN-
WHICH COMMITTEE MEMBERS WILL
RECALL WE STARTED STARTED FORTY
FIVE YEARS AGO THE FIRST
REQUEST. AND THIS IS THE WORK
WAS REQUESTED TO CONTINUE
PERFORMING INSTALLATIONS OF A
B. B. SERVICE EQUIPMENT AND
STATE OWNED AND LEASED
FACILITIES TO MEET CALIFORNIA'S
TRANSPORTATION GREENHOUSE GAS
GOALS. AND FOR THAT I KNOW
MIAMI HE ENTERED A PLEA TO DROP
PERSISTING. ABILITY HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. NO AT ALL
MANAGER OF YOU. THANK YOU FOR
THAT ARE THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HAVE ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. THAT'S NOT OKAY- I
ACTUALLY JUST A POINT OF
INTEREST- FOR YOUR ITEM NUMBER
FIVE THE CONVERSATION AROUND-
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE HAS COME UP A
FEW TIMES AND I'M CURIOUS IF
YOU CAN PROVIDE US WITH
INFORMATION AS TO WHERE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS BEING BUILT
BASED ON ASSEMBLY DISTRICT TO
YOU HAVE THAT DATA AND IF YOU
DON'T EAT TO HAVE IT NOW BUT
IF. OF SOMETHING THAT YOU CAN
HAVE IN THE FUTURE. HI MY NAME
IS NANCY AND AROUND THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR SUSTAINABILITY AT
EACH YES AND YES WE CAN
DEFINITELY PROVIDE YOU THAT
INFORMATION. WE HAVE ALL OF OUR
INSTALLATIONS BY ADDRESS SO WE
CAN CERTAINLY MAP THEM TO
DISTRICT. GREAT THAT WOULD BE
INCREDIBLY HELPFUL I THINK AND
ARE COMMON IN OUR OVERALL
CONVERSATIONS OUTSIDE OF- NOT
ONLY THIS BUDGET COMMITTEE BUT
IN TERMS OF CALIFORNIA GOALS
FOR. REACHING REACHING THE
GOALS THAT WE HAVE SET IN PLACE
SO I THINK I THINK THE MEMBERS
OF THE ASSEMBLY WOULD REALLY
APPRECIATE KNOWING- IF THERE
ARE ANY INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
RELATED TO THIS PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL AND IF THERE ARE. THEY
ARE IN THEIR DISTRICT WHAT'S
THAT WHAT'S A GOOD DEADLINE OR
GOAL FOR YOU TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THAT THAT INFORMATION-
I DON'T THINK IT'LL TAKE US
MORE THAN A WEEK. OKAY GREAT.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE BEEN
ACCREDITED COMMITTEE STAFF AND
WEEKS GREAT THAT'LL BE
FANTASTIC THANK YOU. IF THERE
ARE NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS WE CAN MOVE ON TO.
THE NEXT- THE NEXT ISSUE
BECAUSE WE ARE WE ARE ASSUMING
THROUGH THINGS ISSUES NOW.
SELLING FOR SELLING THROUGH THE
THING IS LIKE OKAY. I'M TOO
NUMBER FOURTEEN DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY UPDATE BUDGET
REQUESTS- THAT THEIR PANELISTS
FOR THIS ONE ARE JUST IN A CO
HAND SHAPIRO WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY. WITH
HELLO MY GOODNESS VITALY. A I'M
JUST GOING TO HAVE YOU HELP ME
WITH YOUR LAST NAME ALTHOUGH
THE DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
ANDREAS SPIERS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY- AND
THE WARDEN. BRIAN METZGER
EVELYN ASSIDUOUS AND RYAN
LINDBERG THANK YOU WE CAN BEGIN
WITH MISTER COLEMAN SHAPIRO-
ACTUALLY- MADAM CHAIR THIS IS A
NISSAN AND THE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA FROM THE TECHNOLOGY
AND I'M GONNA GO AHEAD AND KICK
THIS OFF AND- AND THEN I TURNED
IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUES. WHICH
IS JUSTIN AND TO SPEAK MORE
ABOUT THE- PROPOSAL THING I'M
GONNA START OFF FROM IF I
DIDN'T HAVE YOU ON THE AGENDA
BUT PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU.
I'M SORRY YEAH I DON'T THINK
WITH- YEAH THAT THAT THE UPDATE
THAT I GOT THAT I WAS ON THE
AGENDA SO I'M COLLEGE EYES BUT
THAT MAKES THE BIG THAT WAS IN
ON- BUT I'LL QUICKLY HANDED
OFF- TO WHAT JUSTIN. SO THE
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY IS TO-
HELP TO PROPOSALS IN FRONT OF
YOUR LONG TERM. MANAGER AND
MEMBERS OF THE PANEL. NOW WE
HAVE ONE. STARTING WITH A
SECURITY PCP. THAT IS
CONVERTING THE COST OF FROM A
RECOVERY FINE INTO GENERAL
FUND. THAT IS TWENTY ONE
DOLLARS ARE REPRESENTING FORTY
NINE POSITION AND I
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE- SECURITY
OPERATIONS CENTER S. AS WELL AS
THE SECURITY AUDIT. FOR
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY ON BEHALF
OF THE STATE. AND THE SECOND
PROPOSAL IN FRONT OF YOU IS
SEVENTEEN PRECISION ASK WITH
THE- ELEVEN POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS. TO STABILIZE THE
STATE- KNOWLEDGE SYSTEM. YEAH
I'M FROM. MY TO INFRASTRUCTURE
TO SYSTEMS THAT ARE CRITICAL TO
BUSINESS. ANY ADDITION TO THAT
THERE'S ALSO- A PORTION THAT
THE SUPPORTING THAT- EXTENDED
RESPONSIBILITY FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE STATE
BROADBAND PLAN- BOTH OF THESE
PROPOSALS ARE CONSISTENT WITH-
THE NEW VISION TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. THAT THE DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY HAVE PUT FORWARD- ON
JANUARY FIFTEENTH. THE NEW
THREE YEAR STRATEGIC PLAN FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
WITH THAT- I COULD EITHER HAND
OFF TO JUSTIN QUESTION
PROPUESTAS CHIEF STRATEGIST. TO
GIVE YOU A LITTLE MORE INSIGHTS
TO THE VISION TWENTY TWENTY
THREE OR WE CAN TAKE QUESTION
ON THE PACIFIC FIRST BEFORE WE
GO INTO. THE VISION. GREAT
THANK YOU MISS TOM. GO AHEAD
PLEASE. ALL RIGHT NOT JUST.
MADAM CHAIR MY NAME'S CRUNCH
PARO THE CHEAP STRATEGIST AT
THE PARK TECHNO AND SO- WE PUT
TOGETHER THESE TECHNOLOGY
STRATEGY OBVIOUSLY IN THE
CONTEXT OF KOPEN- WITH THE
INSPIRATION THAT WE WANT
TECHNOLOGY TO POWER
COMPASSIONATE IN TEAMCENTER
GOVERNMENT- COBIT HAS VERY MUCH
REMINDED US OF THE FRAGILITY OF
COMMUNITIES BUSINESSES LIVES
AND SHOWN WHERE WE MUST PREPARE
BETTER AND BE MORE RESILIENT TO
MEET THE MOMENT WHEN IT COMES.
IN SO TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
WHAT WE DID TO BE ABLE TO PUT
THIS PLAN TOGETHER A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT WHAT WE LEARNED AND
WHAT'S IN THE PLAN ITSELF AND
I'LL BE BRIEF. I'M FIRST IS
THAT WE THE PLANS RESULT OF
UNPRECEDENTED PARTICIPATION
DURING A NEW CURRENTLY HARD
TIME. BUT WE DID SIXTY ONE ON
ONE INTERVIEWS WITH AGENCY AND
DEPARTMENTAL LEADERS- WE
ENGAGED LEGISLATIVE STAFF SO
MANY FOLKS THAT ARE ON
COMMITTEE STAFF HERE. THE L. A.
O. WITH THE POTENTIAL BRANCH AS
WELL AS MEMBERS FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. WE ENGAGE THE
PRIVATE SECTOR- BOTH. YOU KNOW
FOUR HUNDRED DIFFERENT-
TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA 30% OF
WHICH I'D NEVER DONE STATE.
WORK BEFORE- SURVEYED STAFF
THERE ON THE FRONT LINES OF
DELIVERING SERVICES TO THE
PUBLIC AS WELL AS OUR A. I. O.
IN CIO COMMUNITY IN THE
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY TO
UNDERSTAND. SOME OF THE PAIN
POINTS AND OPPORTUNITIES. WE
REPEATED A BUNCH OF THE CASE
HISTORY- BOTH ABOUT WHAT FOLKS
HAVE DONE WELL IN OTHER PLACES.
AS WELL AS WHAT WE'VE LEARNED
FROM THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THEN RAN INTO A CROSS US OF
BUILDING OUT THE PLAN ITSELF
INCLUDING GATHERING SOME
FEEDBACK FROM. STAFF OF THIS
COMMITTEE AS. WELL AS THE L. A.
L. AS WE WERE FINALIZED. SO
COUPLE THINGS THAT WE LEARN.
FROM ONE OF THAT KOBE SHOWN
THAT WE PAY PER. IN AND REALLY
TAKE- DIRECTOR TELLING MYSELF
FOR. SPONSORED MAXINE'S BUT
THAT'S OBVIOUSLY NOT ENOUGH WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
GETTING AHEAD OF PROBLEMS- THAT
WE'RE SOLVING PROBLEMS TOGETHER
WITH THE RIGHT FOLKS IN THE
ROOM- AND MAKING SURE THAT
WE'VE GOT. EASIER AND FASTER
WAYS TO GET STARTED. AND SO
WITH THAT IN MIND- WE PUT OUT
THREE GUIDING PRINCIPLES TO
GUIDE THE WAY THAT WE USE
TECHNOLOGY IN THE STATE- WHICH
ONE OF WHICH WOULD BE A
TREMENDOUS SURPRISE THE FIRST
IS. PUTTING PEOPLE FIRST SO WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
PUTTING BOTH THE RESIDENTS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AS
WELL AS THE FOLKS THAT ARE ON
THE FRONT LINES OF DELIVERING
SERVICES TO. THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA FIRST AS WE ARE
MAKING TECHNOLOGY DECISIONS.
SECOND IS WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THEY WERE MAKING CONTINUOUS
TIMELY IMPROVEMENTS SO IT'S NOT
ENOUGH THAT WE'RE JUST GETTING
BETTER. WE NEED TO GET BTTER
SO THAT WE ARE DELIVERING THE
SERVICE THAT IS NEEDED AT THE
TIME THAT I JUST NEEDED TO- AND
THE THIRD IS WORKING TOGETHER
IT'S WORKING ALONE AND SO WE'VE
SEEN THIS A LOT IN THE CONTEXT
OF THE PANDEMIC- EVEN OUTSIDE.
AND DEMOCRATS TAXED WHERE WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE WE'RE PUTTING
THE RIGHT FOLKS AROUND THE
TABLE TO SOLVE COMMON
CHALLENGES THAT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TECHNOLOGY WHERE WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT. WE HAVE
POLICY AND OPERATIONS. TOGETHER
WITH TECHNOLOGY IN THE DATA AS
WE ARE DECIDING. HOW TO BUILD
SOMETHING THAT IS GOING TO
SUPPORT A PARTICULAR SERVICE.
AND THREE ARTICULATED FIVE
FIVE. GOALS ON THAT WERE
DRIVING TOWARDS MUSIC THESE
ARE. TIMELESS GOALS. THE FIRST
IS MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
DELIVERING EASY TO USE FAST
DEPENDABLE AND SECURE PUBLIC
SERVICES. AND SO YOU KNOW IF
YOU COULD TALK TO ME TWO YEARS
AGO BEFORE THE PANDEMIC I MIGHT
TO FOCUS MORE ON THE EASY TO
USE AND FAST- AND I THINK.
QUITE CLEARLY IN THE LAST. YEAR
DEPENDABLE AND SECURE HAS BEEN-
AN INCREASING FOCUS. AND YOU
KNOW HONESTLY WE'VE DONE A LOT
OF REACTION AND THAT'S CRITICAL
IT'S CRITICAL THAT WHEN
SOMETHING FAILS OR WHEN
SOMETHING NEEDS TO HAPPEN WE GO
AND WE FIX THINGS. BUT AS
DIRECTOR TOM MENTIONED EARLIER
WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE WE'RE GETTING AHEAD OF
THAT MORE PREVENTING ISSUES
BEFORE THEY BECOME FIRES THAT
WE NEED TO ADDRESS IN REAL
TIME. AND SO WITH THAT THAT'S
YOUR VERY MUCH SEARCHING OUT
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL. AROUND
TAKING PREVENTIVE ACTION AROUND
THE BOOKS CRITICAL SERVICES
THAT THE STATE PROVIDES. ON THE
SECOND GOAL IS AROUND MAKING
SURE THAT OUR PUBLIC ARE EQUITY
INCLUDE. I'M IN THE I LIKE TO
USE HERE- ACTUALLY IN THAT-
KRISTIN GRIFFIN ACT US A QUOTE
WE WERE WRITING TO THIS REPORT-
WHERE SAID IF IT SOUNDS
SOMETIMES LIKE WE ARE DESIGNING
SERVICES FOR A YOU KNOW AN
UPPER MIDDLE CLASS WHITE PERSON
WITH A POSTGRADUATE DEGREE- AND
THE REALITY IS THAT YOU KNOW
GOVERNMENT HAS A CRITICAL ROLE
TO PLAY FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
AND SO WE NEED TO AND FOR THAT
THINGS LIKE A READABILITY- ARE
NOT A POSTGRADUATE LEVEL WHICH
MANY OF OUR WEBSITES AND
SERVICES ARE. AND WE NEED TO DO
THE HARD WORK OF SIMPLIFYING
AND DRIVE AND ACCESSIBILITY NOT
JUST IN TERMS OF COMPLIANCE BUT
IN TERMS OF THE ACTUAL
EXPERIENCE THAT PEOPLE HAVE.
THE THIRD- BIG GO IS ROW MAKING.
TECHNOLOGY TO ACCESS USE AND
SHARE AND REUSE ACROSS
GOVERNMENT. AN EXAMPLE I LIKE
TEACHERS HERE- IS AROUND
DIGITAL IDENTIFICATION- TO
RIGHT NOW. IDENTIFICATION IS A
PROBLEM THAT WE SOLVE DOZENS OF
TIMES ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND IF YOU THINK
ABOUT THE EXPERIENCE OF A
INDIVIDUAL CALIFORNIAN TRYING
TO. SOMETHING FROM THEIR
GOVERNMENT THEY HAVE TO HAVE
DIFFERENT LOGGINS FOR DIFFERENT
SERVICES SOMETIMES EVEN WITHIN
THE SAME DEPARTMENTS. AND SO
IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY ABOUT
SAYING OKA RATHER THAN
FIGURING OUT THE YOU KNOW
TRYING TO SOLVE THAT PROBLEM IN
A DEPARTMENT BY DEPARTMENT OR
PROGRAM BY PROGRAM BASIS ONE OF
THE WAYS IN WHICH WE CAN
ACTUALLY LEVERAGE THE SCALE OF
THE STATE AND SOLVE THAT
PROBLEM FEDERATED WAY. SO WE'RE
NOT SAYING HEY THERE'S ONE FOR
ONE SORT OF SOLUTION THAT FITS
ALL CASES BUT WE'RE AT LEAST
FEDERATING AND MAKING SURE THAT
THESE THINGS WORK TOGETHER TO
IMPROVE USER EXPERIENCE IMPROVE
OUR USE. OF THE TAXPAYERS
RESOURCES. THE FOURTH GOAL IS
AROUND BUILDING DIGITAL
GOVERNMENT MORE QUICKLY MORE
EFFECTIVELY AND SERVICE THESE
ARE THINGS LIKE WE PUT A LOT
ABOUT WRITTEN REPLACE PROJECTS
OVER THE YEARS. I'M ONE OF THE
THINGS WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE GETTING BETTER AT
ISN'T MODERNIZING LEGACY
INFRASTRUCTURE WITHOUT REPLACE
SO THINKING ABOUT. SORT OF NEW
NOVEL PATTERSON CASE HISTORIES
ABOUT HOW WE CAN USE THINGS
LIKE THE STRANGLER PATTERN TO
BE ABLE TO SLOWLY TRANSITION
AWAY. UP TO ENABLE MORE
ITERATIVE PROGRESS. AND LAST
BUT NOT LEAST- BUILDING
CONFIDENT EMPOWERED MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAMS AND SO WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
CREATING THE RIGHT SPACES TO
BRING THE BEST OF THE RELEVANT
DISCIPLINES TO THE TABLE AND
THAT'S IMPORTANT AT A
LEADERSHIP LEVEL SO THAT WE
KNOW WHAT TABLES TO SET. AS
WELL AS A TEAM IN THE
INDIVIDUAL LEVELS. AND SO WE
ARTICULATED AND PUT THIS OUT
THERE FOR ANY MEMBERS
INTERESTED OR ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IS INTERESTED YOU CAN
FIND MORE INFORMATION AT
FIFTEEN TWENTY TWENTY THREE DOT
C. T. DOT CA DOT GOV. AND WE
PUT OUT SPECIFIC CHALLENGES
UNDERNEATH THESE GOALS
PRECISELY TO HARNESS AND
SOLICIT INVOLVEMENT IDEAS.
ACROSS THE TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
STATE STAFF LOCAL GOVERNMENT
PUBLIC AND OUR COWORKERS- TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
LEVERAGING THE BEST INFORMATION
OUT. THERE TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEMS AT HAND. THANK YOU
JUSTIN- I'M SURE IN. OF ACCOUNT
WITHOUT WORLD TO ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU FOR THAT. ARE THERE
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PANEL WITH
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. HELLO MR
CHU IS WAITING ON THE LINE
MISTER TO GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- LET ME JUST START
BY BY THANKING- D. T. FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION AND- YOU KNOW I
THINK YOU HAVE HEARD ME. IN
THIS COMMITTEE OVER THE LAST
FIVE YEARS TALK ABOUT THE MANY
I. T. FIASCOS THAT HAVE PLAGUED
STATE GOVERNMENT- WE'RE ALL
VERY FAMILIAR WITH THAT WHAT'S
HAPPENED AT THE DMV. AT
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
AT U. D. D. E. WITH A SCHOLAR
WITH VACCINATION SOFTWARE I CAN
GO ON AND ON- ONE OF THE THINGS
I'D LIKE TO ASK- TO DIRECTOR
TONG. COULD YOU LAY OUT FOR US
SORT OF THE ROLE OF YOUR
DEPARTMENT WHEN IT COMES TO
OTHER I. T. PROJECTS IN OTHER
DEPARTMENTS AND WHAT I'D LIKE
TO UNDERSTAND IS. IT'S CLEAR
THAT- THIS WHOLE SYSTEM IS
INCREDIBLY DECENTRALIZED MANY
DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE MAKING
INDIVIDUAL DECISIONS. WHERE
SITE AND IT APPEARS TO ME THAT
YOUR AGENCY- IS NOT
PARTICULARLY EMPOWERED- TO BE
PROACTIVE IN ADDRESSING THESE
ISSUES OR OR IF ANYTHING- THE
DEPARTMENTS CAN DO WHAT THEY
WANT AND THEN YOU GUYS ARE
BROUGHT IN ALMOST LIKE AN
EMERGENCY ROOM DOCTOR. TRYING
TO FIX- THE HORRIFIC MASS AFTER
A CAR CRASH AND I JUST WANTED
TO UNDERSTAND FROM YOU FROM
YOUR PERSPECTIVE. HOW WAS YOUR
DEPARTMENT INVOLVED IN DECISION
MAKING ON IT PROJECTS WHEN YOU
LOOKED AND- I SEE FROM THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS WE HAVE. AT
LEAST THREE MAJOR- READ RATED
STATUS PROJECTS- AT CORRECTIONS
FOR THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS AT. DH CS FOR
FIFTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS OF
THE CHILD WELFARE SERVICES FOR
FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT ARE IN CODE RED.
AT THIS POINT AND WHAT I WONDER
IS YOU KNOW WE'RE ALWAYS CLEAN
WE SEEM TO BE CLEAN UP THE MESS
AFTER THE FACT. IN PART BECAUSE
I'M CONCERNED YOUR DEPARTMENT
ISN'T SITUATED TO AGAIN BE
PROACTIVE AND TRY TO CENTRALIZE
THE JUST NOT AS SOMEONE IF YOU
COULD COMMENT ON. YES I'M HAPPY
TO AND THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TO FOR THAT THE QUESTION
AND I DO YOU KNOW I AGREE WITH
YOU ABOUT THE OVER ALL I. T.
TRACK RECORD IN THE STATE IS
NOT SOMETHING THAT- YOU KNOW
FRANKLY I MYSELF FOR PRODUCTS.
BUT ONE THING THAT I WANT TO
CLARIFY SPECIFIC ABOUT THE ROLE
OF. CALIFORNIA ON THE
TECHNOLOGY. IS NOT JUST LIKE
YOU DESCRIBE WE ARE IN MANY
TIMES ARE- OPERATING ONE YOUR
DOCTOR. IT IS BECAUSE THE FACT
THAT ON THE DAY TO DAY BASIS.
EACH OF THE DEPARTMENTS AND
THEY'RE HUNDRED THIRTY PLUS
STATE ENTITIES EACH ONE OF THEM
HAVE THEIR OWN I. T. SHOP IN
EACH ONE OF THEM HAVE THEIR- I.
T. BUDGET AND- MAKES OWN- I. T.
PROJECT INVESTMENT DECISIONS.
WITH THE EXCEPTION THE NES
THAT ARE OVER A CERTAIN
THRESHOLD WHICH IS WHAT YOU SEE
IN THE OVERALL IT PROJECT
TRACKING LIST. THAT WENT IN
ONLY WHEN DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY- SIDES OVER
OVERSIGHT. RESPONSIBILITY.
HAVING THAT. I THINK THE-
DESCRIPTION ON THIS TECHNOLOGY.
IT'S A VERY BALLOT ONE. AND WE
KNOW IT'S- THE STATE NH.
DECENTRALIZED MODEL IN MANY
CASES. IT MIGHT BE- YOU KNOW
WARRANTED THE SOME POINT NOT
THINKING HEY THE DEPARTMENT
HAVE A LOT OF FREEDOM TO DO
CERTAIN THINGS. BUT ACTUALLY
WHEN IT COMES TO SOLVING THE
PROBLEM. IN MORE THAN ONCE
ESPECIALLY DEPARTMENT OF
SIMILAR PROBLEMS. FOR CATCHING
PROBLEM YOU KNOW IN IN A
PROACTIVE MANNER RATHER THAN
WAITING UNTIL SOMETHING BLOWS
UP AND WE GET SENT IN AS THE AS
THE OUR DOCTOR TO ADDRESS IT.
IS NOT A VERY EFFECTIVE MODEL.
SO INTO TO ADDRESS STOCK. THE
BUDGET ADDRESS THAT WERE ASKING.
RIGHT NOW THE- STABILITY. NOT
QUITE STRUCTURE AND PRIDE. IT
IS IN THE- TO CORRAL OUT OF A-
APPROACH AND IN AN ATTEMPT TO
SAY HEY LOOK LET'S NOT YOU KNOW
CONTINUE TO BE IN THIS REACTIVE
MODE YOU WE HAVE MORE
VISIBILITY TO IT NOT ONLY- THAT
WE CAN BE MORE PROACTIVE TO IT.
BUT IF WE CAN ACTUALLY HAVE
MORE VISIBILITY TO THE DATABASE
EXPENDITURE IN THE DECISION
MAKING IT MORE COMPETITIVE WITH
THE DEPARTMENT WE CAN BE MORE
INTO WHAT I CALL THE PREVENTIVE
CARE AS OPPOSED TO EMERGENCY
RESPONSE OF CARE INTRO THE HELP
OF THE I. T. INVESTMENT AT THE
PARTICULAR PROGRAM. AND THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE VERY MUCH.
YOU'RE NOT OPEN TO. AND
INVOLVEMENT IN THE LEGISLATURE
AS YOU SEE BECAUSE I UNDERSTAND
YOU HAVE THE OVERSIGHT ROLE YOU
KNOW OVER EXECUTIVE BRANCH AS
WELL AND I KNOW THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT IS ON THE TOP OF
MIND FOR YOU ALL AND WE'RE VERY
MUCH LOOKING FORWARD WITH YOU
WANT TO FIND THE BEST WAY TO
CORRECT THIS CULTURE OF
REACTION. TO PREVENTION. AND I
DON'T WANNA MAKE CLEAR
PARTICULARLY TO OUR COLLEAGUES
ON THIS COMMITTEE- WHO HAVE
HEARD. OVER THE YEARS RAIL
AGAINST DIFFERENT AGENCIES THAT
HAVE MISMANAGING I THINK MISS
HANDLE DIFFERENT I. T. BUDGETS.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE- I
ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT YOUR BUDGET
REQUEST I ACTUALLY THINK. THE
STATE WOULD BE BETTER SERVED IF
WE DID A BETTER JOB OF
CENTRALIZING- DIED DIED. THE
THOUGHT PROCESS THE STRATEGY
BUDGET OVERSIGHT WITHIN YOUR
DEPARTMENT OR AT LEAST GAVE YOU
MORE THIRTY BECAUSE WHAT IT
SEEMS TO ME AS- AGAIN YOU GUYS
OF THE AFTERTHOUGHT YOU'RE
BROUGHT IN. WHEN SOMETHING HAS
BLOWN UP. AND WE NEED TO GET
YOUR EXPERTISE AND EARLIER- I
WAS REALLY STRUCK IN THE VISION
TWENTY TWENTY THREE REPORT I'LL
JUST READ THIS. WHERE YOU FOUND
SEVEN NINE CASE MANAGEMENT
SYSTEMS ACROSS TWENTY TWO
DEPARTMENTS FORTY FIVE
REPORTING SYSTEMS ACROSS
FIFTEEN DEPARTMENTS. TWENTY
SEVEN LICENSING SYSTEMS ACROSS
TWENTY THREE DEPARTMENTS TWENTY
THREE CLAIMS MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS
ACROSS SEVEN DEPARTMENTS TWENTY
CONTENT MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS
ACROSS TEN DEPARTMENTS. THIS
IS. THIS IS. ALMOST A
STEREOTYPE OF WHAT BARACK
CHRISSY GONE WILD. AND FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE IT DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE I REALLY. AYE MAYBE MAYBE
THE ONE FOR ONE OF ONE OF THE
FEW LEGISLATORS THAT IS REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT THIS VISION
TWENTY TWENTY THREE REPORT I
THOUGHT IT WAS. I THOUGHT YOU
RAISES THE RIGHT QUESTIONS AND
ISSUES. THAT WE HAVE SEEN OVER
AND OVER AGAIN AND THIS
COMMITTEE AND I'VE SAID THIS
BEFORE BUT FOR ME. EVERY TIME
WE GET YET ANOTHER MASSIVE I.
T. PROJECT THAT IS YEARS BEHIND
AND TENS IF NOT HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. OVER
BUDGET- WE'RE SEEING THESE
ISSUES HAPPEN OVER AND OVER
AGAIN. AND AND THIS HAS TO STOP
IT'S BEEN GROUND HOG DAY SO I
JUST I GUESS I WANT TO ASK YOU.
WHY IS IT THAT DEPARTMENTS
DON'T SEEM TO BE LEARNING FROM
EACH OTHER'S MISTAKES OR WHAT
CAN WE DO BETTER TO SHARE BEST
PRACTICES. WHAT COULD YOU BE
DOING WORK WE CAN UPLIFT THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY TO. PLAY THIS ROLE.
AND SO ON BAD- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SHE WOULD THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS AND THANK YOU FOR
ACTUALLY READING THE VISION
TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND YOU CAN.
OR WEBER- I'M- VERY OPEN AND
HONEST ABOUT THE CHALLENGES
WE'RE FACING. AND I THINK
THAT'S ACTUALLY STEP NUMBER
ONE. M. FOR LONGER THE
DEPARTMENTS YOU KNOW HUNDRED
THIRTY PLUS DEPARTMENT AND THIS
IS NOT A KNOCKING ANYBODY I
THINK IT'S JUST WHEN YOU WORK
IN THE- PUBLIC SECTOR.
EVERYBODY'S TRYING THEIR
DARNDEST AND BEST TO TRYING TO
MAKE THINGS WORK. BUT WHEN
THINGS ARE NOT GOING WELL
INSTEAD OF KIND OF SAY LOOK
LET'S JUST GET FOLKS INVOLVED
LET'S LEARN FROM OTHER AND
LEARN FROM THE EXPERIENCE. I DO
THINK SOMETIMES OUR PEOPLE ARE.
AFRAID OF FAILURE AFRAID OF-
THINGS ARE GOING WELL THEREFORE
THEY'RE TRYING TO ACTUALLY FIX
IT THEMSELVES. AND THAT IS
ANOTHER THING THAT WE WERE
TRYING TO. YOU KNOW OF WHAT THE
WALKER SO AFRAID WE HAVE NOT
BEEN DOING EVERYTHING
CORRECTLY. NOTHING IS PERFECT
BUT WE'RE NOT AFRAID TO SHARE
THAT KNOWLEDGE AS A WAY OF
MODELING THE WAY FOR THE OTHER
DEPARTMENT TO SAY LOOK. YOU CAN
ASK FOR HELP YOU CAN ACTUALLY
SHARE THE CHALLENGE THAT YOU
HAVE. AN M. AND THEREFORE YOU
KNOW. THAT IN SOME PLACES THE
CROWDSOURCING MORE ADDITION TO
HELP FOR YOU TO OVERCOME THE
CHALLENGE WHICH IS ALSO ANOTHER
THEME AS YOU CAN SEE THAT IN
OUR VISION TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
WE'VE LAID OUT THE CHALLENGE
THERE AND WOOD BUT WE ARE NOT
LIMITING PEOPLE THAT CAN
OVERCOME THIS CHALLENGE. BY
ONLY YOU KNOW THE DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY FOR CALLING HELP
ANYBODY WANTED TO COME ADDRESS
DON'T. WORK TOGETHER IS PART OF
THE CHALLENGING TEAM. AS A WAY
OF SETTING UP THE CULTURE TO
SAY. BE TRANSPARENT WHAT YOU DO
SUNSHINE THE CHALLENGES THAT
YOU'RE FACING SO WE CAN WORK
WITH YOU IN A PROACTIVE MANNER.
AND THAT'S THE MEASURE WE'RE
TRYING TO- CONTINUE TO PUSH
FORWARD WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION.
OF VISION TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
I THINK FROM THIS CAR. ON HER.
A MEETING WITH AND YOUR TEAM TO
TALK THIS MORE BUT I DO HAVE
MAYBE ONE MORE. SO IN THE
TWENTY REPORT- IT STATES QUOTE
PEOPLE MUST SEARCH FOR PUBLIC
INFORMATION AND SERVICES
ACROSS. OVER THREE HUNDRED
WEBSITES. MANAGED BY MORE THAN
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
DEPARTMENTS. USERS FACE
INCONSISTENT AND DISCONNECTED
EXPERIENCES. ON CALIFORNIA.
STATE WEBSITES NOPE CLEARLY.
THIS IS A PROBLEM THIS IS AN
INCREDIBLY INEFFICIENT FOR THE-
SENATE OUR STATE. WE'RE SEEING
THIS RIGHT NOW WITH THE
BREAKDOWNS RIGHT EDT. MY
QUESTION TO YOU IS THERE AS ARE
THEIR STATUTORY REASONS THAT
DEPARTMENTS AREN'T INTEGRATING
ONLINE SERVICES. LIKE ID
VERIFICATION INCOME
VERIFICATION IS THERE MORE.
THAT WE CAN DO TO PUSH BECAUSE
THEY WERE UP TO ME. IF I COULD
GET- YOU KNOW MAJORITY OF OUR
COLLEAGUES IN THE ASSEMBLY IN
THE LEGISLATURE. AND AND THE
GOVERNOR TO SIGN. IT SEEMS THAT
WE GOTTA MOVE TOWARD A MORE
INTEGRATED CENTRALIZED APPROACH
BUT RIGHT NOW. THIS
DECENTRALIZED APPROACH IS
CAUSING ENORMOUS WREAKING
ENORMOUS HAVOC ON THE DAY TO
DAY LIVES OF OUR CITIZENS. I'M
I HAVE JUST TO FREE JUMP IN A
WELL I THINK YOU THE NAIL. YOU
KNOW. YOUR OWN ON FACT THAT. WE
MIGHT HAVE POLICY AUTHORITY WE
MIGHT EVEN SAY HEY LET'S DO IT
TOGETHER. BUT I THINK RIGHT NOW
I DO NOT KNOW WHETHER THERE'S%
ENOUGH LEFT SECRETARY FOR THE
OR I CALL THE CHEAT. BEHIND
THAT IN ORDER TO NOT. COURAGE
BUT TO- RIGHT NOT THE WHAT
MANDATE BUT REALLY REALLY
ENFORCED THE ABILITY TO COME
USE THE STANDARD PLATFORM SO
NOT EVERYBODY INVESTING INTO
THE SAME SOLUTION MULTIPLE
TIMES. OR YOU KNOW IN THE IN A
DIFFERENT WAY OF DOING THAT-
JUST I DON'T KNOW IF WE WANT TO
CHIME IN ON. THAT PARTICULAR.
THANK YOU FOR CALLING- I WOULD
RAN FOR THE POINT. AT I. YOU
KNOW THIS IS VERY MUCH A AREA
WHERE WE CAN EXPLORE POTENTIAL
ADDITIONAL STATUTORY LEVERS-
BUT IT'S ALSO A BIG CULTURAL
SHIFT ASSEMBLY MEMBER. WHERE
YOU KNOW DEPARTMENTS ARE USED
TO RUNNING THEIR OWN
DEPARTMENTAL WEBSITE. WHICH HAS
THE DIRECTOR AND THE
ORGANIZATION OF THE DEPARTMENT
FRONT AND CENTER. AND RUNNING
THEIR OWN I. T. SHOPS AND SO
PART OF WHAT THE CULTURAL
CHANGE WOULD BE IF YOU. WANTED
TO ORIENTED AROUND A CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT IS HE- YOU KNOW WHAT
MATTERS A LOT LESS IS HOW THE
DEPARTMENT STRUCTURED WHAT
MATTERS A LOT MORE OF THE
SERVICES NEED INFORMATION ARE
PROVIDED TO THE PUBLIC. AND
SORTS THAT CULTURAL SHIFT AND
BE SORT OF. AND BOTH THE
INSIGHTS AND CAPABILITIES
AROUND HELPING DEPARTMENTS MAKE
THAT SHIFT THAT ARE GOING TO BE
PART OF THE PROCESS. IN
ADDITION TO THE QUESTIONS
AROUND DUPLICATION OF HOSTING-
THAT AB ALLUDED TO EARLIER.
RIGHT WELL WELL I PER THAT AND-
YOU KNOW I. FULL DISCLOSURE I
HAVE BEEN LOOKING OUT FOR
POTENTIAL STATUTORY IS TO MOVE
THIS. WEEK AS- MONTH AFTER
MONTH OF YET ANOTHER I. T.
SYSTEM GONE AWRY AND THE IMPACT
DURING THIS PANDEMIC IN THIS
RECESSION IS JUST LAID BARE FOR
US JUST HOW INADEQUATE OUR
SYSTEMS ARE. AND WE'VE GOT
REFORM SO- SO I'LL JUST SAY TO
THE PUBLIC IF THEIR IDEAS
PLEASE APPROACH ME I WANT TO
CERTAINLY SET UP SOME TIME TO
DISCUSS FURTHER- I DO HAVE ONE
FINAL QUESTION TO THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S. OFFICE
TO THE L. A. IF IT'S OKAY TO GO
TO LA YOU KNOW- IN THEIR REPORT
IN YOUR REPORT- ELLIE- YOU
STATE THAT WE SUGGEST THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDER WHETHER
STATUTORY CHANGES ARE WARRANTED
TO ESTABLISH GOALS. FOR NEW
PROGRAMS ARE PRIORITIZE CERTAIN
ENTITIES FOR SUSTENANCE I'M
WONDERING IF YOU COULD SHED
SOME LIGHT ON WHAT YOU THINK.
COULD BE HELPFUL HERE BECAUSE
L. A. L. YOU ALSO HAVE BEEN
RESPONSIBLE FOR. HELPING US
UNDERSTAND JUST HOW MANY
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IF NOT BILLIONS OF DOLLARS HAVE
BEEN WASTED BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T
BEEN ABLE TO FIGURE THIS OUT.
MONEY THAT COULD HAVE GONE
DIRECTLY TO CONSTITUENTS COULD
HAVE BEEN ADDRESSING THE NEEDS
OF OUR CONSTITUENTS BUT
INSTEAD- SEEM TO BE GET BOG BOG
DOWN IN IN JUST THE MORASCA IT
PROJECT FAILURES SO TO THE.
ELIO WONDER IF YOUR THOUGHTS ON
THAT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU
BRIAN MINSKER L. A. L. WE MADE
THOSE COMMENTS IN RESPONSE TO
THE PROPOSED PROGRAMS THAT WERE
PART OF THAT STABILIZE CRITICAL
SERVICES AND IT INFRASTRUCTURE
PROPOSAL- AND SO WE ARE NOT
MENTIONING ANY SPECIFIC
STATUTORY CHANGE. OF HEART OF
OUR RECORDS. YOU WISH TO HAVE
AN ONGOING CONVERSATION WITH
YOU AND- OTHER MEMBERS ABOUT-
CDC'S EFFORTS- CERTAINLY
RECOGNIZING THAT THESE NEW
PROGRAMS- WOULD BE. IMPLEMENTED
PROVIDING URALS POTENTIALLY.
FOR CDT. AND SO TO THE EXTENT
PUBLIC WITH ADDRESS IN SO
SOMETHING AROUND THESE NEW
PROGRAM. OR IDENTIFYING SAY A
PARTICULAR ENTITY SUCH AS EDTA
FOR THE YOU KNOW FIRST-
ASSESSMENT THAT THESE PROGRAMS
WOULD PROVIDE WE'D CERTAINLY BE
INTERESTED IN HELPING YOU WITH
THAT. AMEN MAYBE LET ME JUST
CLOSE BY SAYING THAT. QUOTING A
GREAT CHIEF CONSULTANT THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE
CHRISTIAN GRIFFITH YOU KNOW
GETS COMMENT ABOUT HOW- WE
ASSUME THE PUBLIC ARE UPPER
MIDDLE CLASS WHITE PEOPLE WITH
COLLEGE DEGREES I OFTEN THINK.
THAT THE DISCUSSION AROUND
TECHNOLOGY THERE'S A LOT OF
ACRONYMS THERE ARE A LOT OF
KIND OF THINGS TURN AROUND
THERE A LOT OF BUREAUCRATS YOU
HAVE GRADUATE DEGREES THAT ARE
ARGUING THE STUFF BUT
FUNDAMENTALLY. OUR IT SYSTEMS
ARE BROKEN. AND IT IS NOT
BECAUSE OF THE FAULT OF THE OF
THE PHARMACOLOGY FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE. IT IS BECAUSE TOO
MANY DEPARTMENTS ARE IN OVER
THEIR HEADS TRYING TO MOVE
FORWARD. WITH PROJECTS THAT
THEY HAVE NO BUSINESS TRYING TO
OPERATE AND WE'VE SEEN THAT
TIME AFTER TIME IN THIS
COMMITTEE. AND I HAVE TO MEET
SIX YEARS AND DURING THIS
PANDEMIC DURING THIS RECESSION
I'M JUST HARD. SO I AM LOOKING
FORWARD TO ENGAGE N THIS
CONVERSATION I'M HOPING THAT WE
CAN FIGURE OUT HOW TO TURN THIS
AROUND AND AGAIN OPEN TO. IDEAS
FROM DAILY- FROM DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY FROM INDIVIDUAL
AGENCIES. WHO WHO HAVE- WHO
HAVE BORNE THE BRUNT OF OUR
FEEDBACK OVER THE YEARS
BECAUSE- AGAIN. DOLLARS ARE AT
STAKE AND BEING ABLE TO SERVE
OUR CONSTITUENTS IS WHAT IS AT
STAKE AS WELL WITH THAT THANK
YOU- MANAGER BACK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER TO I THINK FUND.
WHAT YOU REYES ARE ALSO ISSUES
OF EQUITY. ARE GIVEN TO THE
PANDEMIC WE NEED NOW. HAVE SHED
LIGHT ON TO SOMETHING THAT MANY
OF US ALREADY KNEW AND THAT.
BROADBAND ACCESS TO THE
INTERNET IS NOT SO EASILY
AVAILABLE ACROSS THE STATE
ESPECIALLY IN COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE MOST DISENFRANCHISED THAT
BEING URBAN OR RURAL
COMMUNITIES THAT. SIMPLY JUST
DON'T HAVE ACCESS AND WORKING
WITH- TECHNOLOGY AND WEBSITES
THAT ARE ANTIQUATED AND DON'T
OFFER A GOOD. USER EXPERIENCE
IS A PROBLEM- ONE OF THE MAIN
ONES THAT WE'VE SEEN SO FAR IS-
EDT IN TERMS OF. HOW DOES ONE
GET ACCESS TO A SMARTPHONE TO
TAKE A PHOTO TO VALIDATE
YOURSELF AND IDENTIFY WHO YOU
ARE. WHEN MOST LOW INCOME
WORKERS- ACTUALLY USE FLIP
PHONES THAT YOU GET FROM A
CONVENIENCE STORE. AND DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO PAY THE ONE
HUNDRED DOLLAR PLUS FOR A
SMARTPHONE. WELL WE'RE ASKING
THEM TO VERIFY AND IDENTIFY
THEMSELVES SO THAT THEY GET
ACCESS TO THE BENEFITS THAT
THEY SO RIGHTFULLY DESERVE. IT
IS AN ISSUE OF TECHNOLOGY THAT
WE ARE IN A ANOTHER GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO TRY TO SOLVE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT. SCENE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM. THE COMMITTEE
WE WILL MOVE ON TO THE NEXT-
ISSUE AREA WE ARE AN ISSUE. A
NUMBER FIFTEEN. OUT OF
SEVENTEEN SO WE'RE ALMOST
THROUGH. THE OFFICE OF PLANNING
AND RESEARCH BUDGET BUDGET
PROPOSALS. IN THIS PANEL WE
HAVE. KATE GORDAN WITH THE
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH
SCOTT MORGAN SAME OFFICE. BRIAN
WHETHER FORD WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AND EMMA AND JOHN WORTH WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
LET'S BEGIN. THANK YOU SO MUCH
CHAIR CARILLO I HOPE YOU CAN
HEAR ME I AM CAIT GORDON ON THE
DIRECTOR OF THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF PLANNING RESEARCH
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL. AND
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS UNDER ITS
ADMINISTRATIVE UNIT AND- JUST A
LITTLE BACKGROUND ON OPR
BECAUSE SOMETIMES I THINK IT
IT'S GOOD THAT REMINDER TO
FOLKS ESPECIALLY THE PUBLIC OF
WHAT WE DO. OKAY OUR SERVICE TO
PROVIDE INPUT AND GUIDANCE TO
THE GOVERNOR CABINET
LEGISLATURE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT A LONG RANGE
PLANNING AND POLICY ISSUES WE
SERVE. AS A COORDINATOR
FACILITATOR OF ISSUES THAT ARE
CROSS CUTTING IN NATURE AND
DON'T FIT NATURALLY INTO AN
EXISTING AGENCY BUT INVOLVE
COLLABORATION AND ENGAGEMENT
ACROSS AGENCIES. FOUR FOUR
MAJOR AREAS OF FOCUS AND I
SHOULD SAY- I ENCOURAGE MEMBERS
AND THE PUBLIC TO LOOK AT OUR
WEBSITE WHICH WE JUST
REDESIGNED IN HOUSE. UNDER THE
KIND OF CORE PRINCIPLES THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
JUST LIKE AROUND ACCESS AND
READABILITY SPECIFICALLY SO I'M
REALLY. PROUD OF THAT AND FOR
AREAS WHERE WE FOCUSED OUR-
LAND USE AND PLANNING. CLIMATE
RISK AND RESILIENCE INCLUDING
EMERGENCY RESPONSE TO RECOVERY.
HIGHROAD ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
FOR SUSTAINABLE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND LONG RANGE
RESEARCH INITIATIVE THIS
INCLUDES A VOTE VARIETY OF
CATHOLIC CROSS GENERAL PLANETS
PEOPLE GUIDANCE TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. THE INTEGRATED
CLIMATE ADAPTATION RESEARCH
PROGRAM THE REGION'S AUTHORIZED
TOGETHER AND JUST TRANSITION.
PROGRAMS PRECISION MEDICINE THE
MILITARY COUNCIL AND ALL OF THE
DIRECT PROGRAMS PROVIDED
THROUGH DISTRICT YOU BROKE
COUNCIL AND CALVET YEARS. WE
PERFORM THESE FOUR BIG
FUNCTIONS A VERY SMALL STAFF OF
JUST NINETY SEVEN POSITIONS
OVERSEEING AND ADMINISTERING
OVER FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN STATE FUNDS
PRIMARILY GOING OUT THE DOOR IN
GRANTS OR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
DIRECTLY TO COMMUNITY. OUR
BUDGET REQUEST FOCUS ON ADDING
CAPACITY TO MANAGE OUR
ADMINISTRATIVE AND
COMMUNICATIONS REQUIREMENTS
ACROSS ALL THREE UNITS. AS WELL
AS THE BUILD MINIMAL CAPACITY
TO MEET OUR STATUTORY
RESPONSIBILITIES TO PROVIDE
GUIDANCE AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE ACROSS. GOVERNMENT
AS WELL AS TO REGIONAL LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS SAID THOSE
SPECIFICALLY ARE. ONE POINT ONE
MILLION AND SEVEN POSITIONS TO
ADDRESS INCREASED WORKLOAD AND
STRENGTHEN ADMINISTRATIVE
OPERATIONS ACROSS ALL THREE OF
OUR UNITS OF PR FOR VEHICLE
COUNCIL CALDERON TEARS IN
RECOGNITION. OF INCREASE
STATUTORY GRANTING CONTRACTING
ACTIVITIES. FIVE HUNDRED EIGHT
THOUSAND THREE POSITIONS TO
CONTINUE THE REGIONAL CLIMATE
COLLABORATIVE PROGRAM CREATED
AT THE STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL
THROUGH SB TEN SEVENTY TWO
WHICH PROVIDED ONLY TWO YEARS
INITIALLY OF SUPPORT FOR THAT
PROGRAM. REALIGNMENT OF
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS IN BE AT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES PROGRAM
THROUGH STC TO REFLECT THE
REALITY. OF THE COMPLEXITY AND
THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE NEEDS
THAT OF WRITING NOT PROGRAM AND
I JUST WANTED TO KNOW THAT THE
PROGRAM CURRENTLY RUNS WITH
LESS THAN ZERO POINT 4%
ADMINISTRATIVE OVERHEAD SO THIS
WOULD BE A REALIGNMENT TO ALLOW
FOR MORE ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT
FOR THE PROGRAM. FOUR HUNDRED
SIX THOUSAND TO IMPLEMENT A
JUST TRANSITION ROADMAP AS
REQUIRED BY EXECUTIVE ORDER AND
SEVENTY NINE TWENTY BUT ALSO.
BY THE STATE'S OVERALL FOCUS ON
THE TRANSITION TO A CARBON
NEUTRAL ECONOMY BY TWENTY FORTY
FIVE. HUNDRED SEVENTY THREE
THOUSAND AND DOLLARS AND ONE
POSITION EMPLOYMENT AB TWENTY
TWO THIRTEEN FOCUSED ON
PLANNING GUIDANCE AND VOLUNTEER
COORDINATION FOR CALVET HERE'S
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS DURING
DISASTERS AND FINALLY. ONE
POINT SEVEN MILLION AND NINE
STAFF POSITIONS THE CALIFON
TEARS TO MAINTAIN THE EMERGENCY
RESPONSE FRAMEWORK THAT WAS PUT
IN PLACE DURING COMBAT. WE ALSO
I SHOULD SAY HAVE A SMALL PIECE
OF THE OVERALL WILDFIRE BUDGET
BUT THAT'S NOT BEING ADDRESSED
HERE TODAY I KNOW THAT'S BEING
ADDRESSED IN ANOTHER HEARING
SO. THOSE ARE MADE PROPOSALS
SCOTT MORGAN MY CHIEF DEPUTY
AND I ARE HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR THAT LET'S HEAR FROM MR
WHETHER FORD AND- IN STRONG
WORTH WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. YES BRENT WHETHER FORD
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- REGARDING THE
ADMINISTRATIVE STAFF
AUGMENTATION RECIPIENT. THANKS
FOR STOPPING WE NEED THESE
POSITIONS ARE REASONABLE IN
LIGHT OF THE SIGNIFICANT GROWTH
IN THE- ON THE STATUTORY
RESPONSIBILITIES OF THE OFFICE
OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH. STEP
COMMITTED THE OBJECT AND IT DID
HIGHLIGHT THE INCREASED SIZEAND SCOPE OF THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING RESEARCH AND- BUT WE
DON'T HAVE ANY SPECIFIC
CONCERNS ABOUT. THIS TIME WILL
BE HAPPY TO HELP YOU CONSIDER
THESE ISSUES. THANK WORK
DEPARTMENT AND WE HAVE NO
ADDITIONAL CONCERNS- AT THIS
TIME YEAH. THANK YOU TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HAVE
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. OKAY
I DO HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS
FOR YOU MISS GORDON THE AGENDA
RAISES CONCERNS ABOUT THE
GROWTH OF THIS OFFICE CAN YOU
COMMENT ON THAT. SURE
ABSOLUTELY SO MOST OF THE
GROWTH IN THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING RESEARCH IN TERMS OF
OUR BUDGET WHICH AGAIN IS
PRIMARILY GOING OUT THE DOOR
ACTUALLY IN IN DIRECT GRANTS
AND SUPPORTED IN TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE MOST OF THAT GROWTH
COMES THROUGH THE STRATEGIC
GROWTH COUNCIL. THE STRATEGIC
pORIGINALLY PART OF THE OFFICE
OF PLANNING RESEARCH IT WAS
ORIGINALLY PART OF THE
RESOURCES AGENCY ALTHOUGH IT
WAS CO LOCATED WITH THE OFFICE
OF PLANNING RESEARCH. THE I. OD
STATUTORY DIRECTION OF ODD
FUNDING THROUGH THE GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION FUND TO THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES PROGRAM
THE TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES PROGRAM AND THEN
NOW THE REGIONAL CLIMATE
COLLABORATIVE'S PROGRAM. AS
WELL AS THE CLIMATE RESEARCH
PROGRAM ALL RUN THROUGH AS YOU
SEE AT THE FINANCIALLY I
DIRECTED AT A SIGNIFICANT OUT
OF FUNDS TO BE RUN THROUGH OUR
OFFICE AND THROUGH S. YOU SEE
SINCE THAT TIME. ALL OF THESE
PROGRAMS ARE REALLY HIGH. I
THINK RELEVANT TO OPR SEVERAL
FOCUS BECAUSE THEY ARE CROSS
CUTTING THEIR PROGRAMS THAT
BRING TOGETHER ARE THE STATE'S
HOUSING TRANSPORTATION CLIMATE
AND EQUITY GOALS. UNDER ONE
ROOF I WITH THE GOAL TOWARD OR
AN IDEA TOWARD A MORE
SUSTAINABLE AND RESILIENT AND
INCLUSIVE GROWTH PATTERN FOR
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS UP ON
THE GROUND HOUSING PROJECTS
THAT SHOW EXACTLY HOW THAT
MONEY IS SPENT AND WHAT IT
LOOKS LIKE TO DO A REALLY IS.
THE STATE ABOUT RESILIENCE YOU
KNOW AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECT
FOR INSTANCE GOING FORWARD SO
WE THINK THEY'RE VERY
PERFORATED OPR AND AGAIN THE
MAJORITY OF THAT FUNDING IS
GOING DIRECTLY OUT THE DOOR
WITH VERY VERY LIMITED STAFF
PROVIDING. VERY EFFICIENT
SERVICES TO GET IT OUT. THANK
YOU FOR THAT- UPLIFT. RESTORED
IN. I GUESS MY CONCERN REALLY
IS IF YOU WERE TO IF YOU LOOK
AT THE GROWTH OF OPR IT. REALLY
COINCIDES WITH OTHER LARGE
DEPARTMENTS LIKE THE DEPARTMENT
OF TECHNOLOGY THAT DEPARTMENT
CONSUMER AFFAIRS. AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIN SUBSTANCE
CONTROL THE TSC. WHICH- HAS
ACTUALLY NOT BEEN GREAT IN
DEALING WITH IT A HUGE ISSUE IN
MY DISTRICT AND OTHER MEMBERS
DISTRICT- KNOWN AS EXCITED
WHICH I BELIEVE IS THE LARGEST
ENVIRONMENTAL DISASTER ACROSS.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT NO
ONE KNOWS ABOUT. AND SO I AM
I'M JUST CONCERNED IN TERMS OF.
THE GROWTH OF A DEPARTMENT AND
COMPARE INSTANT IN COMPARISON
TO OTHER DEPARTMENTS THAT.
DON'T NECESSARILY- REPORTS OR
ACT OR CONVEY TRUST IN THEIR
ABILITY TO FUNCTION. AND SO I'M
I'M CURIOUS WHAT YOU THINK OF
THAT IN TERMS OF IF YOU WERE TO
COMPARE DEPARTMENTS AT THAT
SCALE- FUNCTIONALITY OF IT.
ABSOLUTELY I THINK IT'S- IT'S
THAT IMPORTANT POINT I DO WANT
TO POINT OUT IT'S A LITTLE BIT
OF APPLES AND ORANGES
COMPARISON FROM A BUDGET
STANDPOINT. OPR AGAIN PRIMARILY
INCLUDES PATH THROUGH GRANTS
INCLUDING THAT FOR A HOUSING
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES PROGRAM
WHICH IS BY FAR OUR BIGGEST
PROGRAM THROUGH THE STREETS
TRIPITAKA COUNCIL IF YOU LOOK
AT OVERALL BUDGETS DTS YOU
TOTAL BUDGET IS SIX HUNDRED
FIFTEEN MILLION CD T. IS FOR
NINETY TWO AND A PR CIS FIVE
TWENTY ONE BUT- MOST OF THOSE
DOLLARS ARE GREAT DOLLARS SO
FROM A STAFF PERSPECTIVE. ETFC
HAS NINE HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO
POSITIONS ST EIGHTY EIGHT
HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO WHAT OKAY
ARE JUST NINETY SEVEN VERSIONS
ON THE BOOKS SO. WE REALLY FEEL
THAT WE ARE PROVIDING EXTREMELY
EFFICIENT SERVICES ON FIVE
HUNDRED TWENTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS IN STATE FUNDS AT A
FRACTION OF THE COST THAT OTHER
EIGHT THAT OTHER DEPARTMENTS
DO. THAT ARE AT WORK STREATLEY
EFFICIENT WERE EXTREMELY LEAN-
AND WE PRIDE OURSELVES ON BEING
YOU KNOW THEY ARE TO PROVIDE A
VIGOROUSLY IN PORT AN ESSENTIAL
FUNCTION PARTICULARLY. AS THE
FIFTH FACING INCREASING THE
ACTORS AND OUR LACK OF
RESILIENCE IN THE FACE OF THE
EARTH AFTER HIS BECOMING
CLEARER. WE REALLY FINANCED
THROUGH- HIGHLIGHT THE LONG
TERM POLICY PLANNING ISSUES
THAT THE STATE IS FACING TO
LOOK AT BUILDING OUT A MORE
RESILIENT SYSTEM A MORE
SUSTAINABLE SYSTEM AT DOING
THAT AGAIN IS EFFICIENTLY AS
POSSIBLE SO I THINK. WE WHEN
YOU REALLY LOOK AT THE KIND OF
DIG INTO THE NUMBERS ON THOSE
DEPARTMENTS CHAIR I THINK. YOU
REALLY SEE THAT WE ARE- WE'RE
PRETTY LEE. I APPRECIATE THAT
YOU THAT IN OF MISS I THAT'S AS
A ABOUT YOUR RESEARCH IN TERMS
OF THE- REPRESENTATION OF THE
DEPARTMENT I APPRECIATE THAT
HAS THE ADMINISTRATION
CONSIDERED MOVING SOME OF THE
OFFICE FUNCTIONS TO A
DEPARTMENT. OUTSIDE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. OVER TIME IT
YES FIRST. CERTAIN THINGS IT'S
INTERESTING YOU KNOW WE AT OPR
AND I'LL LET SCOTT BECAUSE THIS
IS WELL IF YOU'VE BEEN THERE
FOR MUCH LONGER THAN I HAVE BUT
AT OPR. WE ACTUALLY PRIDE
OURSELVES ON ON. HELPING THE
LEGISLATURE ANOTHER AGENCIES
AND THE GOVERNOR- THINGS WHERE
APPROPRIATE WE'VE SPENT A FAIR
AMOUNT OF THIS BUDGET SEASON
FOR INSTEAD. OF FOCUSING ON THE
BUDGETS OF OTHER AGENCIES THAT
WE THINK ARE MORE WELL SUITED
TO SOME FUNCTIONS THAN WE ARE
WE HAVE SUPPORTED GO BANS ON
BUILDING UP POSITIONS IN THIS
BUDGET WE SUPPORTED THE I. BANK
IN THE CLUB A CATALYST FUND.
WE'VE BEEN- YEAH I WOULD GET A
YEAR LONG COLLABORATION WITH
THEIR RESOURCES AGENCY TO
REALLY IDENTIFY WHAT PIECES OF
CLIMATE RESILIENCE MAKES SENSE
EVERY FORCES VERSUS- PR. SO I
LIKE TO THINK THAT WE'RE VERY
INTENTIONAL. ABOUT WHAT WE CAN
DO WHAT WE SHOULD DO AND WHERE
OPR SCORE VALUE WITH WHICH IS
REALLY THAT COORDINATION
FUNCTION. BEING ABLE TO LOOK AT
LONGTIME RETIREMENT BEING ABLE
TO SUPPORT YOU NO LONGER TERM
KIND OF FUNCTIONS AT OTHER
AGENCIES BUT ALL OUTSIDE SCOTT
IF YOU HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD TO
THAT. FROM A HISTORICAL CONTEXT.
YEAH I WOULD AGREE WITH THOSE
COMMENTS KATE'S CALIFORNIA WITH
A P. R. THE MANY TIMES WILL WE
END UP DOING IS PARTNERING WITH
OTHER ENTITIES EARLY ON IN
PROJECTS. AND THEN. HAVING THEM
OVER TAKE KIND OF THE DAY TO
DAY OPERATIONS ON THINGS SO. IF
YOU THINK ABOUT THE ONLINE
LEARNING LAB WE PARTNERED WITH-
THE FOUNDATION OF COUNT
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
TO HELP US IMPLEMENT THAT. THE
CRADLE TO CAREER PROGRAM IS
SIMILAR TO THAT WHERE WE'VE
WE'VE- PARTNERED WITH CSU. AND
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
MORE. EXPERTS IN THAT FIELD SO.
YOU KNOW WE END UP KIND OF
FINDING THE SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS AND WORKING WITH THEM
AND HAVING THEM. HELP US
IMPLEMENT A LOT OF THOSE PRETTY
PROGRAM SO. YOU KNOW WE DO YOU
KNOW OFFLOAD PROJECTS. AS WE
CANDID TO THE EXPERTS THAT ARE
IN THOSE FIELDS AS MUCH AS WE
CAN. GOT IT THANK YOU MISTER
MORGAN. I DON'T HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT- WE HAVE ANY FROM
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS AS WELL
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TAKING
THE TIME APPRECIATED FOR GONNA
MOVE ONTO. HERE ARE. I'M SORRY.
OKAY THANK YOU- WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO OUR ISSUED NUMBER
SIXTEEN GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS
AGENCY ROLE IN CRISIS. A VERY
TIMELY WE'RE GOING TO GO WITH
OUR PANELISTS JUSTIN HOWARD
WITH GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS
AGENCY CHEST ALAMO WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
EVELYN SEUSS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND RYAN
WEINBERG WITH APARNA FINANCES
WELL LET'S BEGIN MISTER HOWARD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR CAN YOU
HEAR ME OK YES WE CAN HEAR YOU
OKAY GREAT THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TODAY.
TO DISCUSS THAT ARE AGENCIES
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY
OUR ROLE IN THE CRISIS I THINK
THE AGENDA LAYS OUT VERY WELL
BACKGROUND HISTORY BUT I'LL GO
THROUGH. PIECES OF IT AGAIN I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT OUR AGENCY WERE ALLEGEDLY
NEW AGENCY WE WERE ESTABLISHED
BACK IN JULY OF 2013% TO THE
GOVERNMENT REORGANIZATION PLAN
NUMBER TWO- WE WERE CREATED IN
ORDER TO HELP SIMPLIFY YOUR
STRENGTH AND IMPROVE THE
OPERATION MANAGEMENT PROGRAMS.
THAT PROTECT AND PROVIDE
SERVICES TO STATE AGENCIES
UNEMPLOYED. WE ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR ADMINISTERING A VARIETY OF
FUNCTIONS THAT EXIST IN THE
GENERAL OPERATIONAL STATE
GOVERNMENT SUCH AS CHAIRMAN
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY HUMAN
RESOURCES. OUR GOAL ULTIMATELY
IS TO HELP FOSTER STATEWIDE
PERSPECTIVES IMPROVE
COMMUNICATION AND INFORMATION
SHARING THE CHANGE DEPARTMENT
POP CULTURES THAT PRIORITIZE
CONTROL OVER SERVICE WE ARE
COMPRISED OF- TEN DIFFERENT.
STATE ENTITIES IN TWO SEPARATE
STANDALONE OFFICE IS THAT ALL
REPORTER AGENCY ONE OF THE
SMALLER AGENCIES THE STATE
GOVERNMENT BUT ULTIMATELY WE
ARE TASKED WITH SIGNIFICANT
POLICIES THAT WE HAVE TO
IMPLEMENT ALL OF WHICH
TYPICALLY HAVE CROSS CUTTING-
IMPLICATIONS. FOR ALL STATE
DEPARTMENTS. I'M WITHIN THE
PAST YEARS BOB HAS UP FOR GRAND
OFFICES WHAT BY SIXTY TWO
MILLION BEFORE. TO NEW
DEPARTMENTS ALL OVER- VARIOUS-
THE- VARIOUS THINGS WILL LABOR
RELATIONS CHAIRMAN CHU AND TO
AND- FURTHERMORE COLLAPSES
BROUGHT INTO ASSESS OTHER STATE.
THROUGH OPERATIONAL CHALLENGES
THAT EXISTS ON SOME OF THOSE
EXAMPLES AS NOTED IN THE AGENDA
WHAT THE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
VEHICLES ANALYSTS STRIKE TEAM.
A LITTLE OVER A YEAR AGO AS
WELL AS READ MOST RECENTLY EVP.
STRAIGHT TEAM THIS PAST FALL.
BOB THIS IS A VERY UNIQUE ROLE
WITHIN STATE GOVERNMENT AND SO
FAR AS WE ARE ABLE TO CUT
THROUGH SOME OF THE FOR LACK OF
A BETTER WORD RED TAPE THAT
EXISTS BECAUSE WE OVERSEE THREE
OF THE- FOUR MAJOR CONTROL
DEPARTMENTS WITHIN THE STATE.
THOSE BEING THE DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY WHO YOU HAD ON
REGION EARLIER THE DEPARTMENT
OF GENERAL SERVICES AS WELL AS
SPEAK. AND DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN
RESOURCES. WILD DEVOPS- IS
ALWAYS WILLING TO HELP WHEN
ASKED FOR ASSISTANCE. FROM OUR
FELLOW DEPARTMENTS OUT THERE
ONE OF OUR GOALS THAT WE'RE
HOPING TO DO AND SOME OF THE
PROPOSALS AND THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET ARE AIMED AT THIS ARE TO
BE MORE PROACTIVE IN TERMS. IN
TERMS OF HELPING TO IDENTIFY
IDENTIFY ISSUES AND ADVANCE OF
THEM BECOMING A CRISIS- SO THAT
WAY WE ARE ALWAYS BEING
REACTIVE AND BEHIND THE BALL
SOME OF THOSE AND SOME OF THOSE
EXAMPLES INCLUDE THAT RESOURCE
IS BEING REQUESTED BY CDTV WAS
PREVIOUSLY DISCUSSED AS WELL
FOR ADDITIONAL RESOURCES. THE
REQUESTED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
HUMAN RESOURCES THAT ARE. GOING
TO HELP US BE MORE PROACTIVE
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS IN ADVANCE
SO THAT THEY DON'T FALL INTO
THE- THE CRISIS THAT WE HAVE
SEEN. WITH EDT- AND DMB. AND
WHAT I'M TO- AND ANY QUESTIONS
OF THE MEMBERS HAVE ABOUT OUR
WALNUT SOME TALKING HERE ABOUT-
OUR RECENT- BEING PASSED TO
HELP WITH THE VACCINE RELATED
EFFORTS- I'LL JUST NOTE THAT-
PART OF THE- THE WORK THAT
WE'RE DOING RELATED TO VACCINES
AND THE- RELATION AND
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE TGA IS
STILL. UNDER WAY- IT HAS NOT
BEEN FINALIZED AND- TIONS.
AGREEMENT IS STILL. ONGOING SO
IRAQI INTELLIGENCE TOO MUCH
ABOUT THAT BUT I CAN SHARE
WHAT- I CAME IN TERMS. ROLES
AND RESPONSIBILITIES RELATED TO
CHRIST. THANK YOU FOR THAT
MISTER HOWARD LET'S HEAR FROM
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE AS WELL AS THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. THANK YOU-
CHAD ALAMO WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE ON A FEW
COMMENTS IT SPECIFICALLY IN
REGARD TO- THAT GOV OPS IS ROLE
WITH THE EDT STRIKE TEAM REPORT
ON. WHAT WE ARE CONSISTENT WITH
SOME OF THE COMMENTS IN THE
STAFF AGENDA REGARDING SORT OF
SETTING ACCOUNTABILITY AND
EXPECTATIONS FOR OF OPS- WE
THINK THAT'S A AN ONGOING
CONVERSATION THE LEGISLATURE TO
HAVE GIVEN THIS SORT OF NEW
ROLE. THAT WERE SAYING THE
AGENCY PLAY AND CRISIS
MANAGEMENT FOR STATE OPERATIONS
ON. THE STRIKE TEAM REPORT- WAS
UNDERTAKEN AND HEADED BY THE
GOVERNOR OFFICE AGENCY AND WHEN
THAT REPORT WAS RELEASED IN
SEPTEMBER THIS SUBCOMMITTEE
HEARD- FROM REPRESENTATIVES
FROM THE AGENCY AS AS WELL AS
OUR OFFICE AND- IN REVIEWING
THE STRIKING REPORT ITSELF IT
WAS INCREDIBLY THOROUGH IT WAS
CRITICAL OF EDIE'S LONGSTANDING
OPERATIONS- AND- CULTURAL-
PERSPECTIVES RELATED TO FRAUD
PREVENTION. AND IT WAS
RELATIVELY CONSISTENT WITH HOW
OUR OFFICE HAD VIEWED THE
CHALLENGES THAT EDT BUT ONE OF
THE ISSUES WE RECOMMENDED AT
THE TIME THIS WAS IN OCTOBER.
WAS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
ENCOURAGED GOV OFFICE TO
MAINTAIN. AN OVERSIGHT ROLE OF
EDIE'S PROGRESS IN IMPLEMENTING
THE RECOMMENDED CHANGES IN THE
STRIKE TEAM REPORT. AND GIVEN
ITS NEW ROLE THERE THERE
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE A
LEGISLATIVE MECHANISM FOR
ENSURING THIS KIND OF
OVERSIGHT- AND SO I RAISE THAT
BECAUSE OF THE UNIQUE NATURE OF
DEVOPS IS ROLE IN THE
REDISTRICTING REPORT ONGOING
CONVERSATION. BETWEEN THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT HOW THE
AGENCY WELL. ESTABLISH
ACCOUNTABILITY ROLES AND
EXPECTATIONS WHEN IT IS
INVOLVED IN AN SERVE STEPPING
IN WITH DEPARTMENTS TO WORK IN
A CRISIS SITUATION LIKE THIS
THANK YOU I'M HAPPY THAT STAY
ON THE PANEL FOR QUESTIONS- BUT.
AGAIN JUST. BOB RESERVING MY
COMMENTS TO ET DE SPECIFIC
THANK. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
RIGHT ONE OF THE FINANCE
FINANCES. OR ANYTHING GIVEN
MISSION FOR OUR OFFICE FIVE.
BUT THANK ARE THERE ANY COMMON
FROM COMMITTEE. ROGER YES
MISTER CHIP FIVE MAY I LET ME
FIRST START I WANT TO JUST
COMPLEMENT GOV OPS FOR YOUR
ROLE IN DEALING WITH SOME OF
THE MOST INTENSE CRISIS WE'VE
HAD RECENTLY PARTICULAR AROUND
DMV AND EDT- ANDREALLY- YOU
KNOW AS WAS ALLUDED TO THE
DISTRACTING REPORT THAT TO US
SECRETARY RICHARDSON WAS WAS A
PART OF AND YOUR TEAM IS A PART
OF REALLY DID I THINK PROVIDE
AT LEAST AN INITIAL ROAD PATH
FOR MOVING US OUT OF THE EDT
MORASS BUT I HAVE TO ASK THE
QUESTION TO GO BOPS REITERATING
WHAT ELIO HAS JUST ASKED. BUT
THE NUMBER OCCASIONS. HOW IS IT
THAT THE DMV STRIKE TEAM
CONTINUES ON FOR THE BETTER
PART OF THE YEAR AND REALLY.
SHEPHERDS MUCH NEEDED REFORMS
THERE WHEN IN THE CONTEXT OF
EDT. GIVEN HOW INTENSE THIS
CRISIS IS HOW MANY MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE IT'S IMPACTING HOW MANY
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS. WE'VE
SEEN. DISAPPEAR TO FRAUD. THE
IDEA THAT. WE WERE. ONLY HAD A
FORTY FIVE DAY STRIKE TEAM.
ENGAGEMENT AND AT THIS TIME
WITH AN AGENCY THAT'S ONLY
IMPLEMENTED HALF OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS WHILE THE
BACKLOG HAS GOTTEN WORSE. WHILE
MAJOR FRAUD CONCERNS OF
MATERIALIZE I'VE GOT TO ASK WHY
IS GOV OX NOT ENGAGING AND
ANOTHER ROUND OF. THE STRIKE
TEAM EFFORT- TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS GETS DONE BECAUSE FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE. EDT NEEDS ALL THE
HELP THEY CAN GET AND IT SEEMS
THAT. IN THE FORTY FIVE PLUS
DAYS THAT. YOUR AGENCY WAS
INVOLVED. YOU HELPED A BIT AND-
YOU KNOW I THINK. REGAUGED
INCOME. ASSIST AT THIS TIME.
THE QUESTION. NUMBER TWO- I
GUESS I'LL JUST OFF BY SAYING
USUALLY WHEN WE'RE CALLED
INFORMING GAUGE AND WE DO TRY
TO WORK ON DEFINING WHAT THE
SCOPE OF THAT ENGAGEMENT IS
PRIOR TO US GETTING INVOLVED-
AS IT RELATES TO SPECIFICALLY
EDT I DON'T WANT TO HAVE THE
MISCONCEPTION THAT WE'RE NOT
DOING ANYTHING- THE OFFICE THE
DIGITAL INNOVATION CONTINUES TO
BE INVOLVED TO SOME EXTENT
BEHIND THE SCENES IN TERMS OF
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ADVICE AND
GUIDANCE AS IT RELATES TO OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS- SO WE PRETEND
WE CONTINUE TO PROVIDE SOME
LEVEL. OF GUIDANCE ON THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE PUT OUT
THERE AS DOES AS IT IS CDTV
HOWEVER THE ULTIMATE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR OVERSEEING
AND IMPLEMENTING- AND BEING
RESPONSIBLE FOR OVERSEEING
WHETHER OR NOT ET EMPLOYMENT.
RECOMMENDATIONS WILL LABOR AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY AS
THEY ARE AT THE- IT'S TNC
GOVERNMENT THAT IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR OVERSEEING. THAT DEPARTMENT.
SO AGAIN I APPRECIATE THAT- BUT
THERE HUNDRED- YOUR DEPARTMENT
WAS INTIMATELY INVOLVED IN
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE
DMV CONTEXT YOU WERE INVOLVED
IN MAKING SURE THOSE GOT
CARRIED OUT IN THIS CONTEXT. IT
FEELS LIKE A LITTLE BIT OF
COTTON CALDERON- I DON'T MEAN
THAT IN A DATABASE USING
NEGATIVE WAY BUT- WE NEED ALL
HANDS ON DECK TO FIX CD THIS
IS. I DON'T THINK ANYBODY CAN
DESCRIBE IN AN UNCERTAIN TERMS
JUST HOW MUCH OF A CRISIS IS
FOR CALIFORNIA AND- IT'S JUST
MISTER FIND US THAT EDT THAT
THAT THAT GOV UP SEEMS TO BE A
BIT ON THE SIDELINES. MANY OF
US HAVE CALLED FOR MORE WORK-
AND SINCE THAT STREAK TEAM
REPORT THERE HAVE BEEN ALL OF
THESE NEW ISSUES THAT A
MATERIALIZE SINCE SEPTEMBER
THAT THE STRIKE TEAM DID NOT
INVESTIGATE BY ITS OWN
ADMISSION RIGHT- FRIDAY SHE'S.
pSQUARELY IN THE PURVIEW OF THAT
STRIKE TEAM WORK THAT YOU DID
SO AGAIN- I HAVE BEEN IT'S BEEN
UNCLEAR TO US IN THE
LEGISLATURE WHO. GET ON SOLVING
THESE PROBLEMS AT THIS POINT
PARTICULARLY AROUND FRAUD- BUT
ALSO GETTING THE SYSTEM UP AND
RUNNING. ALL WE KNOW IS HALF
RECOMMENDATIONS HAVEN'T BEEN
FULFILLED THE BACKLOG IS
GETTING WORSETHE FRAUD STILL
WE DON'T HAVE A HANDLE ON IT
AND- AND YOU YOU PLAYED A
DECENT ROLE BEFORE AND BE
REALLY GREAT TO GET YOU GUYS
BACK IN THE GAME. I APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS I CAN DEFINITELY
CHECK THOSE BACK I WILL NOTE
THAT SOME OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THEY WERE LIKE
SHORT TERM MEDIUM TERM AND MORE
LONG TERM RECOMMENDATIONS- AND
AGAIN. THE OFFICE OF DIGITAL
INNOVATION COMES UNDER THE
PURVIEW OF OUR AGENCY IS STILL
WORKING ON. TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND GUIDANCE BEHIND
THE SCENES FOR IMPLEMENTATION.
THANKS OKAY THANK YOU AGAIN
I'LL JUST NOTE- WE'VE ASKED
THIS QUESTION REPEATEDLY OF WHY
IS THERE NOT BEEN A SECOND
ENGAGEMENT OF THE STRIKE TEAM
HAVEN'T GOTTEN ANY ANSWERS. THE
CRISES CONTINUE SO- WE CONTINUE
TO WAIT. MANAGER BACK TO YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER CHU
I ALSO HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS- MISTER HOWARD CAN
YOU ARTICULATE WHAT
EXPECTATIONS WE SHOULD HAVE FOR
THE AGENCY AND THE SECRETARY
AND THIS NEW VACCINATION
ROLLOUT EFFORT. YEAH THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION AND CHAIR I'M
SO OUT AS I PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED- THE TGA IS STILL
UNDER AND- ALLOW IT'S VERY
CLOSE TO BEING FINISHED- WHAT
YOU'LL ULTIMATELY SEE WHEN IT
DOES GET RELEASED AS- WHAT ARE
THE STATE RESPONSIBILITIES WITH
AN- AD THAT TVA AND THOSE WILL
BE SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WILL
BE RESPONSIBLE FOR COORDINATING
THIS PART OF OUR- EFFORT FOR
MINISTRY. B. T. PA ONCE IT IS
FINALIZED SO THERE THERE IS A
JOINT HEARING TOMORROW MISSING
LINK BETWEEN TWO DIFFERENT-
COMMITTEES AND ARE GOING TO BE
A LOT. MORE DETAILS THAT'LL BE
COMING OUT TOMORROW AND THE DAY
AFTER RELATED TO THE TGA AND
RESPONSIBILITIES- AND WE CAN BE
HAPPY TO CIRCLE BACK AND GET
MORE DETAILS ON THE
EXPECTATIONS OF THE BOXES ROLE
IN ENSURING. THAT THE TPS. WHEN
CAN WE EXPECT THE FOLLOW UP.
CAN YOU GIVE ME A DATE. YEAH SO
ONCE THE TVA HAS BEEN EXECUTED-
WILL HAVE A BETTER SENSE OF THE
RESPONSIBILITIES OF OUR
AGENCIES SO MY GUESS IS LATE
NEXT WEEK WHICH BE ABLE TO GET
BACK TO ALL NOTE THAT WE DO
HAVE A REGULAR. WEEKLY CHECK
AND MEETING WITH THAT BOTH.
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY AND
SENATE RELATED TO THE VACCINE
EFFORTS AND- RIGHT UPDATES
THROUGH THAT PROCESS. WHAT'S
THE ADDITIONAL HEARING THAT WE
CAN ABOUT TOMORROW. YES THANK
YOU SO THERE IS A JOINT HEARING
TOMORROW AND BETWEEN I BELIEVE
THE EMERGENCY AT. WE JUST GET
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIGHT IT'S AN
ASSEMBLY WOMAN CUTTING
PETRIE-NORRIS THAT ARE DOING
THE JOINT HEARING CORRECT. THAT
SOUNDS CORRECT YES SO THOSE TWO
COMMITTEES- IS THAT IS THE
JOINT HEAD CARRYING AND ALL
INCLUDE BOTH A WEE STD PH AS
WELL AS OUR AGENCY SECRETARY
WILL BE TESTIFYING AT HEARINGS.
OKAY GREAT THANK YOU.
ADDITIONALLY WE ARE. HEARING
QUESTIONS AND CONCERNS ABOUT
THE VACCINE EFFORT FROM VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDERS OBVIOUSLY FROM
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE-
WITH LACK OF. ACTUALLY
ACCOUNTABILITY IN TERMS OF WHO
DO WE GO TO- IS IT GO OFF AS A
PUBLIC HEALTH IS SAID- THE H.
H. S. AGENCY. CAN YOU YOU KIND
OF HAVE A MILITARY PEOPLE
QUESTION- WHO SHOULD THE
LEGISLATURE BE SPEAKING TO WHEN
IT COMES TO QUESTIONS CONCERNS
FROM AROUND THE VACCINE.
EFFORTS IS THAT GOV OPS IS THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
LIKE WHO DO WE GO TO WHO HAS
THE ANSWERS- ALTERNATELY WEAK
GOVERNMENTS WILL BE
IMPLEMENTING AND ADMINISTERING
THE TICE SO I BELIEVE THAT
COMES OUT AND THE ANSWER TO
THAT QUESTION. WILL BE CLEAR.
OKAY I KNOW THAT AS HUMAN
BEINGS WE ALL CAN RELATE TO HOW
WE'RE TRYING TO GET THROUGH
THIS PANDEMIC IN TRYING TO HELP.
YOU KNOW THOSE WE LOVE IN OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA GET THE VACCINE.
HOWEVER THE DIFFERENT CHANGES
AROUND THE VACCINATION EFFORTS
HAVE CREATED A LOT OF CHAOS ON
THE GROUND IT'S CREATED A LOT
OF. A LOT OF CONCERN REGARDING
ESSENTIAL AND FRONTLINE WORKERS
WHO ARE NOT RECEIVING THE
VACCINE THERE'S A LOT OF FOLKS
AND I KNOW AND MY DISTRICT AND
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES THAT-
ESSENTIAL WORKERS SIMPLY ARE
NOT GETTING THE VACCINATION
THERE ARE PEOPLE COMING IN FROM
OTHER COMMUNITIES TO TRY TO
GET. ACCESS TO THOSE VACCINES
PEOPLE THAT HAVE ACCESS TO THE
INTERNET PEOPLE THAT CAN MAKE
APPOINTMENTS ONLINE WHILE AT
THE SAME TIME THOSE THAT
ACTUALLY NEEDED OUR FRONT LINE
AN ESSENTIAL WORKERS AREN'T
BEING PRIORITIZE AFTER. THE AGE
LIMITATION OR AGE REQUIREMENT
BECAME SIXTY FIVE AND OVER SO
I'M- SO GIVEN THAT. WHAT IS THE
RESPONSE FROM GOV OPS IN TERMS
OF HOW DO WE MAXIMIZE. VACCINE
DISTRIBUTION EQUITY LANGUAGE
BARRIERS TECHNOLOGY BARRIERS.
ACCESS TO RESOURCES A LOT OF
THESE MEGA FIGHTS LIKE THE ONEIN MY DISTRICT AT DODGER
STADIUM. THERE'S NO WALKABLE
WAY TO GET THERE YOU HAVE TO
HAVE A CAR. HOW DO HOW DO WE
THINK ABOUT- HOW DOES GOV OPS
THINK ABOUT THOSE INDIVIDUALS
THAT DON'T HAVE A CAR AND RELY
ON PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION. YEAH
AND I FULLY APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION WHERE YOU'RE COMING
FROM AND I FULLY UNDERSTAND
YOUR CONCERNS. I'M GONNA HAVE
TO GET FOUR OR IN ANSWERING
THAT TO THE PANEL TOMORROW WE
WILL HAVE MORE EXPERTISE TO BE
ABLE TO ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS.
OKAY PLEASE LET THEM KNOW THAT
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE IS THINKING ABOUT
IN TERMS OF YOUR DEPARTMENT AS
WELL AS- I WOULD IMAGINE EVERY
MEMBER OF THIS LEGISLATURE IN
TERMS OF HOW WE'RE GETTING THE
VACCINES TO. MOST IN NEED A
CONVERSATION THAT KEEPS COMING
UP IS FARMWORKERS. FARMWORKERS
ON THE FRONT LINE THEY ARE NOT
ABLE TO TAKE A DAY OFF AND
ALLOW FOR THE REST OF THE
PUBLIC TO BE ABLE TO. STAY AT
HOME AND QUARANTINE AND- BE
SAFE WHILE AT THE SAME TIME
HAVE NOT BEEN PRIORITIZE TO
RECEIVE THE VACCINE. FIVE I
WANT FULLY FULLY UNDERSTOOD. I
WANNA MAKE IT MAKE IT A POINT
TO DEATH ALSO LET YOU KNOW IN
TERMS PLEASE SPEAK TO YOUR
COLLEAGUE THAT THIS IS THIS IS
SOMETHING OF URGENCY. THAT WE
WOULD LIKE SOME ANSWERS ON.
YEAH AND THEN REST ASSURE WE'RE
WORKING AROUND THE CLOCK AS
EVERYONE ELSE. ON THIS ISSUE
RIGHT NOW AND OUR AGENCY HAS.
MOST OF OUR AGENCIES DEDICATED
TOWARDS US AS WELL AS PEOPLE
HELLO YES AND CDPH ALL HANDS
ON. DECK EFFORT WITHIN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND TOMORROW.
MORE INFORMATIONAL BE COMING
OUT. OKAY THANK YOU. DOES THE
VOTES HAVE PLANS TO RE ENGAGE
IN- EDT AT THE EXECUTIVE LEVEL
GIVEN THE WORSENING
PERFORMANCE- WORSENING
PERFORMANCE OF THE DEPARTMENT.
AT THIS TIME WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
IMMEDIATE PLANS TO RE ENGAGE
OUR TIME AND EFFORT IS
DEDICATED. CURRENTLY TOWARD
SOME OF THE FACTS AND STUFF
WITH MINISTRATION AS WELL AS
OTHER UNDERTAKINGS THAT WE'VE
BEEN FANTASTICALLY. OKAY JUST
WANNA PUT ON THE RADAR THAN ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN
DISCOVERED WITH VARIOUS-
HEARINGS BOTH IN THIS ONE THIS
COMMITTEE AS WELL AS THE JOINT
HEARING BETWEEN. A J. LACK AND
INSURANCE WAS THE- THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE- THERE'S BEEN FOUR
DIFFERENT DIRECT DEPUTY
DIRECTORS IN THE LAST FIVE
YEARS THE LAST PERSON WAS THERE
FOR THREE MONTHS AND LEFT ABOUT
TWO WEEKS AGO THERE- THE
UNDERSECRETARY OF LABOR HAS
BEEN. VACANT FOR ABOUT A YEAR
NOW OUR SECRETARY OF LABOR WILL
BE LEAVING TO THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION THERE'S A NEW.
DIRECTOR AT EDT. SO WHAT I'M
TRYING TO SAY IS. THERE SEEMS
TO BE A LACK OF CONSISTENTLY-
SHIP AT THE DEPARTMENT WHICH
HAS BROUGHT US TO THE POINT
WHERE WE ARE TODAY. SO I DON'T
I'M NOT QUITE SURE I UNDERSTAND
WHY YOU WOULD NOT RE ENGAGE
WITH EDT GIVEN THE
CIRCUMSTANCES. WELL IN THE IN
SCOPE RESPONSIBILITY AT
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY IS
WE STILL WE STILL HAVE OUR
AGENCY FROM WHICH WE HAVE TO
RUN AND OPERATE AND MANAGE THE
DEPARTMENTS THAT REPORT TO US.
I KNOW THAT THERE'S A THERE'S A
HIERARCHY IN THE STRUCTURE IN
STATE GOVERNMENT AND THE
ADMINISTRATION- WHERE-
RESPONSIBILITY LIES IN TERMS OF
DEPARTMENTS REPORTING AGENCIES
AGENCIES ACCORDING TO THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE- TO THE
EXTENT WE GET ASKED AND FUTURE.
AND I BELIEVE THAT'LL HAVE TO
BE A DISCUSSION WITH THE AGENCY
SECRETARY- IF. THERE NEEDS TO
BE EIGHT ANOTHER ENGAGEMENT
WITH EDT AS OF RIGHT NOW I'M
NOT AWARE OF THAT CONVERSATION.
HAVING HAD TAKEN PLACE. OKAY
ONE MORE QUESTION FOR YOU
MISTER HOWARD HOW RELATED TO
EDT AS WELL AS VACCINES DOES
GIVE UP TO HAVE THE TOOLS AND
RESOURCES IT NEEDS TO MEET THE
EXPECTATIONS OF THESE TWO
CRITICAL EFFORTS FOR THE STATE.
YEAH THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION IS A VERY GOOD
QUESTION. AND WE ARE ASSESSING
AND RESOURCE NEEDS RIGHT NOW
ESPECIALLY AS IT RELATES TO-
THE VACCINE. EFFORTS AND TO THE
EXTENT THAT WE NEED RESOURCES
TO FULFILL WHATEVER OUR
ULTIMATE ROLE. IN THE VACCINE
WORK WE WILL. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND- COMMITTEE THAT
STAFF AND GETTING THOSE
RESOURCES ALLOCATED TO US THAT
WE CAN BE SUCCESSFUL OKAY. AND
WE WANT YOU TO BE SUCCESSFUL
JUST GOT A LITTLE SNOW WHAT YOU
NEED. YEAH THANK YOU FOR THE
SUPPORT AND CONSIDERATION WE
DEFINITELY APPRECIATE. THANK
YOU MISTER HOWARD- IF THERE ARE
NO MORE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE I BELIEVE I
AM NOW COMMITTEE OF ONE AS WE
REACH OUR LAST ISSUE THANK YOU
MISTER HOWARD- MOVING ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER SEVENTEEN OUR LAST
ONE FOR TODAY. GOVERNMENT
GOVERNMENTAL OPERATIONS BUDGET
PROPOSALS OUR PANELISTS TODAY
WILL INCLUDE A LOTTA TRAIL TO
THE GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS
AGENCY. JANE I ENJOYED BONTA
GIRL JUSTIN HOWARD YOU'RE
STAYING ON. A AS WELL AS CHAZ
ALAMO WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE EVELYN SUITS
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AS WELL AS RYAN WEINBERG WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LET'S
BEGIN. PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT
WELL- THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY I'M GONNA TEAR UP
THE TWO PROPOSALS HERE- IN IN
IN THE S. TIME I'LL TRY TO BE
BRIEF FINAL THINGS ARE RUNNING
OLD RATHER LONG BUT WE DO HAVE
TO BUDGET PROPOSALS FOR YOU
TODAY THE FIRST ONE IS RELATED
TO THE STATEWIDE DATA
STRATEGIES ARE AGENCY IS
REQUESTING THREE POSITIONS AND
FIVE HUNDRED FIFTEEN THOUSAND
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. I'M TO
FACILITATE AND SUPPORT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF A STATEWIDE
DATA STRATEGY CONDUCT
EVALUATIONS- FOR GOV OP CENTER
OF GOVERNMENT EXCELLENCE AND
COMMITTEE ON COMMUNITY IN THE
STATEWIDE DATA STRATEGY WILL
HELP LAY THE GROUNDWORK FOR
STATE DEPARTMENTS TO DELIVER
BETTER OUTCOMES TO THE
RESIDENTS THEY SERVE BY
BREAKING DOWN DATA BARRIERS.
ANNOUNCEMENTS AND GOVERNMENT
PRACTICES INCREASE DEPARTMENTS
ABILITY TO USE DATA ANALYTICS
ALL OF WHICH SHOULD LEAD TO
BETTER DECISION MAKING AND
RESOURCE ALLOCATIONS BY SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND POLICY MAKERS IN
THE FUTURE WITH ME TODAY ON
THIS PROPOSAL IS JOY RUNNING
AROUND THE STATE THIS IS THE
STATE'S CHIEF DATA OFFICER AND
SHE CAN HELP ANSWERANY
PROGRAMMATIC QUESTIONS RELATED
TO THE STATEWIDE DATA STRATEGY.
THE PROPOSAL FRONT OF YOU- IS A
WORKLOAD PROPOSAL AND
SPECIFICALLY WE ARE ASKING FOR
FOUR POSITIONS AND ONE MILLION
ELEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE EIGHT HUNDRED
THIRTY SIX THOUSAND ONGOING AND
AN ASSOCIATE TRAILER BILL ALONG
WITH. LANGUAGE TO FIND AND
MANAGE. NEW AND EXISTING
WORKLOAD RELATED TO STATE
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS WHILE
ALSO ADDRESSING SOCIAL ECONOMIC
AND RACIAL DISPARITIES WITHIN
THESE OPERATIONS. I APPROVING
THIS REQUEST WILL OUT OF THE
BOX TO APPROPRIATELY PROVIDE
STATEWIDE POLICY DEVELOPMENT
AND CRITICAL INDEPENDENT
OVERSIGHT OF THE ENTITIES THAT
REPORT TO BELMONT AND ESTABLISH
A STATE WIDE EQUITY INCLUSION
FRAMEWORK FOR HIRING
PROCUREMENT AT THE STATE
DEPARTMENT MUST FOLLOW WITH ME
TODAY AS I WANNA TRY TO CHOOSE
A SPECIAL CONSULTANT FOR THE
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCIES
SPECIALIZING AND RACIAL EQUITY
AND INCLUSION EFFORTS. AND
SHE'S AVAILABLE TO IT'S VERY
PROBLEMATIC QUESTIONS RELATED
TO OUR EQUITY COLLUSION EFFORTS
WITHIN OUR AGENCY SO WITH THAT
WE. ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU LET'S GO WITH THE- LET'S
ANALYST'S PLEASE. FOLLOWED BY
THE DEPARTMENT FIND. THANK YOU
CHAD ALAMO WITH THE L. A. L.
OUR OFFICE IS CURRENTLY
REVIEWING BOTH THE PURPLE AND
THAT NO ISSUES AT THIS TIME BUT
WILL REACH OUT TO COMMITTEE
STAFF IF ANYTHING ARISES. THANK
YOU MR ALAMO DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
RIGHT WE HAVE SOME GOOD AS WELL.
OKAY THANK YOU I ACTUALLY DO
HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS I
BELIEVE THE CICERO FROM MISTER
HOWARD OR FOR- MISS TROUT HOW
CAN WE ENSURE THAT HIRING A
CHIEF EXECUTIVE CHIEF EQUITY
OFFICER LEADS TO MAKE
MEANINGFUL IMPROVEMENTS IN
INCREASING ACCESS AND
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE BEEN LEFT BEHIND. I CAN
TAKE THAT TESTING- GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM LIR-
ADDRESS YOUR QUESTION. I AM A
SPECIAL CONSULTANTS BEEN
BROUGHT IN OVER SIX MONTHS AGO
TO LOOK AT THIS ISSUE. AND I
WILL SAY THAT. THIS **** IS SO
CRITICAL FOR THE TIME THAT.
SOMEONE NEEDS EQUITY RACIAL
EQUITY AND INCLUSION ISSUES ARE
IT IT NEEDS OWNERSHIP AND THAT
WAS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
NOTICED WAS PROMISING FROM THE
STRUCTURE THE CURRENT STRUCTURE
THAT'S IN PLACE WHERE MULTIPLE
COLLABORATIONS AND WORKS GOING
ON TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE BUT
IT'S IN FIVE MODE IN DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS AND- WE THOUGHT
THAT THE ESTABLISHMENT OF A
CHIEF BUT THE POSITION OF THE
CHIEF EQUITY OFFICER. ALLOW
SOMEONE TO TAKE OWNERSHIP AND
THEN AS YOU HEARD IN THE
PREVIOUS- TESTIMONY WHERE THE
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY
HAS A VERY CONSULTANT TYPE ROLE
SO HAVING AN EXPERT IN THIS
FIELD JUST ADDS TO THAT KIND OF
THAT WHOLE HOLISTIC TYPE OF
CONSULTING THAT THE AGENCY CAN
OFFER AND HELP IT RAMP UP AND-
PUTTING TOGETHER ALL THE
RESOURCES THAT. ARE IN
DIFFERENT AGENCIES SO WE COULD
HELP DEFINE WHAT THIS FRAMEWORK
LOOKS LIKE. THANK YOU FOR THAT
MYSTERY I THINK THIS IS PERHAPS
THE FIRST TIME THAT I HEAR
SOMEONE SPEAK ABOUT RACIAL
EQUITY ANDINCLUSION- IN A IN A
BUDGET HEARING I BELIEVE I'VE
I'VE BROUGHT IT UP A COUPLE OF
TIMES AND I APPRECIATE IT. IT
JUST SEEMS TO ME. I TAKE THAT
THOSE POSITIONS VERY SERIOUSLY.
AND IT SEEMS ONE INDIVIDUAL
CHARGED. WITH OVERSEEING AN
ENTIRE GOVERNMENTAL STRUCTURE-
IS REALLY. IT CAN LOOK LIKE
IT'S JUST A FIGURE PERSON AND
NOT SOMEONE THAT'S ACTUALLY
GOING TO BE DEDICATED TO DIVING
INTO THE INEQUITIES ACROSS THE
VARIOUS DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS
AND AGENCIES ACROSS THE STATE-
HOW HOW WILL THAT ACTUALLY
IMPROVE OUR EQUITY ISSUES. I
WILL SAY AND I HATE TO BE
CLICHE ABOUT THAT IS THE
JOURNEY OF A THOUSAND MILES
BEGINS WITH ONE SINGLE STAFF-
ONE OF THE THINGS CRITICAL
THINGS I. ARE MY OBSERVATION
HAVING COME IN THERE TO LOOK AT
THE STRUCTURE WAS THOUGH. WE
DIDN'T SEEM TO BE SOMEONE WHO
OWNED IT AN INDIVIDUAL WHO WAS
RESPONSIBLE FOR. EXECUTING
MANAGING CONDUCTING MASSAGING
BAY KIDDING. WHAT THIS
FRAMEWORK LOOKS LIKE AND SO I
KNOW IT'S ONE BUT THAT WE ARE
IN TALKS WITH- THE
ADMINISTRATION TO LOOK AT
REALLY AND TRULY HOW DO WE
ADDRESS THIS IN A HOLISTIC WAY.
AND I MAY NOT BE HERE BECAUSE
THEY SET UP A SPECIAL
CONSULTANT BUT HOW DO WE
CONTINUE TO WORK AND MAKE SURE
THAT IT IT IT IT HAS
CONTINUITY. IT STAYS IT
OUTLASTS BECAUSE THIS IS NOT
THE FIRST TIME THAT THIS HAS
BEEN ADDRESSED BY AN
ADMINISTRATION. SO WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WHATEVER WE PUT
INTO PLACE STAYS AND- OUTLASTS
WHOEVER IS RUNNING THE
ADMINISTRATION SO THAT'S THE
PURPOSE OF A YOU KNOW LIKE I
SAID ONE.YOU KNOW TAKES ONE
PERSON. SOMETIMES FOUGHT BALL
GO. IF I COULD ADD TO THAT-
JUST SAVE THAT ONE THING HAS I
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED IN THE
OTHER ITEMS OR THAT LEVERAGING-
RESOURCES ACROSS THE STATE SO
MANY DEPARTMENTS HAVE VARIOUS-
THINGS GOING ON IN THIS AREA
AND WE PLAN TO LEVERAGE
RESOURCES WHETHER IT BE AT
EXPERTISE OR EXISTING PROGRAMS
WHERE POSSIBLE. BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY IS AGAIN BECAUSE WE
OVERSEE ASK THREE OF THE MAJOR
CONTROL AGENCIES THIS PERSON
WILL BE ABLE TO HAVE A BIG
IMPACT IN THAT SCENE WHERE THE
GAPS ARE AS IT RELATES TO
RACIAL EQUITY INCLUSION WITHIN
THE STATES AND TO THE EXTENT
THAT WE IDENTIFY NEED. FOR
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES IN THE
FUTURE WILL OBVIOUSLY GO
THROUGH THE APPROPRIATE PROCESS
AND WHAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IF THAT DOES COME TO
FRUITION THERE'S A LITTLE BIT
OF A PARALLEL TO THE STATE WIDE
DATA STRATEGY AND SO FAR AS- WE
FIRST BROUGHT ON THE STATE'S
CHIEF DATA OFFICER ABOUT THAT
INDIVIDUAL CHOI WHO'S ON THE
LINE SPENT HER FIRST YEAR KIND
OF DOING A REVIEW OF THE ENTIRE
LANDSCAPE OF DATA. WITHIN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
IDENTIFYING YOU KNOW WHAT WAS
MISSING WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE
IN ORDER TO MAKE THAT A MORE
CENTRAL PARK. GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS AND SO THIS PERSON
WILL LIKELY HAD A SIMILAR ROLE
AND MATT AND MESHEL. MICHELLE
WORK NEEDS TO BE DONE. THANK
YOU FOR THE MISTER I A- IT THE
TO. OF THE PROCESS SEEMS TO
FOLK ON. AND HIRING BY THE
STATUS ANY INTO TO ALL LOOK AT
HOW STATE ITSELF COMMUNICATES
WITH DIVERSE COMMUNITIES. YES
THERE THERE WE THE JOB
DESCRIPTION OF THIS POSITION IS
OUR WORKING PROCESS THAT WE
WERE COLLABORATING WITH MULTI
AGENCIES OF COURSE CALAIS TIMER
AND- COMMUNICATE INFORMATION
ACCESS AND TRUST. THOSE ARE THE
THREE LANES OF WHICH WERE
LOOKING AS WE- WE ROLLED OUT
WHAT IS OF WHAT IS IMPORTANT.
FOR THIS POSITION WITHIN THE
STATE. SO A WORK IN PROGRESS
POSITION FOR A CHIEF EQUITY OF
EQUITY OFFICER- UNFORTUNATELY
TO ME DOESN'T SOUND LIKE IT'S A
FULLY VETTED POSSESSION WITH
INTENT TO ACTUALLY DO THE WORK
NECESSARY AROUND EQUITY-
MISTRUST YOU BEEN BROUGHT IN
FOR THE LAST SIX MONTHS. I
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT YOU'RE
DOING WITH THE STATE AND
SHEDDING SOME LIGHT ON THIS
HIGHLY IMPORTANT ISSUE- CLEARLY
THE PANDEMIC HAS SHOWN US THAT
THERE IS- A CLEAR LACK OF
EQUITY IN TERMS OF- RESOURCES
AND OPPORTUNITIES AS WELL AS
OUR A CUP OUR RECOVERY EFFOTS
AROUND COVE IT I WANT TO BRING
UP. THE INFORMATION THAT MISTER
HOWARD SURE IN TERMS OF DATA IN
A PREVIOUS HEARING THAT WE
HELD- THE CONVERSATIONS AROUND
DATA AND EQUITY ARE MARRIED SO
WHEN I ASK CAN YOU PROVIDE US
INFORMATION OF HOW MANY WHAT'S
THE PERCENTAGE OF SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT HAVE RECEIVED-
OUR SMALL BUSINESS GRANTS THAT
ARE BOTH WOMEN AND MINORITY.
THE DATA WAS NOT AVAILABLE. AND
SO THAT IS AN EQUITY ISSUE HOW
ABOUT LANGUAGE CULTURAL
BARRIERS- AND SO I'M I'M
CURIOUS AS TO HOW ONE
INDIVIDUAL ONE PERSON. IS GOING
TO BE CHARGED WITH ENSURING
THAT DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES
AND PROCEDURES. OF FOLLOWING
ISSUE OF EQUITY. OR DO THEIR
WORK THROUGH THE LENS OF EQUITY.
HELLO AND THIS IS JUST THE END
OF JULY I DON'T I THINK YOU'RE
YOU'RE ON BUT- I'LL TAKE A STAB
MAYBE FILL IN SOME GAPS. IN
DATA IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
AND ESPECIALLY WHEN IT RELATES
TO. EQUITY ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE NEED TO DO A BETTER JOB
AT THE STATE IS ENSURING THAT
THE DATA THAT WE'RE COLLECTING
IS THE APPROPRIATE DATA SO THAT
WE CAN PROPERLY EVALUATE HOW
PROGRAMS ARE WORKING WHETHER
EQUITIES PEOPLE FELT SO. IN
RELATION TO- THE POSITION OR
BEING ASKED FOR THEY WILL
DEFINITELY BE WORKING CLOSELY
GIVEN THAT THE WILL BE HOUSED
IN THE SAME AGENCY WITH- THE
STATE'S CHIEF DATA OFFICER AS
WELL AS THE POSITIONS THAT WE
ARE SEEKING EMPLOYMENT THE
STATEWIDE DATA STRATEGY SO THAT
DEPARTMENTS ARE ACTUALLY.
COLLECTING THE CORRECT TYPE OF
DATA IN MINUTES AND WE CAN
THAT'S CAN BE USEFUL FOR ALL
DEPARTMENTS AND THE LEGISLATURE
ADMINISTRATION SO THAT WHEN
THEY'RE TRYING TO MAKE
DECISIONS ABOUT THE-
EFFECTIVENESS OF PROGRAMS. THEY
CAN CLEARLY SEE THAT. JOY IS
THERE ANYTHING YOU'D LIKE TO
ASK. DATA IMPORTER EQUITY. NOW
I'LL I'LL JUST TELL THAT- I- BY.
IN JUST BEIN THE SAME AGENCY
WITH THE CHIEF EQUITY OFFICER
WE'VE I FULLY EXPECT WORK
CLOSELY AND I'M ALREADY WORKING
VERY CLOSELY WITH A LINE OUT
AROUND- SEVERAL ISSUES AROUND
EQUITY AS FAR AS WELL AS THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE ON
CALIFORNIA. LEADS TASK FORCES
AROUND EQUITY ISSUES AND DATA
COMPONENTS THERE. THANK YOU AND
I TRULY DO APPRECIATE THE
EFFORTS I THINK- THE
FRUSTRATION THAT I FEEL AS WELL
AS I KNOW IN CONVERSATIONS THAT
HAVE THAT I HAVE HAD WITH MY
COLLEAGUES. ARE JUST RELATING
ON ON. THERE'S THE EXPEDIENCY
AND HOW THINGS ARE MOVING VERY
QUICKLY GIVEN. CODE RECOVERY
EFFORTS. OF BOTH FOR VACCINES
TESTING- REOPENING SAFELY OUR
ECONOMY AND ENSURING THAT
ESSENTIAL IN FROM MY WORKERS
ARE PRIORITIZED ESPECIALLY. OUR
MOST VULNERABLE- IN TERMS OF
ACCESS TO THE INTERNET TO EVEN
MAKE AN APPOINTMENT ONLINE OR
ANY LANGUAGE BARRIERS AND SO I
FEEL LIKE WE ARE BEHIND IN MANY
WAYS ON THE CONVERSATION ON
EQUITY AND DECISIONS THAT ARE
BEING MADE THAT AT THE END OF
THE DAY CAN EITHER- HELP OR
HARM. OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY AND SO I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU'RE AWARE IN TERMS
OF THE CONVERSATIONS THAT ARE
TAKING PLACE AND THE NECESSITY
OF INCLUSION. EQUITY RACIAL
RACIAL EQUITY INCLUSION AND
CONVERSATIONS THAT ARE
NECESSARY AND I THINK WHEN
WE'RE LOOKING AT HOW DO WE FIND
A POSITION THAT THE POSITION IS
NOT JUST SOLELY A POSITION TO
SAY THAT WE HAVE ONE. BUT THAT
IT IS IT IS ACTUALLY A PERSON
WITH INFLUENCE POWER AND
ABILITY TO MOVE THINGS IN THE
WAY THE DIRECTION THAT THE
STATE NEEDS SOME TO BE MOVED ON.
YES THANK YOU FIVE FOR THAT
FEEDBACK AND- I THINK WE ARE
IN. COMPLETE AGREEMENT ON THAT
AND- WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CONVERSATION FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS ON THE SUBJECT.
TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN. FURTHER
MOVE THIS CALL FORWARDED MAKING
SURE THAT WE ARE BEING ECHOED
ALL ACROSS EVERYTHING THAT WE
DEAL WITH IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU FOR THAT
I DON'T HAVE ANY FURTHER
COMMENTS BUT WE CAN DEFINITELY.
I KNOW THAT I'M INTERESTED IN
HAVING A CONTINUED CONVERSATION
ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR- BUDGET
PROPOSAL. THANK YOU SO MUCH- WE
ARE NOW GOING TO WORK ON TO-
THAT WAS OUR LAST ISSUE- WE'RE
NOW MOVING ON TO PUBLIC
COMMENT. IF THERE IS ANY MEMBER
IN THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM THAT
WISHES TO SPEAK. THEY MAY RAISE
THEIR HAND AND I WILL- YOU CAN
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. I
WOULD ALSO ASK THAT THE PUBLIC
RESPECT THAT THE GOAL
DISTANCING AND NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE HE WILL HAVE ONE
MINUTE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT FOR
THOSE OF YOU. ON THE PHONE THE
NUMBER IS 877-692-8957 WITH THE
ACCESS CODE. FOUR THREE SEVEN
ONE THREE ONE FIVE. OPERATOR
YOU MAY BEGIN. OKAY IF YOU'D
LIKE TO BECOME ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO ONE AND ZERO
ON YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE. AND
THEN THE FIRST COMMENT. COME
LINE FORTY EIGHT LINE FORTY
EIGHT LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING PERRIN
COMMITTEE MEMBER CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES I CAN HEAR YOU PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OUR GREAT MY NAME'S
JACKIE GRAY WHILE LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR WITH THE F. B. W.
WESTERN STATE COUNCIL SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE NUMBER ONE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS
CONTROL. UPW REPRESENTS SEVERAL
THOUSAND OF SEVERAL THOUSANDS
OF WORKERS IN THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY FROM SEED TO SALE AND
HAS BEEN THE PREMIER UNION.
SINCE I SUPPORT OF PROPOSITION
SIXTY FOUR THE ONLY UNION CITY
SOUTH. UPW STRONGLY BELIEVES
THAT THE CONSOLIDATION OF THE
LICENSING AGENCIES AND THE ONE
DEPARTMENT WILL ASSISTANCE WITH
THEIR LICENSING PROCESS THESE.
LICENSE TRANSPARENCY AND
ENFORCEMENT AGAINST THE ILLICIT
AND LEGAL MARKET. WE ARE THAT
THE NEW DEPARTMENT PRIORITIZE
ENFORCEMENT SO WE CAN RAISE THE
STANDARD OF LIVING FOR WORKERS
IN THE CANNABIS INDUSTRY. AND
MAKE SURE CANNABIS STOPS ARE
GOOD MIDDLE CLASS JOBS WITH
BENEFITS AND HEALTHY AND SAFE
WORKING ENVIRONMENT. AND IT'S
CRITICAL THAT THE STATE AND
LOCAL ENTITIES ISSUE LICENSES
TO GET HIGH ROAD OPERATORS.
THAT POSITIVELY BENEFIT THE
COMMUNITIES READY CANADA THREE
TELL OPERATORS ARE LOCATED. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF CANADA CONTROL. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY. THANK YOU
FOR THAT NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANKS WE'VE GOT A LINE NUMBER
FORTY SEVEN FORTY SEVEN MIL AND
IS OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR. CAROLINA CORREA. YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOU HAVE ONE
MINUTE. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON CHERYL MCCURRY AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- MY
NAME IS BY SAYING WHEN THAT I
LIVE IN SAN DIEGO CALIFORNIA
AND I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THEIR INSURANCE REQUEST THAT
THIS COMMITTEE APPROPRIATE-
THREE POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS. IN ASK FOR ONGOING
FUNDING TO ENSURE THAT THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE AFTER
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY. TO PAY
THEIR INTERNS A LIVING WAGE.
THERE ARE A FEW HAVE. ANY OTHER
QUSTIONS ON THIS MATTER I
WOULD REFER YOU TO THE POINT
THEY BRING SAN DIEGO BASED ON
THE IDEA OF MY TIME THANK YOU
CHAIR. THANK YOU FOR THAT NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. MY NUMBER
FIFTEEN OF YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE THANK YOU
JULIE BAKER EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
CALIFORNIA ARTS ADVOCATES
REPRESENTING OUR CULTURE
CREATIVITY IN PARTS WORKERS IN
INDUSTRIES IN CALIFORNIA
CALLING TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE
FIFTEEN MILLION FIVE MILLION
EARLY ACTION AND TEN MILLION
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO IN THE
CALIFORNIA CREATED CORPS PILOT
PROGRAM WE SEE THIS AS A WIN
WIN FOR THE STATE EMPLOYEES
ARTIST'S WORK BASING ON A PLANE
NUMBER 65% OF THE WORKFORCE.
WELL BENEFITING PUBLIC HEALTH
MESSAGES IN A HIGHLY LOCALIZED
CULTURALLY SPECIFIC ON THE
GROUND PROGRAM SH BIRDS ARE
AFFECTED COMMUNICATORS JUST
THINK OF AMANDA GORMAN AT THE
INAUGURATION AND WE KNOW THE
POWER OF ARTS TO BUILD TRUST
CREATE EMPATHY AND CHANGE
BEHAVIOR ALTHOUGH WE APPRECIATE
THE LEGISLATURE NEED MORE
INFORMATION ON HOW THE GRANT
FUNDS WILL BE EQUITABLY
DISTRIBUTED ACROSS CALIFORNIA
DROUGHT MOST IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES. THAT HAVE A
NATURAL WORKS OR NOT TO PUT
UNDER BURKE OVER UNDUE BURDEN
ON THE VERY PEOPLE WE ARE
TRYING TO SUPPORT WE ARE
CONFIDENT THAT THE CALIFORNIA
ARTS COUNCIL HAS THE TOOLS
MECHANISM AND DECADES OF
EXPERIENCE IN GRANT MAKING IN
AND EQUITABLE THE BILL HAS A
VERY SMALL INVESTMENT OF
MEMBRANOUS AREA MENTIONED THAT
COULD HELP OUR MOST IMPACTED
INDUSTRIES. IN CULTURE SECTOR
GETS BACK TO WORK AND SERVICE
FIRST TO PUBLIC HEALTH THANK
YOU WE ARE CURRENTLY SHUT DOWN
AND SHUT OUT OF OUR NORMAL WORK
WE APPRECIATE YOUR LISTENING
THANK YOU THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THE FEEDBACK. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. IN NEXT TO LINE
NO SIXTY ALAINA OPEN. K. IT
LOOKS LIKE SIXTY DROPPED NOW WE
BUILD- AND FIFTY ONE. THE
GREETING JUNIOR KAPLAN WITH THE
PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE AND I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF ACTION
SEVENTEEN FOR GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS AGENCY. WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING CLOSELY WITH A WIDE
RANGE OF STATE DEPARTMENTS AND
AGENCIES. UNDER RACIAL EQUITY
HER PRACTICES. AND OPERATIONS
AND- THERE'S LOTS OF WELL IN
WE'RE CONTINUALLY ISSUES COME
UP THAT REALLY ARE SYSTEMIC
WE'RE VERY HOPEFUL THAT THIS
POSITION ALTHOUGH IT'S ONLY ONE
POSITION IS THE BEGINNING. OF
OUR OPPORTUNITY TO TACKLE
COMMITMENTS IN A SYSTEMATIC WAY
AND WE WOULD OF COURSE WELCOME
AND SUPPORT ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
ONE NUMBER FIFTEEN OR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN FIVE FOUR. GOOD EVENING
TERRIBLE MCCARTY ON MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE- MY NAME IS BRING
HIM IN AND I CAN GRADUATE TO
MAKE HUNTING NORTHRIDGE-
ASSEMBLY UNPAID INTERNSHIP THAT
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTATIVE. AND
I'M CALLINGON BEHALF OF THEIR
INTENT TO ASK THAT YOU GRANT
THEY'RE TO THE POINT TWO FOR A
MILLION DOLLAR ON AN ONGOING
FUNDING TO ENSURE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE OFFICES
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO PAY
THEIR INTERNS A LIVING WAGE.
RECENT REPORTS OF THE ONLY 10%
OF CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY OFFICE
PAID THEIR INTERNS I KNOW
SENATE OFFICES TO THEIR INTENT
ADDITIONALLY I'D LIKE TO BRING
UP THE TOPIC ABOUT A LACK OF
ACCESSIBILITY AND REGARDING
INTERNSHIP. THE ISSUER INTENDS
ARE UNABLE TO FIND ACCESSIBLE
INFORMATION ABOUT
OPPORTUNITIES. THAT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK THANK YOU
FOR THAT IN GOMEZ. NEXT CALL
PLEASE. LINE NUMBER EIGHTY
THREE EXCUSE ME ON THE SIXTY
THREE YEAR LINE IS OPEN AT SIX
THIRTY. GOOD EVENING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MANY BILLING
ETCETERA WITH ACTION POLICY A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION WORKING
WITH GRASSROOTS BOARD- THE UP
WITH THE VOICE OF THE
HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED IN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WE
APPRECIATE THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION ON REFLECTING
SYSTEMIC CHANGE WITHIN- THE
SUBCOMMITTEE'S PURVIEW. PENSION
POLICY WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
THAT THE POOR ON ISSUE
SEVENTEEN AS RELATES TO THE
CHIEF EQUITY OFFICER WE BELIEVE
THIS POSITION IS A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION AND CAUTION THE
USE OF EFFORT. USE THE WILL-
CAUTIONARY F. TO YOU EQUITY A
BUDGET BUDGET BIRDS AFFECTING
TANGIBLE AND MEANINGFUL
SYSTEMIC CHANGE. AMPLE EARLIER-
LATE LAST YEAR THE STATE CALLED
FOR COMMUNICATIONS FIRMS TO
HELP OUT WITHOUT REACH WITHIN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND HARD
TO REACH POPULATIONS ONE OF
THOSE REQUIREMENTS WITH WHAT'S
FOR THE FIRM'S REVENUE TO
EXCEED A MILLION DOLLARS THESE
ARE FIRMS THAT DO NOT HAVE A
POLL FROM WHAT COMMUNITY COLOR
NEED OR HOW TO REACH OUT TO
THEM. AND WE HOPE THAT THE
ISSUES LIKE THESE CAN BE
ADDRESSED WITHIN THE PURVIEW OF
THE CHIEF EQUITY OFFICER WITHIN
COME OFF AS IT RELATES TO
PROCUREMENT. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU THAT IS AN EXCELLENT
POINT NEXT QUESTION. MY NUMBER
IS SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
SIX FIVE. HELLO THIS IS A WELL
RESPECTED AND I'M REPRESENTING
PRESERVATION SACRAMENTO ON THE
DGS AND REBUILDING. AND WE ARE
ASKING THAT THE COMMITTEE.
AMANDA ALTERNATIVE ONE TO
INCLUDE RENOVATION OF THE STATE
CAPITOL CROWN. THIS DISTRICT IS
THE SECOND MOST IMPORTANT STATE
HISTORIC AREA IN SACRAMENTO
NEXT AT THE STATE CAPITOL. WHY
BECAUSE THE LAND WAS DONATED BY
THE CITY IN NINETEEN TWENTY
SOMETHING. TO BUILD TWO NEW
OFFICE BUILDINGS FROM OUR
OFFICE SPACE. THIS DISTRICT WAS
COMPLETED IN NINETEEN TWENTY
NINE. AND NOT VALENTINE'S THE
UNREAL TREASURER'S OFFICE AND
THE LIBRARIAN COURTS BUILDING
TOGETHER AND PREVENTS ANY
OBVIOUS GEARING OF THE VIEW THE
STATE CAPITOL. WE MET WITH THE
CHANCE AND ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS. AND THEY HAVE AGREED
TO WAIT TO GET DIRECTION FROM
THE LEGISLATURE TO RENOVATE THE
FOUNTAIN. WE'RE ASKING PLEASE
RECORD YOUR COMMENTS AND
AMENDMENTS. YES WE'RE ASKING TO
ADD LANGUAGE THAT DIRECTS DHS
TO RESTORE THE FOUNTAIN
ACCORDING TO THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S INTERIORS STANDARDS AND
RESTORATION GUIDELINES AND
AUGMENTATION OF TWO MILLION
DOLLARS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR THAT JUST GENTLE REMINDER
PUBLIC COMMENT IS ONE MINUTE
NEXT CALLER. IF YOU'D LIKE TO
MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH
TONE PHONE ONE AND. ZERO LOOKS
LIKE WE HAVE A COUPLE OF QUEUED
UP IT'LL BE A MOMENT. PUBLIC
LINE NUMBER SIXTY ONE YEAR LINE
IS OPEN SIX ONE. YES THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS AMY
JENKINS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
CONSOLIDATE THE THREE CANNABIS
LICENSING AGENCY CENTURY
UNIFIED DEPARTMENT OF CANADA
CONTROL WE BELIEVE IT FURTHERS
THE GOALS OF LEGALIZATION AND
REGULATION WE ALSO WANT CHIPS-
WE EMPHASIZE OUR STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THE CENTRALIZED ENFORCEMENT
EFFORTS THAT WERE DISCUSSED AT
LENGTH EARLIER. IN THE HEARING
WE ARE HOPEFUL THAT
CENTRALIZING ENFORCEMENT WILL
RESULT IN MORE EFFECTIVE
COORDINATION TO ADDRESS
UNLICENSED ACTIVITY BETTER
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY AND DISCOURAGE
PARTICIPATION IN THE UNLICENSED
MARQUETTE WE ALSO STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR
SOCIAL EQUITY PROVISIONS WHICH
WEREN'T ADDRESSED TODAY. AND
ONGOING COMMITMENT TO ALLOCATE
FIFTEEN AND A HALF MILLION IN
FUNDING FOR LOCAL EQUITY
PROGRAMMING AND SUPPORT THAT WE
HIGHLIGHT THE NEED FOR FUNDING
RELATED TO THE WAIVERS AND
DEFERRALS FOR CANNABIS
OPERATORS- THAT OUR SOCIAL
APPLICANTS WHICH WAS ADVANCED
BY FEDERAL BRADFORD LAST YEAR.
ALL LAST THING I'LL POINT OUT
IS THAT WE HAVE OVER FOUR
HUNDRED MEMBERS THAT SUBMITTED-
RECOMMENDATION AND
COMPREHENSIVE RECOMMENDATIONS
AROUND AGENCY CONSOLIDATION AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE TO ADVANCE
SOME OF THOSE PRIORITIES ARE.
MOVING FORWARD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU FOR THAT NEXT
CALL PLEASE. ONE SIXTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN SIXTY. AN
OPERATOR HOW MANY CALLS WE HAVE
IN THE QUEUE. PRESENTLY THIS IS
THE LAST ONE THANK YOU. PLEASE
GO AHEAD SIXTY EIGHT CAN YOU
HEAR US. SIX IT IS DROPPED
SORRY BOUT THAT BACK TO YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I WANT TO
THANK OUR BUDGET STAFF AS WELL
AS OUR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEES AND ALL THE
PANELISTS THAT PARTICIPATED IN
TODAY'S. IN TODAY'S HEARING
APPRECIATE ALL THE FEEDBACK
COMMENTS CONCERNS AND QUESTIONS
AND LOOK FORWARD TO- NEXT STEPS
AND WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE THIS
THIS THE INFORMATIONAL HEARING
IS NOW ADJOURNED.